Eine pünktlich beginnende Mobile-Max-Sendung, Leute!
Also soweit nochmal kommen würde.
Dass wir das noch erleben dürfen. Wollen wir das Fenster eigentlich offen lassen?
Ja, total. Ganz dringend. Wir sollten das mal zumachen, oder?
Ist schon ein bisschen laut da draußen.
Wir haben gerade die Hubschrauber aufgelegt. Ich mach mal das Fenster zu.
Genau, die Ila stört.
Und Großdemo heute auch.
Großdemo ist auch? Echt, gegen was wird denn wieder gerade demonstriert?
Ich weiß nicht.
Lass doch den Vorhang dann gleich zumachen, dass keiner reinguckt. Wenn wir uns hier schon alle ausziehen.
Aber von draußen sieht man noch gar nichts.
Ich finde, Nackt-Podcasting hat einfach was. Man redet einfach freier. Das ist schon so.
Klebt auch besser.
Ja, willkommen. Robalmax, Ausgabe Nummer 47. Wir schreiten langsam voran, aber wir schreiten voran. Das ist schon mal was wert. Wir sind wieder drei, aber heute mal mit ohne Dennis. Der hat sein Motorrad-Abo, muss er irgendwie einlösen. Das ist ganz offensichtlich. Von daher mit ohne Dennis. Ich begrüße Hucke endlich mal wieder dabei.
Hallo.
Und ich begrüße Max auch endlich wieder zurück aus dem Urlaub. Was schön.
Hier war so total scheiße.
Und du warst in Spananien und hast ja irgendwie die Wampe gewärmt.
Total, das war ja total arm.
Das hat so viel Spaß gemacht.
Dann komm, bist du wieder da, geht das dann hier auch endlich mal los?
Ja, genau. Perfektes Timing. Da wurde es auch gerade so heiß, unangenehm heiß, langsam.
Hast du den letzten kalten Tag noch mitgekriegt?
Ja, ich bin hier eingekommen.
Es gab hier in Berlin ernsthaft 4 Grad und drei Tage später 29. Das ging echt überhaupt nicht mehr.
Wir sind da gestartet, so in Klamotten wie jetzt.
Also so Flip-Flops. Also nichts.
Das macht mich auch bei der Flugzeugssecurity viel, viel besser.
Dann wollen sie nur mal kurz in die Arschröße kutzeln und alles schon okay. Und dann hier durch die... Und dann im Lande an Flug, und das ging so in die Wolke rein. Die Wolke hört nicht auf, die Wolke hört nicht auf, die Wolke hört nicht auf. Und irgendwann sieht man da den Boden und man ist immer noch in der Wolke. Und, oh, furchtbar.
Ja, und du hattest nur dein iPad dabei?
Nein, ich hatte iPhone und iPad dabei.
iPhone und iPad.
Also iPhone, klar. Man hat mir dann vor Ort das erste Mal auch so eine SIM-Karte geholt.
iPhone, klar. Warum hast du nicht dein iPhone auch zuhause gelassen, man? Das wäre doch mal eine konsequente Ansage gewesen.
Wozu?
Na, das iPad ist doch der Computer des 23. Jahrhunderts.
Ja, aber nicht das Telefon des 23.
Wieso?
Da gibt es doch Skype drauf und Lautsprecher und ein Mikrofon.
Skype ging ja dann auch nicht über OMTS zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt? Wieso? Ist das wirklich jetzt erst, während du weg warst, ist das schon erst so kurz?
Sie haben eine neue Skype-Version rausgebracht. Die übrigens, wenn man sie auf iPhone 4 startet, meckert, dass sie nicht auf jailbreakten Geräten läuft. Also Skype hat irgendwann mal, die haben auf jailbreakten iPhones, massiv abgestürzt. Und anstatt ihre Software ein bisschen zu verbessern, haben sie eine Warnung davor geschaltet, so, äh, dieses Gerät, dieses Software läuft nur auf, und dann die Firmware-Version hingeschrieben, die iPhone-OS-Version hingeschrieben, und auf nicht jailbreakten Geräten.
Das steht da sozusagen als Text, aber sie sind nicht in der Lage, zu erkennen, dass sie auf einem jailbreakten sind?
Offensichtlich schon, weil diese Warnung kommt nur, wenn sie auf...
Wie stellen sie denn das fest?
Keine Ahnung. Naja, irgendwelche Dateien werden da verändert sein, oder?
So ein paar lose... Gitterfenster. Dass so ein Text durch den App Store gekommen ist.
Der Kuchen mit der Pfeile noch drinne, liegt noch da.
Collecting Evidence, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
So Progress Bar.
Und wenn jetzt Skype auf iPhone OS 4 startet, dann kommt diese Warnung, dass man sich darauf einstellen soll, dass es nicht läuft. Das finde ich schon mal relativ hart für so ein Programm, das gerade vor 4 Millionen erschienen ist.
Dann müsste ja das iPhone OS auch in der Lage sein, festzustellen, dass es auf einem Jailbreak-Dings ist.
Ich glaube, das könnten sie relativ einfach tun.
Ja, aber warum tun sie es da nicht einfach und versagen den Dienst? Das verstehe ich irgendwie. Ich meine, Security und Hacker-Initiative in allen Ehren. Und ich weiß, die kommen immer weit. Ich verstehe trotzdem nicht, warum man bei einer so kontrollierten Plattform nicht den Laden zugemacht bekommt. Das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht.
Sie könnten es abschalten. Ich meine, sobald eine Maßnahme ergriffen würde, würde eine Countermaßnahme ergriffen werden.
Ja, das ist mir schon bewusst. Sie kontrollieren wirklich alles von dem allerersten Boot-Moment an. Ich habe leider immer noch nicht geschafft, mir diesen damaligen Vortrag von der... Wie heißt die Bande noch gleich?
Dev-Team?
Genau.
iPhone Dev-Team.
Das iPhone Dev-Team nochmal anzuschauen. Ich war zwar da und habe mir den angeschaut, aber das war so komplex.
Auf dem Kongress damals.
Wir haben auch schon mal kurz darüber geredet. Seitdem habe ich mir das immer wieder auf den Desktop gelegt, so dass ich mal in Ruhe, aber diese Ruhe will einfach nicht kommen. Ich erinnere mich halt nur daran, dass sie an mehreren Stellen meinten, aber da haben wir ja Glück gehabt, weil sie da nicht verschlüsseln und so. Das machte auf mich eigentlich so den Eindruck, dass da nur noch wenige Türen zuzusperren sind. Um den Aufwand so weit zu kommen, so schwierig zu machen. Aber da sie es immer wieder innerhalb kürzester Zeit schaffen, bei jedem Release da einzusteigen, bin ich echt...
Also einen Unlock haben sie nach wie vor nicht hingekriegt fürs 3GS, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Also Jailbreak ja, aber einen Unlock für eine aktuelle Firmware, für Spaceband, gibt es glaube ich noch nicht. Also das Ding scheint Apple tatsächlich relativ erfolgreich zugekriegt zu haben. Vielleicht macht sich auch einfach niemand mehr die Arbeit, weil die Leute halt sagen, naja, also, weil es gibt ja Möglichkeiten an freier Einfachung reinzukommen. Also ich zum Beispiel persönlich oder du, wir legen ja auch keinen großen Wert auf einen Unlock, weil wir haben ja quasi einen offiziellen Unlock.
Also ich will halt kein Telefon haben, was ich erst hacken muss, damit ich es benutzen kann. Also würde Apple keine Unlock-Telefone verkaufen, ich hätte keins.
Ja, so, ganz einfach. Und das habe ich ja damals bei der ersten Generation noch anders gehandhabt. Da war ich auf diesen Unlock dann quasi angewiesen.
Da warst du noch jung. Da war ich noch jung und brauchte den Unlock.
Ja, und zwischendurch war es immer mal so ein bisschen, bis jetzt 3.1.3. gejailbreakt war und so. Das hat auch eine ganze Weile gedauert. Das hat jetzt gerade wieder Tempo aufgenommen irgendwie. Wahrscheinlich sind die Hacker über den Winter immer in Schockstarre oder so was. Vielleicht ist das Kaltblüter, der dann einfach nicht so schnell zu winken ist.
Also ich bin gespannt, was mit dem iPhone jetzt passiert, mit dem neuen. Also ob das Ding, ob sie sich wieder was Neues haben einfallen lassen. Das ist ja nun ganz offensichtlich eine komplett neue Generation in jeder Hinsicht. Und ja, ich bin nur gespannt.
Also beim iPad ja offensichtlich nicht. Das war ja schon gejailbreakt, ich glaube noch bevor es auf den Markt kam.
Da spricht man natürlich wiederum dagegen. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht sind die beiden sich sehr ähnlich.
Ja, gehe ich auch mal von aus, dass die eigentlich einfach im Wesentlichen dieselbe Hardware, also zumindest dasselbe Motherboard mit mehr Akku beim iPad.
Ja, das kann schon sein.
Vielleicht denken sich ja auch so viele sind es gar nicht.
Kann aber auch anders sein.
Apple hat ja auch wirklich, muss man ja sagen, so ein bisschen die Gründe zurückgenommen, warum man überhaupt einen Jailbreak... Also es ist, während ich eine Zeit lang quasi ohne Jailbreak nicht leben wollte, ist es jetzt so, naja, es geht ja. Also jetzt fängt langsam an, dieses Multitasking auch zu funktionieren und so was.
Na ja, damit du da halt eine Shell hast, ne?
Jetzt erzähl doch mal, wie dein Erlebnis war mit dem iPad unterwegs. Also ich meine, du hast das jetzt nicht so mega ausschließlich benutzt, aber du hattest zumindest keinen MacBook dabei.
Ich hatte keinen MacBook dabei.
Dann würde mich ja mal interessieren, du hattest auch kein 3G.
Ich hatte kein 3G, also ich hatte für das iPhone eine SIM-Karte gekauft, von Yoico heißen die. Da kann man für 3 Euro am Tag surfen. Später haben wir dann festgestellt, dass es bei Careformovil, also Carefor, das ist so ein riesiges Einkaufszentrum, so wie Real hier oder so was. Da gibt es SIM-Karten, es war allerdings ein bisschen spät schon im Urlaub und da hat sich das nicht mehr gelohnt, welche zu kaufen. Die bieten wohl für einen Tag 1 Euro pro Tag quasi dann 100 MBit-Treffig, was so im Urlaub ja reicht. Also zum Twitteren, Recherchieren und Googeln und Google Maps reicht das ja. Und ins iPad habe ich mir keine SIM-Karte gesteckt, weil so 3 Euro pro Tag wäre mir noch ein bisschen happig gewesen. Und darum habe ich das immer so im WLAN zwischendurch benutzt. Ich bin, ich wusste ja, also in der letzten Sendung saß ich ja hier und war so ein bisschen ratlos, was ich mit diesem iPad überhaupt anstellen sollte. Mittlerweile ist die Antwort für mich relativ klar, um all das zu tun, was ich bisher auf dem Computer getan habe.
Alles?
Fast alles. Also ich benutze mein MacBook zu Hause nur noch sehr selten.
Was hast du denn vorher gemacht? Du surfst eigentlich nur und liest Mail und guckst Porn?
Genau. Im Büro habe ich natürlich eine Entwicklungsumgebung und so was. Das ist jetzt dieser Arbeitsteil aus und vor gelassen. Aber ansonsten ist das tatsächlich noch ein bisschen Zittern und so was. Und ein bisschen rumsurfen, RSF-Bilder leer lesen, ein paar Videos gucken, so ein Zeug halt. Und das geht zu einem erstaunlich großen Teil sehr, sehr gut auf dem iPad. Also es geht nicht irgendwie auf dem iPad, sondern es geht ganz und gar hervorragend. Also zum Beispiel habe ich die Erfahrung gemacht, dass ich sehr, sehr gerne Texte schreibe, längere Texte auf dem iPad.
Mit Tastatur oder wirklich auf dem Glas?
Mit Klick-Tastatur, also mit Bildschirm-Tastatur. Längere Texte?
Was hast du so geschrieben?
Blog-Artikel.
Längere Texte? Längere Texte ist ja wohl eher so Diplomarbeit, würde ich mal sagen.
Längere Texte ist mehr als 140 Zeichen.
Welchen Blog-Artikel hast du denn darauf geschrieben?
Bei 343max.de einige.
343max.de, der erste Plug dieser Sendung. Max, Persönliches Blog.
Ja, ich blogge jetzt.
Eischreibmaschine. Du hast über das Schreiben geschrieben.
Ich habe über das Schreiben auf dem iPad geschrieben.
Den Copy und Paste, den hast du auch schon...
Den habe ich auch schon darauf geschrieben und ich habe irgendwie...
Laser auch?
Ja, der auch.
Ist das über Google?
Ja, das ist das... Ach, das war da.
Mit der Google Street View Geschichte.
Da hat sich irgendein... Hat sich der Hatz Chefredakteur über einen Tweet von mir aufgeregt. Und was ist der? Hatz?
Ja.
Aaz, Hannoverische Allgemeine Zeitung.
Hannoverische Allgemeine Zeitung. Und das fand ich sehr lustig, dass er mich so in einem Atemzug genannt hatte mit der FAZ und mit der Tatz. Und 343Max hat auch noch was Böses gesagt.
Sie wissen schon.
Ja, der mit dem... Wir werden es euch noch wünschen.
Und daraufhin habe ich dann nicht genötigt gefühlt, diese Antwort zu schreiben.
Echt, was haben die denn da geschrieben?
Ach, die hatten das einfach zwischendurch. Die haben einfach so das... Dass die ja auch Laserscanner einsetzen. Das war wirklich...
Das habe ich mal richtig geschrieben. Lasera-Scanner.
Na, ich habe mich... Die haben halt so das Wort Laser in den Raum geworfen und haben dann so, oh Gott, oh Gott, und wenn das jemand wüsste, ist da Laser eingesetzt werden.
Und was ist denn, wie alle anderen Firmen das auch schon seit Jahren machen?
Ja, aber wirklich auch so, was ist denn, wenn man das ins Auge kriegt? Was passiert, wenn das in einer Mikrowelle landet? Also wirklich, das war... Also wirklich so eine totale Panikmache.
Was ist, wenn diese Google Streetview-Cars einfach anfangen zu brennen? Was ist dann?
Was ist, wenn das alles Bomben sind?
Ach ja, das ist dann so... Ich meine, man kann ja über Google eine Menge diskutieren und sowas, aber so dieses... Ich glaube, das ist ein Niveau, da wäre sich selbst die Bild zu schade für. Und dann ist mir nämlich aufgefallen, dass wir das mit den Laserscannern wirklich damals, als die ersten Google Streetcars, Views-Cars, hier in Deutschland losgefahren sind, dass wir über diese Laserscanner schon gesprochen haben. Und ich habe das dann mal wirklich bei Google recherchiert und habe festgestellt, dass Google schon seit Jahren eine Webseite hat, auf der drauf steht, dass sie Laserscanner haben. Und dann heißt es so, der hat es quasi zu ihren unglaublich gigantischen Recherchefähigkeiten gratuliert, dass sie offensichtlich in der Lage sind, Google zu bedienen, mit anderthalb Jahren Verspätung. Und daraus jetzt eine große Seite 1-Meldung machen. Und deswegen hat er sich ein bisschen angepasst, ein gepisst Gefühl.
Okay, aber das Schreiben, das ging sozusagen easy auf dem iPad.
Das geht ganz hervorragend. Das liegt natürlich auch daran, dass es ein schickes neues Gerät und sowas, aber es geht besser als auf dem MacBook. Weil zum einen, man ist nicht so abgelenkt natürlich durch dieses Multitasking. Das ist böses, böses Multitasking. Also in dem Fall ist das fehlende Multitasking echt ganz gut. Man ist nicht so die ganze Zeit durch Twitter und weiße Teufel was abgelenkt. Ich habe das Ding wirklich immer dabei. Ich habe es im Urlaub immer dabei gehabt, weil wir haben oft im Zelt übernachtet und dann im Mietwagen. Da möchte man ja ungern so teure Unterhaltungselektronik irgendwie rumliegen haben, weil man weiß ja nicht, wann die Karre aufgebrochen wird. Und darum habe ich das einfach in meinen Rucksack gesteckt, weil das ist leicht genug, das merkt man im Rucksack echt nicht. Wenn man da noch eine 2 Liter Flasche Wasser dabei hat, dann ist die 2 Liter Flasche Wasser mit Abstand das schwerste da drin. Was bei einem MacBook nicht der Fall wäre. Und ich finde das Arbeiten echt geil da drauf. Ich habe ja diese Hülle, die man so aufklappen kann. Und wenn man auf der so ein bisschen rumditscht, die gibt es so ein bisschen nach. Das heißt, das ist nicht so ein hartes aufs Glas auftappen. Ich finde das Geräusch ganz geil. Es ist nicht so ein Klacka, Klacka, Klacka, sondern so tipptipp. Und man ist irgendwie, man hat immer alles im Blickfeld. Also es ist so dieses, man sieht die Finger, man sieht sich beim Tippen, man sieht den Text, den man schreibt. Wenn man etwas editieren will, braucht man nur den Finger so ein paar Millimeter zu bewegen. Man braucht nicht irgendwie die Hand zu nehmen und zu einer Maus bewegen, die sonst irgendwo liegt, sondern es ist immer alles direkt da und man tippt direkt. Man fasst den Text an, wenn man ihn bearbeiten will. Das ist wirklich eine tolle Sache. Es gab ja viel Kritik von wegen, auf dem iPad kann man überhaupt keine Texte schreiben. Was hat Apple da denn für einen Scheiß gemacht? Gerade auch von irgendwelchen Journalisten, die sagen, Schreiben ist die kreative Tätigkeit.
Ein haptischer Orgasmus.
Und ich muss sagen, man kann auf dem iPad sehr wohl auch längere Texte schreiben.
Also anhand der Fingerabdrücke und Schlierspuren auf deinem iPad kann man auch wirklich sagen, dass du das intensiv benutzt.
Das sieht man im Tastaturbereich.
Man sieht hier auch die Laptaste.
Jedes Pixel ist schon mal gedrückt. Oh, mein iPhone bootet. Ich mache hier mal das Experiment und mache mal in der Live-Sendung hier mal ein Software-Update. Ich will jetzt auch mal wissen, wie das hier ist.
Und jemand hat mir empfohlen, danke dafür, das App Simple Note. Und zwar ist das so ein Cloud-Syncing-Programm fürs iPhone. Das ist so ein Notizettel-Programm. Sieht sehr unscheinbar aus. Aber alles, was man da so eingibt, wird halt irgendwo in die Cloud gesynkt. Das habe ich mir auf dem iPhone installiert oder auf dem iPad installiert. Das heißt, alle Texte, alles, was ich hier auf dem iPad eingebe, habe ich immer sofort auf dem iPhone umgekehrt. Was ganz hübsch ist, weil man irgendwie so, man wird rausgeholt aus dem Gedanken.
Erwannote, das auch schon macht.
Erwannote, kann man da auch Texte beliebig eingeben?
Wie meinst du das? Beliebig?
Stimmt, da kann man auch Texte eintippen, oder?
Ja, vor allem. Aber du kannst auch Audio und auch Bilder da reinklicken. Beliebig? Also Evernote, mich stört ein paar Sachen an Evernote. Also bisher hat es noch keiner geschafft, mich von Things wegzukriegen. Und ich verstehe eben auch immer noch nicht, ich wiederhole mich. Es gibt immer noch nichts mit einer Outline, was SYNC'ed. Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, eine Outline macht einfach am meisten Sinn, wenn ich mir etwas notiere. Also wenn ich mir eine Liste von Dingen notiere, eine Struktur notieren will, dann will ich das nicht mit Tab und Sternchen machen und so weiter. Sondern will ich irgendwie korrekt eingeregte Hierarchien haben, die ich auf und zu klappen kann. Und ich begreife nicht, warum keiner in der Lage ist, zumindest einfach mal OPML als Basis zu nehmen. Und das kriegt man einfach in HTML rausgerendert. Das ist einfach überhaupt gar kein Problem. Aber ja, wie auch immer. Also es macht keiner. Und der erste Dienst, der das macht, den benutze ich vielleicht. Für meinen ganzen To-do-Kram benutze ich immer noch Things. Und bei den Notizen habe ich noch nichts gefunden.
Also dieses To-do-App quasi.
Ja, aber das ist einfach so organisiert, wie ich auch denke. Also das passt ganz gut. So mit diesen Areas und so. Ich weiß, es gibt auch noch andere Tools, die es auch machen. Und die kämen vielleicht auch noch in Frage. Aber dieses, alle zwei Wochen ein anderes To-do-App auszuprobieren, das ist auch, das macht einen wahnsinnig.
Also für Sinks war ich jetzt auf dem iPad dann doch ein bisschen geizig, muss ich sagen. Insbesondere, weil man ja, weil es dieses Cloudsyncing nicht kann, sondern eben, ja, und das ist nämlich, genau, ich war nicht so geizig, ich hab's mir angeschaut.
Ich find's, auf dem iPad versuchen die jetzt alle irgendwie auszusehen, wie so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Leder-Molluskiner. Ja, okay, meinetwegen ja, aber manchmal liebe ich auch einfach so diese, dieses nackte User-Interface, also wie mich bei Omni-Outliner, also auch denen, den ich die ganze Zeit benutze, immer noch völlig ankotzt, dass sie irgendwann mal dazu übergegangen sind, ihre Checkboxen selber zu malen, damit die halt schön aussehen und dann, wenn ich sie ausdrucke, auch genauso aussehen. Aber I don't fucking care, aber es sieht schön aus mit dem Ausdruck. Ich hätte einfach ganz gerne so eine Checkbox, wie alle anderen Checkboxen auf meinem Computer auch sind, damit ich meinen Hirn nicht jedes Mal umtrainieren muss, um eine andere Checkbox zu erkennen. Ich will nur eine Checkbox. Ich will, dass es blau ist. Weißt du, was ich meine?
Ja, so ein bisschen schon.
Eine Checkbox. Rich Texts und diesen ganzen Quatsch.
Genau. Wie war es bei dem 1984 Werbespot von Apple?
Das ist jetzt der Fanboy-Test, weil man den 1984 Text aufwendigt hat.
Ich kriege ihn tatsächlich nicht zusammen. Aber was der Big Browser da sagt?
Ich kann es dir googeln. Das kannst du aber auch auf deinem iPad selber mit deinen Wurstfingern machen. Dann kann ich dir noch mal was zu meinem Problem sagen. Ich habe es noch nicht ganz so intensiv ausprobiert, weil ich nicht einen Urlaub gemacht habe und bisher auch noch nicht bereit wäre, nur mit einem iPad zu verreisen. Aber ich habe schon gemerkt, die Dinge, die ich normalerweise tue, kann ich nicht mit einem iPad tun. Also schon, wenn ich so einfach meine Feats lese, wunderbar. Wenn ich ein paar Artikel nachschlage, wunderbar. Längeren Text lesen, auch super. Bücher lesen habe ich jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert. Dafür habe ich eigentlich nicht genug durchgehende Zeit. Bilder angucken, Filme angucken, alles ganz toll. Dafür ist es wirklich spitze. Und Spiele spielen auch super, habe ich ja schon mal gesagt. Aber da geht es dann los. Alles andere, was ich mache, ist eigentlich immer ein permanentes Juggling zwischen zehn Programmen. Also ich bin immer hier Copy-Paste, da Dreck und Drop, da was rein, aus dem Tweet, in den Browser, die URL, in die Outline, abspeichern, zack, ins Spreadsheet, wumm und so. Also ich habe halt immer mindestens zehn Programme laufen und mindestens zwei Drittel davon stehen in irgendeiner Form in Kommunikation, auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. Und das, ja, das leistet natürlich das iPad nicht. Das soll es ja auch gar nicht leisten, aber für mich ist an der Stelle eben, ist es das irgendwie nicht so, ne? Trotzdem glaube ich, dass das Ding sinnvoll sein kann. Wenn auch für mich jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade so direkt. Was ist denn mit dir eigentlich, Huckel? Willst du keins? Du hast ja auch 17 Zoll, ne? Du bist ja auch irgendwie... I've got the pixels.
Ja, also ich bin... Also prinzipiell... Ich hab ja das letzte Mal auch schon gesagt, ich würde ja meine Oma eins kaufen oder meine Familie und so weiter. Und ich würde das, glaube ich, auch so als Rumtragegerät statt... Also es gibt ganz oft so, wenn man mal so zu einem Meeting oder sich zu irgendeiner Besprechung verabredet, dann immer so die Überlegung, nehm ich jetzt meinen Computer mit, und wahrscheinlich brauch ich ihn eh nicht, aber was, wenn ich doch mal kurz auf den Browser gucken will? Davon auch klappen, so ist es nicht. Oder, also ich hab halt immer so diesen Zwiespalt, oder öfters diesen Zwiespalt, okay, reicht jetzt mein iPhone, oder nehm ich doch mein Computer mit, oder brauch ich eigentlich beides nicht? Und in solchen Situationen wäre, glaub ich, ein iPad schon genau das Richtige, wenn man sich halt schnell auch so mal Sachen aufschreiben will, mal ein Tweet loswerden, mal ordentlich brausen. Weil letztens war ich irgendwie auch mal so ein paar Tage weg und hatte gedacht, okay, ich komm nur mit dem iPhone klar, und da hab ich schon gemerkt, wenn man viel brausen will auf dem iPhone, ist das einfach ein bisschen zu fiddlig. Und da könnte ich mir halt schon so genau, was du auch sagst, im Urlaub irgendwie so ein Ding immer dabei haben. Also trotzdem muss ich sagen, will ich jetzt als Erstes erstmal das neue iPhone, bevor ich... Also iPad, nice to have, irgendwann hab ich bestimmt auch eins, aber das ist jetzt noch nicht so ganz dringend.
Ja, ich bin gerade aus meinen iPad-Erfahrungen heraus, und weil mein schwarzes MacBook hier einen langsam schleichenden Tod stirbt, brauch ich eigentlich ein neues MacBook. Mein Threshold, den ich mir eigentlich gesetzt hatte, für dann kauf ich mir auf jeden Fall ein MacBook, hat leider Apple noch nicht erreicht. Ich war maßlos enttäuscht, dass das letzte MacBook-Update immer noch kein 3G vorgesehen hat. Also da hab ich kein Verständnis für, muss ich sagen. Ich meine, es gibt echt so shitty Netbooks, die das haben. Das kann mir einfach keiner erklären, dass das irgendwie ein Problem ist.
Es gibt doch so merkwürdige Touchcomputer von Apple, die das haben.
Ja, ich meine, wenn sogar ein iPad für 500 Dollar das hat, dann kauft man sich so ein 2000 Euro, weißt du?
Ja, könnte man wirklich mal langsam machen, das stimmt schon.
Also ich meine, dieser SD-Card-Slot, der macht ja... Es gibt viele Leute, die finden ihn sogar gut, die mit Klicky-Kameras umherlaufen und das schnell mal reinstecken. Aber ich glaube auch, dass man zehnmal mehr Leute glücklich machen würde, wenn da einfach so ein SIM-Card-Slot drin wäre.
Ja, vor allem den würden sie ja irgendwo noch unterkriegen können. Da unten, wo Memory ist, da kann man auch eine SIM-Card reinbauen.
Ich meine, Micro-SIM.
Kriegen sie auch einen Display-Rahmen irgendwo unter oder sowas?
Ja, und dass sie die Antennen sowieso für verschiedene Sachen da re-usen haben, zeigen sie ja im iPhone. Ich meine, wenn im iPhone schon Wi-Fi, 3G und Bluetooth und was nicht alles reinpasst, dann sollte ja wohl in so einem MacBook auch eine Chance bestehen, das zu machen. Also es gibt keinen Engineering-Grund. Das ist ein reiner, ja, keine Ahnung, was da der Grund ist.
Sie haben es bisher noch nicht gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich ist der Grund LTE. AT&T würde sie einfach umbringen, wenn sie das auch noch tun würden.
So, jetzt packen wir das Netzwerk von AT&T noch auf der letzten Ebene.
Ja, AT&T sagt ihnen einfach, naja, ihr könnt das natürlich gerne machen, aber der monatliche Tarif, den wir dafür aufrufen würden...
Wie beim Preis von 8 iPads.
Und dann sagen sie halt ähnlich wie beim... Also jetzt beim iPad ist es doch kein AT&T. Also da gibt es zwar so ein Special Deal, aber es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie nur damit verfügbar.
Du kannst mit dem iPad auch T-Mobile in den USA benutzen.
Also das hier ist ja ein amerikanisches iPad mit.
Also klar wäre das natürlich ein Problem, weil auf dem Notebook benutzt man Internet ganz anders. Aber wenn man nicht an AT&T gebunden ist, relativiert sich das vielleicht auch schon wieder.
Ja, aber ich würde sagen, dass es auch Tethering gibt. Ich meine, wo ist denn da dann bitte der Unterschied? Es gibt keinen Tethering in den USA, aber es wird jetzt Tethering geben. In dem Moment, wo ich Tethering habe, ist es schon so, dass Sie ja den Traffic des Computers erwarten müssen. Das ist die Basis Ihrer Kalkulation. Warum soll denn der Computer nicht selbst die Bits senden? Warum muss es dann noch durch?
Aber wahrscheinlich ist AT&T die Antwort tatsächlich auf die Frage. Ich habe da echt kein Verständnis dafür.
Und es ist auch kein GPS in diesem MacBook. Ich bin einfach dagegen.
Aber Core Location funktioniert doch voll gut. Mit IP. Ehrlich, klickt mal hier in deinem Browser irgendwie.
Ja, das stimmt. Safari 5 hat das drin. Wenn man jetzt auf Maps, Google geht, dann hat man jetzt hier auch diesen kleinen Punkt, den man anklicken kann. Und probieren wir das mal aus.
Lokalisiert er das schon?
Ich glaube, der lokalisiert hier relativ gut. Er lässt sich bloß Zeit. Also bis auf den Hinterhof trifft er das hier.
Das machen sie schon ganz ordentlich.
Aber das geht nur in Gegenden, wo du in WLAN-Umgebung bist.
Ja, und grob dann ansonsten halt mit GeoIP-Fu und so. Das geht auch. Also die machen ja, glaube ich, schon auch GeoIP-Fu.
GeoIP-Fu? Wie meinst du das jetzt?
Ach so. Wenn du Internet hast, hast du eine IP. Und wenn du eine IP hast, kann man zumindest sagen...
Ja, aber wenn du eine IP über 3G hast, dann sagt die gar nichts aus, weil das in der Regel genattet ist und da eben keinerlei Location-Informationen...
Aber sie holen sich einfach dann eine externe IP.
Aber das ist ja genau der Punkt, ne? Um halt über diese GSM-Ortung zu machen. Also unabhängig von GPS, wenn sie nur auf GSM die Lokalisierung machen würden, dann würde es ja gerade Sinn machen, dass der Laptop das halt auch hat.
Das Problem nämlich...
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Naja, aber wahrscheinlich liegt es wirklich... Ihr habt es erwähnt, was gibt es für GSM-Anbieter in Amerika? Das ist AT&T und T-Mobile im Wesentlichen noch.
Richtig, es gibt nur genau die beiden. Und dann gibt es noch zwei mit CDMA. Das ist Sprint und Verizon.
Und auf CDMA wollen sie offensichtlich nicht, ansonsten hätten sie es wahrscheinlich mittlerweile mal gemacht. Dann hast du diesen einen großen, der am Rande seiner Kapazitäten offensichtlich arbeitet. Und hast einen total kleinen, der nur in Großstädten verfügbar ist und da vernünftig funktioniert. Und jetzt für eine Firma wie Apple, die rein in den amerikanischen Markt, also ich meine, die machen ja nie ein Produkt, was nicht innerhalb der USA verkauft wird. Also gibt es bestimmt aber nie so ein Major-Produkt, was nicht innerhalb der USA verkauft werden würde. Für die ist das einfach noch kein Markt. Die sagen sich einfach, solange das AT&T nicht auf die Reihe kriegt, das mit 3D-Durchsatz zu machen, bauen wir da kein Chip ein, weil das bringt ja nichts.
Ja, aber ich meine, erstens die Welt ist groß und zweitens... Das glaube ich nicht. Habt ihr sein Gespräch gesehen, diese volle Aufzeichnung auf der D8, auf dieser Konferenz, wo er da mal wieder befragt wurde? Ach, das war ja wieder mal ein extrem lichter Moment, wo er sich ja eigentlich, wo erst eine Woche später klar geworden ist, was er da eigentlich alles gesagt hat, weil er da eigentlich eine Menge schon angekündigt hat, was dann erst zur WWDC klar wurde, was das bedeutet. Also zum Beispiel, wie er da nochmal so auf Flurry eingehauen hat, diese Bude, die eben diese Analytics-Daten, also diese Usage-Daten aus den Applikationen rausholt. Also Programmierer holen sich diese Library rein und diese Library sammelt alle möglichen Daten und schickt das dann an Flurry, woran sie dann eben das 3GS-iPhone sozusagen erkannt haben, dass das schon im Einsatz ist, weil eben Apple-Entwickler Apps benutzt haben, wo das drin war, auf dem Campus. Und da kam dann sozusagen der neue Gerätetyp schon. Und er saß ja da und meinte, we went through the roof.
Diese Diskussion hab ich echt gar nicht so mitbekommen.
Und irgendwann werden wir auch wieder mit Ihnen reden, aber nicht heute. Er war wirklich gepisst so. Und dann hat er da sehr drauf rumgeritten, auf diesen wir wollen niemanden erlauben, da sozusagen zu spionieren. War auch richtig zickig. Und eine Woche später, ich greife jetzt so ein bisschen hier vorweg, hat sich das jetzt mit der Vorstellung des neuen iPhones, auch neue SDK-Lizenzbedingungen, und das ging ja schon ordentlich rum, diese News, dass eben AdMob, oder sagen wir mal so, sie schließen alle diejenigen, die eben analytische Daten einsammeln. Ne, ich muss nochmal alles anfangen. Es gab ja schon vorher die Einschränkung, wenn Werbung gemacht wird, oder wenn da ein Werbeelement ist in dem Programm, dann darf da nicht Daten verwendet werden, die nur für die Werbung eingesammelt werden.
Also zum Beispiel keine Location-Daten, nur für die Werbung eingesammelt werden.
Genau, wenn ihr ab und an ganz andere Sachen macht. Und das ist ja schon ein sehr schwieriges Feld, das dann genau zuzuordnen, aber so sind die Bestimmungen. Und das haben sie jetzt nochmal dahingehend verschärft, dass eben diese ganzen Analyse-Daten gar nicht gesammelt werden dürfen, wenn die Firma ein Competitor ist von Apple. Und da AdMob jetzt Google gehört.
Sie haben explizit gesagt, wenn es ein Competitor ist?
Wenn die die Formulierung gerne nochmal genau raussuchen.
Ich dachte, dass da irgendwo Independent drin stand oder so was.
Ich habe die Formulierung jetzt nicht genau im Kopf, aber ich suche die gerne nochmal raus, weil die war ja relativ explizit. Wir schlagen nach im Buch der Waffen. So, da ist die Formulierung. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen lang, um das komplett vorzulesen. Ich schaue mal kurz durch. Sag doch mal jemand was kluges zwischendurch.
Ich kann auch mal zwischendurch hier von Reader ein bisschen erzählen, oder? Oder ist das jetzt zu falsches Thema gerade?
Ja, ne, Tim hat es doch gleich bestimmt.
Oh man, mach mich fertig. Also, Sie haben hier sozusagen... Wie formulieren Sie das? Also, darf nur ein unabhängiger Advertising Service Provider machen, dessen Primary Business eben das Liefern von Mobile Ads ist. Und als Gegenbeispiel führen Sie an. Advertising Service Provider owned by or affiliated with a developer or distributor of mobile devices, mobile operating systems or development environments other than Apple would not qualify as independent. Also Adobe und Google, also es ist sehr explizit und bei AdMob sind die irgendwie auch gleich komplett tot umgefallen, weil ich meine, die dürften echt eine Party gehabt haben die letzten Wochen so, wir sind super und so und dann hat Apple Iads angekündigt, ja, können wir auch hier auf der Google IO und so, Labri, kein Problem, mach mal mit und so. Und jetzt diese Klausel, die im Prinzip sagt, naja, ihr dürft gerne noch Werbung einblenden, aber ihr dürft halt keine Analytics mehr zurückschicken. Und da halt Google, ich meine, die basieren darauf. Ja, das ist schon irgendwie ein bisschen so Teil ihres Systems, aber sie wollen sich halt jetzt einfach nicht mehr ihre neuen iPhones vom Campus wegscannen lassen, da ist ja, kann man durchaus nachvollziehen. Ich meine, jetzt regen sich natürlich wieder alle drüber auf, so, aber es ist halt die alte Leier, es ist Apples Produkt, die Apps sind Produkte, sind Teil dieses Produktes und Apple definiert dieses Produkt, soll sich echt keiner wundern, wenn die Bedingungen nicht so sind.
Also ich stecke da noch jetzt in der Diskussion, da ist noch nicht tief genug drin, um da wirklich laut irgendwas zu sagen, aber naja.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob es da halt Antitrust, also wie das jetzt in den nächsten Monaten einfach so jetzt auch so mit Klagen und so weiter.
Die ist ja schon eingereicht, oder?
Ja, da kommen bestimmt noch mehr. Ich bin nur mal gespannt, wie die ausgehen halt so, also was da so dann die Gerichte sozusagen darüber urteilen, wenn die da überhaupt Ahnung genug dafür haben, um das irgendwie qualifiziert beurteilen zu können. Also ob Apple da einen Dämpfer irgendwo mal kriegt oder ob es da halt sozusagen auch weiter so...
Das wird auch sehr gespannt. Ehrlich gesagt, ich rechne nicht mit sehr vielen Dämpfern. Wobei, wo sie mal wirklich eins auf die Nuss kriegen sollten, das so was so iTunes betrifft und so.
Wie inwiefern? Meinst du, dass Apple gerichtlich dazu gezwungen wird, werden sollte endlich mal iTunes X werden?
Das wäre in der Tat auch mal ein Schritt da vorne. Was doch den Zugang von Musik auf dieses Gerät z.B. betrifft. Das halte ich schon für sehr fraglich, ob das nicht durchaus auch erzwingbar wäre, dass Apple eine Möglichkeit bieten muss, dass auch andere Programme den Musik-Content dieses Gerätes bespielen können müssen.
Von so iPad und iPhone?
Übrigens auch den Podcastbereich, um den ich ehrlich gesagt noch mehr Interesse hätte. Da wäre ich schon mal extrem glücklich, wenn sich da was tun würde. Nur mit iTunes braucht iTunes einfach mal Konkurrenz.
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, auf das iPad ohne iTunes eigene Inhalte draufzuspielen, bzw. ohne Rechner.
Ohne iTunes geht es nicht, genau.
Also es ist sowohl Musik, als auch Videos, als auch Fotos. Wirklich alles durch die Bank weg, alles geht über iTunes drauf. Und das war so etwas, was mich im Urlaub doch reichlich genervt hat, dass es zwar theoretisch diesen SD-Card-Reader für das iPad gibt, mit dem man Fotos von seiner Kamera da drauf kriegen kann, aber die Fotos von meinem iPhone kriege ich ums Verrecken nicht ohne Mac dazwischen aufs iPad drauf.
Gibt es keine Möglichkeit.
Also ich könnte sie per Mail verschicken.
Oder Hocker benutzen.
Eine Anwendung, die beim Chaos Radio Express über Android zur Sprache kommt. Gibt es aber auch fürs iPhone.
Und die ermöglicht auch vom Rechner ohne iTunes Daten. Kannst du dir noch mal das Chaos Radio anhören?
Mach ich, mach ich.
Ich habe diese Sendung sogar gehört. Man könnte das iPhone mit dem Foto-USB-Adapter anschließen. Wie eine Kamera.
Den hat doch niemand.
Den kann man aber kaufen.
Für 29,95?
Der ist total ausverkauft.
Ach so, in Deutschland?
Nein, auch in Amerika. Das ist ja auch sehr aufwendig. Zahl gehört? 190 Dollar.
Bitte. So viel zum Thema, das ist alles teuer, was Apple da verkauft. Ihr könnt wahrscheinlich auch ganz andere Zahlen aufrufen.
Ich finde aber 29 Dollar für so eine iPhone-Socke auch schon sportlich.
Also gehen würde es, das ist ja auch bewusst, aber du hast so einen Teil nicht und von daher geht es nie anders.
Ja, außerdem könnte ich mir auch einen schöneren Weg... Ich wusste aber...
Ich kann mir auch schönere Wege vorstellen.
Ich wusste nicht, dass es geht, wusste ich nicht. Ich dachte...
Zum Beispiel dieses Lightweight-Tool Image Capture, was ich ja immer noch sehr gerne mag, zum Daten reinholen. Also wenn es so eine Lightweight-Variante gibt, zum Musikfoto und so weiter hin und her schieben, das wäre es ja schon mal. Und dieses iTunes-OS könnte dann einfach mal rausbleiben. Ich lasse das auch immer an, auch beim Suspenden und so. Ich traue mich das gar nicht mehr auszumachen. Jedes Mal, wenn es startet, ist dann erst mal dein ganzer Rechner blockiert, bis er da alles eingelesen hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob das mit einer SSD ist. Das ist wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen entspannter.
Wahrscheinlich schon. Wie?
Was? Ich habe eine große Musikbibliothek, Videos drin, Fubar drin, Tralala drin. Dann irgendwie klickst du auf den Store oder... Weiß schon. Was bleibt einem anderes übrig? Also in der Hinsicht kann man sagen, das Songbird, was ja jahrelang eine totale Katastrophe war, wird jetzt tatsächlich langsam benutzt. Ich habe ja immer diesen Test mit einer großen Bibliothek aus natürlich lizenzfreier Musik hier und da mal gesehen und die mal ausprobiert und reingeworfen. Und Songbird hat das jahrelang gar nicht überhaupt geschafft, mehr als 50.000 Tracks zu speichern und zu verwalten. Aber das letzte Mal, als ich es probiert habe, hat es das zum Beispiel anstandslos gefressen.
Ich habe mich immer wieder ganz furchtbar über die RSS-Feed-Lesefähigkeiten von iTunes aufgeregt. Und zwar, ich habe mir zuhause so etwas gebastelt, um Videos zu konvertieren für das iPad. Da habe ich gedacht, wäre auch eigentlich ganz praktisch. Man legt einfach einen Ordner an. Also das wollte ich auf dem Server haben. Und alles, was bereits konvertiert ist, liegt in diesem Ordner drin. Und dann mache ich mir einen RSS-Feed daraus und synchronisiere den mit iTunes. Und dann habe ich es ja immer auf dem iPad drauf. Finde ich eigentlich ganz praktisch. Muss ich 2 synchronisieren und sowas. Und dann war ich irgendwann im Urlaub und hatte einen Film, den ich 100%ig...
Piepst.
Bin ich das?
Das kann auch ich sein.
Habt ihr etwa nicht den Airplane-Mode an?
Nein. Ich bin ja hier gerade dabei, mein Telefon in die 22. Jahrhundert zu bringen.
Ah, hier guck mal, da wo einer gerade sagt, die haben das mit dem iPod in einem Autohin verbaut. Da kann ich auch noch was zu erzählen, ja. Ne, ich bin ja nach Krakau gefahren, ne, mit dem Auto und hatte mir irgendwie mit dem iPhone hier irgendwie mit Offline-Maps irgendwie gigabyteweise... Ah, okay.... Polenkarten runtergeladen.
Wie Offmaps.
Genau, Offmaps oder Offline-Maps, wie auch immer, damit ich dann ohne GSM halt schön trotzdem GPS navigieren kann. Und da, also da hatte auch dann ein Beifahrer noch ein iPad dabei, der das Gleiche gemacht hat praktischerweise. Und ja, so mit iPad im Rechner, da hat jetzt eigentlich nur noch so dieses Dock gefehlt zum raufstecken, ja, und dann wäre das so das perfekte Navigationssystem. Also ich fand das, ich fand ja, also das, das war total das coole Feature, muss ich da sagen. Offline-Maps und so ein iPhone bzw. iPad im Outdoor und am besten dann noch so in die Mittelkonsole geflanscht.
Da kann ich nur wieder dieses Video empfehlen mit dem Velcro-Strips.
Muss ich mal kurz ausziehen, mir ist zu warm hier im Moment.
Was willst du denn noch ausziehen, Huckel?
Nein, das ist nicht die Haut vom Körper.
Peeling nennt man das.
Die Brustbehaarung abrasieren.
Ja, es ist Sommer, Huckel. Da haben wir dich mit den Themen hier ganz schön ins Schwitzen gebracht, da wissen wir auch mal, wie es den Hörer geht.
Herr Sauner hier.
Vielleicht noch mal zurück zum... Oder wolltest du gerade noch irgendwas zu Ende fällen?
Nein, iPad im Auto, toll.
iPad im Auto, toll, genau. Ich habe mal dieses Video, das ist auf Vimeo. Habt ihr bestimmt gesehen, habe ich getwittert. Wo jemand einfach mal... Ja, Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich mich geoutet. Also ich twitte runter. TimpredLove, folgen sie mir jetzt. Da kommen dann coole Videos, zum Beispiel dieses tolle Video. Ich kann das auch gerne hier noch mal raussuchen. Da suche ich mal nach Vimeo, iPad und Velcro. Dann dürfte das wahrscheinlich gleich auf dem Bildschirm erscheinen. So sieht es aus.
Ach, jemand, der da sein iPad am Lenkrad angepappt hat? Oder was war das?
Genau.
Auch schön, ja.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob der Ton jetzt hier auch gerade mit einfließt. Ich vermute mal nicht, aber der ist auch nicht so interessant. iPad plus Velcro gleich Herzchen. Und da machen wir ja auch gleich mal schön voll schrien.
So, HTML5 schon.
Der dreht einfach das iPad auf den Rücken und macht sich da so zwei Velcro-Strips dran. Und zwar macht er an das iPad diese flauschige Seite ran.
Ah, damit die keinen Dreck sammelt.
Damit die keine Dreck sammelt, die flauschige sammelt.
Die hat keine Häkchen drin.
Die Häkchen-Seite kommt dann jetzt hier zum Beispiel ans Auto.
Aber wenn da der Airbag rauskommt, ne?
Wenn da der Airbag rauskommt, ist eh alles vorbei.
Sollten sie mal testen, ob das Glas das aushält.
Nee, aber das ist doch genau das, was du machst. Dann kann man das iPad einfach direkt ans Armaturenbrett ranmachen. So und jetzt haut er sich sozusagen überall in der Wohnung so ein Strip hin. Anstatt des Bildes dann halt iPad als Bilderrahmen. Und dann geht man erstmal schön durch die Wohnung. Und dann kann man sich die ganzen Fotos, die man sowieso schon kennt, alle nochmal anschauen. Oder dann halt irgendwie auch noch ans Fenster machen. Und dann hat man da irgendwie seine Weather-Up. Welche ist das hier eigentlich? Die von Weather Channel. Ich hab auch noch nichts richtig gefunden, was mich so richtig überzeugt hat. Oder dann halt in der Küche, sehr naheliegend. Wobei das iPad jetzt direkt neben dem Herd, das ist glaube ich eher eine schlechte Idee, aber übers Bett, so an die Decke und dann halt auch noch hier, das ist ja auch speziell für dich, direkt aufs Motorrad.
Ja, mit so Klett aufs Motorrad.
Ja, da dachte ich mir auch, ob das mal reicht. Aber so ein richtig fetter Strip, der hält natürlich auch gar nicht.
Im Zelt, im Zelt hätte ich es gern gehabt. Weil beim Videogucken abends im Zelt, da kann man...
Genau, dass es mal so an die Decke hängt. Also fand ich auf jeden Fall eine schöne Idee. Und ob das wirklich am Motorrad hält, das kannst du ja mal ausprobieren. Aber nicht mit meinem iPad.
Was mir noch so ein bisschen fehlt hier, bei diesen iPad- und iPhone-Geschichten, ist ja irgendwie noch so, das fühlt sich ja alles so ein bisschen wie Star Trek an. Also hier hast du irgendwie so deinen Trikorder in der Hand und so weiter und kannst so ein bisschen... Kannst Wetter gucken, Regenradar und so weiter.
Hey, Wetter gucken!
Aber ich hätte ja gerne noch so Aufstecksätze, sowas wie einen Geigerzähler oder irgendwie so, weißt schon, hier so Sensoren.
Ja, ist doch viel zu wenig.
Ja, sowas gibt es echt wirklich zu wenig, dass man hier wirklich so Trikordermäßig unterwegs ist.
Alkoholmesser.
Das wundert mich übrigens sehr, dass es das noch nicht gibt, weil wenn ihr euch erinnert, letztes Jahr war ja eine der großen neuen Nachrichten, war ja, dass das ganze SDK jetzt eben auch noch erweitert wird auf Hardware-Erweiterungen. Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe schwer damit gerechnet, dass da jetzt eine Flut von Zeug kommt, aber offensichtlich sind die Lizenzbedingungen...
Na, wir haben ja...
So krass...
Wir haben ja auch mal... Nee, also wir haben da auch mal geguckt so, weil wir wollten da eigentlich auch mal irgendwie was bei Artcom ausprobieren, ja. Und dann liest du da halt irgendwie, ja, dann musst du dich erstmal mit denen in Verbindung setzen und denen erstmal die Hose runter. Was willst du denn überhaupt machen? Und dann entscheiden sie überhaupt, ob sie das überhaupt wollen. Und bevor du da... Also du hast halt erstmal so von vornherein halt auch kaum Sicherheit, dass jetzt das, was du da bauen willst, überhaupt auch dann von Apple dann später mal...
Also sozusagen, wer den App Store für Hitler hält, sollte das mal sich antun.
Ja, also es wirkte schon sehr... Also wenig ermutigend, da jetzt mal nach vorne zu gehen und mal einfach was zu machen, weil du musst halt vorher erstmal mit denen telefonieren und dann zählen und dann Hose runter und wie viele Leute und wer und was und warum. Und statt mal zu sagen, hier Jungs, das ist die API, baut noch was Cooles. Sagt Bescheid. Also hier, weißt du, die Musik auch hatten, diesem Gitarrenverstärker und so. Also, das waren jetzt wirklich auch so die einzigen Highlights, die man in der Hinsicht mal irgendwie oder der Blutdruckmesser gut... Also kannst du an einer Hand abzählen, die Beispiele, ne?
Ich weiß vor allen Dingen nicht, ob irgendwas von dem jemals was geworden ist. Also von diesem Gitarrenverstärker habe ich nie wieder was gehört.
Ja, das ist auch ein bisschen gefloppt auf jeden Fall, weil die da... Aber glaube ich, ist die auf den Markt gekommen? Ja, schon, aber ich glaube, das war dann selbst verschuldet, eher, dass sie... keine Ahnung, Preistag oder so. Auf jeden Fall gibt es da, finde ich, viel zu wenig Hardware-Accessories mit cooler Spielerei. Blutdrucksendenso ist ein Anfang, aber ich will einen Geigerzähler, ich will einen Hygrometer, ich will irgendwie... Ich will halt meinen iPhone-Trikorder haben. So, jetzt ist es raus. Ja. Apple Deutschland.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so.
Apple Deutschland hat da wenig.
In vielen Jahren, wenn man nachts von der Polizei angehalten wird, darf man wahrscheinlich auch immer ein iPod reinpusten.
Pusten Sie mal in mein iPhone.
Weißt du, was die Leute da machen? Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz erzählen. Weißt du, was die Leute machen, um das zu hacken und zu umgehen, dass sie bei Apple immer die Hose runterlassen müssen, um Hardware zu bauen? Jetzt haltet euch fest. Sie benutzen das Audio, um seriell über Audio, also Hardware, mit dem Audioport, seriell mit der absprechen zu lassen, weil du kommst halt an das Audio und so weiter ran und dann spricht ein serielles Protokoll in Audio.
Diese Square-App, das funktioniert doch so.
Das ist ein Kreditkartenleser.
Da gibt es auch eine Library für genau diesen Zweck, dass du halt Serial-over-Audio sprichst.
Der andere Vorteil ist, dass es universell ist. Das würde dann auch am Android funktionieren. Da brauchst du eine Blip, passt ein bisschen an.
Ist diese Square in irgendeiner Form erfolgreich? Ich habe das noch so richtig nicht wahrgenommen.
Ich habe es mir auf dem iPad und iPhone installiert, um mir das mal anzugucken. Das ist im Augenblick noch alles sehr, sehr barebones. Irgendwie kann man ja, wenn man in Amerika wohnt, sich auch schon diese Box holen. Die rollen das halt so relativ langsam aus. Ich finde die Idee aber schon sehr, sehr geil. Also die Idee ist echt großartig.
Es muss auch mehr von diesen ich will jetzt mal spontan bezahlen Dinger geben, weil irgendwie das ist auch echt so. Es ist auch komisch, wie wenig Leute, oder wie viele Leute, immer noch dieses PayPal- und Google-Checkout, wo du dann erstmal noch anrufen musst und dich verifizieren lassen.
Anrufen?
Ja, bei Google-Checkout musst du dir eine Telefonnummer angeben, dann wirst du anrufen und musst es verifizieren. Oder hier, wenn du Musik kaufen willst, das ist unfassbar, dass du in 2010 immer noch so behindert wirst, wenn du Geld ausgeben willst für Musik.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen, was ich bei meinem Gedanken über Flattr, das habe ich nicht mit aufgeschrieben, aber ein HTML5-Pay-Element. Also so, wie man Videos angucken kann, ein HTML-Element zu schaffen, mit dem man Inhalte bezahlen kann. Finde ich total geil. Und wo sich dann irgendwelche Visa oder irgendwelche großen Kreditkarten anbieter, die sollen sich da hinten dranhängen und dass man dann direkt mit Browser-Unterstützung und alles secure und bezahlen kann, gefälligst. Das wäre doch mal...
Das wäre eine Maßnahme. Ich versuche ja hin und wieder mal Musik zum Beispiel online zu kaufen und jedes Mal denke ich mir, warum macht ihr es mir eigentlich so schwer? Also da gibt es irgendwie junge Bands, die dann irgendwie CD auf Amazon 40 Euro kostet, mit zwei Wochen Lieferzeit und auf ihrer Webseite, sie können noch einfach einen Button dahin machen, verdammt. Ich klick, ich kauf's. Aber nicht mal das, also manchmal. Aber naja, gut, ist noch eine andere Thematik, dieses Online-Payment, aber...
Ja, wobei wir ja beim Thema werden. Ich wollte zwar eigentlich immer noch MacBook-Beratungen haben, aber vielleicht verschieben wir das einfach noch mal nach hinten.
Erst muss ja das Geld zusammenkommen für...
Ja, das natürlich auch. Aber wie gesagt, mein... Vielleicht erwähne ich es doch noch mal. Also mein MacBook ist am Sterben und... Also es ist wirklich am Sterben, es ist irgendwie echt nur noch am Lüften. Ich habe das Ding schon komplett gereinigt und ich habe vor allem so einen total obskuren Fehler. Und ich bin wirklich... Ich zweifle mittlerweile an mir, weil es mir irgendwie nicht gelingt, so richtig einzuschätzen, was eigentlich der Grund ist. Ich vermute mal, ich habe ein Mainboard-Problem. Ich habe bloß irgendwie immer so wenig Zeit, dass ich das nicht wirklich testen kann. Ich müsste jetzt noch mal meine Festplatte immer extern anschließen und das irgendwie über Firewire eine Weile betreiben und schauen, ob ich denselben Effekt habe. Das werde ich auch noch mal tun.
Welche Effekte?
Der Effekt ist, dass ich irgendwie Frises habe. Also so komplette UI-Frieses mit irgendwie Maus bleibt stehen und umso mehr RAM benutzt wird und also sprich umso mehr geswappt wird eigentlich. Das scheint schon wirklich extrem mit der Platte zusammenzuhängen. Also meine Theorie ist die, dass mein Mainboard einfach ein Problem hat direkt beim Platteninterface.
Dazu muss man aber sagen, dass Tim nicht ein DAU-User ist, sondern ein GAU-User. Der größte anzunehmende Unfall. Nein, Quatsch, nicht Unfall, aber User für Computer, der installiert halt auch alles, probiert auch alles aus und benutzt das halt auch natürlich profimäßig total am Limit. Und es gibt so in der Zeit, wo ich Tim kenne, auf jeden Fall diverse Beobachtungen, wie die Hardware in seinen Händen auch zerbröselt, quasi bei der Benutzung.
Ich bin für meine Burgonen-Energie bekannt.
Das ist echt der Härtetest, wenn du mal Hardware baut und dann mal einen Durability-Test haben wolltest. Schick das mal an Tim. Und ich staune dir sowieso, dass du mit diesem Plastik-Macbook so lang überhaupt klarkommst, weil ich halte dir, also ich würde das ja auf gar nicht anfassen wollen, diese Plastik-Computer, die taugen noch nichts. Langsam, klein.
Ich habe vorher einen Powerbook G4 gehabt, die letzte Generation Powerbook G4, und das war mit Abstand der schlechteste Macintosh, den ich überhaupt jemals gehabt habe. Also ich habe noch nie so viel Ärger gehabt mit einem Mac wie mit dem Teil. Ich erinnere an diesen Soundbug, der da irgendwie monatelang war, wo sich da irgendwie die ganze Zeit dieses Echo da eingefangen hat. Du hast da auch recht. Und das ist mir, der ich irgendwie Audio mache. Und dann bei Präsentationen, weißt du? Stehst du da mit deinem Powerbook, ja, hier Präsentation, und auf einmal macht dieses Teil irgendwie diesen Echo-Bug und zerstört einem einfach alles. Wie peinlich ist das bitte? So, und dann, ich meine, ich mag dieses MacBook, weil es einfach kompakt ist und weil es alle Interfaces hat. Was eben die ganzen Nachfolger davon so nicht richtig hatten.
Also was du so brauchst, ist so Digital Audio in und out?
Zum Beispiel, das habe ich viel benutzt, wobei das jetzt nicht mehr ganz so die Hauptrolle spielt.
Wegen iMac?
Weil ich es unterwegs mache ich es derzeit eh mit USB und hier habe ich jetzt auch eine neue Lösung, also hier im Studio habe ich das jetzt auch über IP an meinem Mesh-Pult angeschlossen. Aber davon abgesehen, Firewire war nötig, dann kann man ja dieses 13 Zoll raushaben, Firewire sein gelassen und so, das fand ich irgendwie auch nicht so schön. Wie auch immer. So, und jetzt dachte ich mir halt, ok, baut jetzt einfach nochmal GSM ein in dieses Teil und drauf mir irgendwie das neue rechts unten Modell. Trotzdem, ich finde die neuen MacBooks eigentlich cool, aber jetzt kann ich mich nicht entscheiden zwischen dem 13 Zoll und dem 15 Zoll. Ich kann mich einfach nicht entscheiden.
Na, wie bist du denn mit dem Formfaktor glücklich?
Na ja, in einem Betracht der Tatsache, dass es doch häufiger eigentlich hier auf dem Tisch steht, als wirklich unterwegs zu sein und man ja auch mit dem iPhone weniger den wirklichen Mobilbedarf hat. Früher war das für mich noch ein Argument, ja? Ein Laptop kleiner, weil ich den eigentlich fast immer dabei hatte. Dann kam irgendwie das iPhone, ich hatte nicht immer dabei, sondern meistens sogar nicht dabei. Verlasse das Haus ohne Computer, das ist wirklich absurd. Ja, das hätte ich jetzt seit ich Laptops habe, seit ich Laptops habe, da haben die mich eigentlich immer begleitet. Seit wann habe ich Laptops? Mein erster eigener Laptop war ein Powerbook, wie hieß das Teil? Powerbook G3. Und zwar das erste. Nee, Quatsch, Blödsinn. Das Wall Street? Vergiss es. Nein, nein, nein. Wie hieß denn das Teil nochmal?
Mit dem umgedrehten Abfüll oder das davor noch?
Dieses fette mit dem Subwoofer im Deckel.
Warte, ich mach Mac-Tracker auf.
2400.
Ja, ich hab Mac-Tracker hier.
Ich guck mal bei everymac.com. Das ist ja meine Source. Kann ich sehr empfehlen. Hab ich auch schon mal empfehlt. everymac.com.
Ich bin schon da. Und du hast einen G3, oder was? Also November 1997.
Da war ein 604 drin.
Ein 604, das ist...
Das war der Vorgänger vom G4. Das war der 603.
Das war das letzte Modell, bevor die G3s rauskamen.
Ach so, das letzte Modell bevor. Okay, dann war es doch hier bestimmt die... 603e gibt's. 1995. Macintosh Powerbook 5300 Series.
Genau. Das 5300.
Mac Tracker, das?
Das fette Teil. So, seitdem bin ich irgendwie... Oder 3400er?
Also es gibt davor noch ein 3400c. Auch. Sieht ähnlich aus.
Ich komme gerade total...
Das ist ein bisschen runder.
Oder? Ja, ist runder. Gucken wir mal hier. Was hat das für General? Das hat einen 603EV.
Ich weiß echt nicht mehr, was ich für einen Computer hatte. Ich drehe die echt durch. 3400er.
Aber gut, dann ist das doch eigentlich schon klar, oder? Du willst eigentlich einen 15 Zoll.
3400C. Das war genau mein Teil. Nee, ich weiß nicht, ob das so klar ist, weil... Es ist so, wenn ich jetzt unterwegs bin, dann habe ich meistens sowieso meinen Rolli dabei. Und dann ist das sowieso alles schon viel zu schwer, weil ich nämlich dann auch immer, wenn ich mit dem Computer unterwegs bin, dann habe ich auch all diese Adapter dabei, Kabel, Netzteil, VGA, DVI-Adapter, sonstiger Dünnschiss, den man halt immer noch so mit rumschleppt, so Computer, da braucht man ja, im Prinzip braucht man ja für ein Laptop immer noch so einen Werkzeugkoffer, weil die halt auch nicht so richtig mit dem Akku so lange halten.
Ich erinnere mich.
Das ist natürlich jetzt auch wieder anders. Also das ist für mich sehr schwer. Wo ich total Angst davor habe, ist, dass die Dinger anfangen zu lüften. Und ich habe von verschiedenen 13 Zoll Leuten gehört, dass die Teile lüften. Und Lüfter, ich meine, dieses Teil lüftet nur noch. Das geht überhaupt nicht mehr. Und das ist irgendwie nicht so...
Also ich würde ja sagen, hier 15 Zoll hat ja zum Beispiel, erstens hast du in und out zwei Buchsen, also nicht diese Unified.
Ja, das ist ein Argument.
Das ist ein Argument, finde ich.
Aber der Akku hält länger bei dem kleineren. Das finde ich ja irgendwie ein bisschen frech.
Dann hast du aber trotzdem auch noch hier natürlich mehr Screen Estate. Und die höhere Auflösung.
Das ist ein besser Prozessor.
Und wenn du das jetzt hier als Production-System benutzt, ist ja so ein bisschen Screen Space.
Und dann habe ich in Apple Store mir diesen hochaufläsenden Bildschirm angeschaut und sie hatten den Matten da. Und der sah eigentlich auch gut aus.
Matte gibt es auch nur bei 15 Zoll.
Wer hat dann so einen Silberrahmen?
Ich weiß nicht, will ich wirklich einen Mattenbildschirm haben?
Also, ich kann mich ja immer noch nicht mit diesem Glossi anfreunden.
Aber es ist dann kein Glas. Das kann man wieder nicht reinigen. Diese Plastik-Wabbel-Oberfläche.
Ach, das kann man natürlich reinigen.
Das nicht wirklich. Glas, da kannst du irgendwie Glasreiniger drauf. Sauber.
Und dann spiegelt es sich auch gleich wieder richtig schön drin und kannst sie erstmal rasieren.
Naja, das kann man auch als Vorteil sehen.
Ich weiß nicht, mich nervt das. Immer, wenn ich neben Leuten sitze, mit diesem glossy Screen, also... Ich weiß nicht, ich komm damit nicht klar mit diesen Spiegelungen.
Aber deins ist doch auch glossy, oder?
Nein, meins ist voll unglossy.
Er ist doch Gestalter.
Ja, ich hab außerdem noch hier so ein altes MacBook Pro.
Ja, aber das ist doch, das ist doch... Ich seh doch hier eine 1-1 Top-Spiegelung.
Also es ist nicht so, dass sich da gar nichts mehr drin spiegelt, aber es ist generell eine ganz andere Kategorie. Also es ist so ein matter Bildschirm, aber es ist wirklich noch der Mathe-Matte. Ich kann mich nicht so richtig entscheiden. Und dann sind die Dinger natürlich dann in der Summe. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt wirklich mir das 15 Zoll rechts unten Modell irgendwie klicke und dann will man natürlich auch 8 GB RAM drin haben, weil man will ja auch erstmal wieder ein Jahr irgendwie Frieden haben, dann ist das so teuer. Und dann denk ich mir, so viel Scheißgeld, und dann ist da noch nicht mal UMTS drin. Hier ist Scheißer. Würde ich auch problemlos nochmal die 100 Euro Aufpreis zahlen, wie beim iPad auch. Ich meine, wenn das schon das Problem ist, dann Option. Ja, egal. Ich zahle auch 200 Euro dafür. Habe ich gar kein Problem damit. Aber es gibt es einfach nicht. Also ich bin einfach unentschlossen.
Gibt es nicht so GSM-Karten für diesen SD-Card-Slot irgendwie so?
Ja, aber das Problem ist, klar, es gibt so USB-Dongles und so was. Also erstmal, gebimsel kann ich eh nicht leiden. Und zweitens, ich möchte gerne, dass der Computer selbst bestimmt, wann er eingebucht ist und wann nicht. Mit diesem ganzen irgendwie USB-Teil, dann fliegst du raus und dann musst du selber anwählen. PPP sprechen mit einem USB-Stick. Ich meine, wo leben wir denn?
Ja, aber das ist bei meinem Stick auch ein bisschen anders. Ich weiß nicht, womit er spricht, aber wenn die Verbindung zwischendurch...
Ach, das ist bei deinem Stick nicht anders, weil der UMTS... Nein.
Wenn die Verbindung zwischendurch weg ist, dann ist er kurz weg und dann ist er wieder da, sobald er wieder da ist.
Du hast auch genau den gleichen, den ich auch habe, diesen komischen, den es bei Rewe gab, da, dieses Teil.
Wie, und den fliegst du raus?
Ihr kauft USB-UMTS-Sticks bei dem?
Der ist ja nochmal richtig übel und dann diese Software, die diese...
Die Software ist furchtbar, das stimmt.
Grauenhaft, ja, da leide ich einfach drunter. Und so was will ich einfach nicht haben.
Aber übrigens hier nochmal, genau, 15 Zoll, war auch im Chat schon erwähnt, hat ja dann eben auch den Core i7, wohingegen das 13 Zoll ja auch noch...
Wobei, das ist, muss ich sagen, da würde ich eher schon Geld in SSD investieren. Weil das bringt zehnmal so viel Speed wie so ein i7.
Also, ja, aber gerade bei so Encoding- und Decoding-Jobs und so weiter?
Hab ich hier mein iMac stehen und so weiter, das würde ich halt auf so einem Teil dann eh nicht machen. Also Speed hängt im Wesentlichen derzeit von der Platte ab. Und meine ganzen Frieses, die ich hier habe, sind halt des Frieses. Umso mehr hier irgendwie Plattenaktivität ist und mehr Programme laufen, die kleinteiliges Zeug machen, Mail und News und so ein Kram, da merke ich immer schon so, jetzt geht es los bis irgendwie nur noch...
Ja, ich will auch SSD.
Und ich denke heute, und wenn man aber dann wiederum SSD klicken will, dann will man natürlich auch so eine Intel haben. Weil nur die dann aber auch so richtig performen. Und das ist dann wiederum so Schweine teuer. Und dann bin ich schon wieder da und denke mir so, ich schiebe einfach noch mal eine Monatschicht hier an meinem kleinen Lüfter-Macbook. Na gut, ich habe jetzt genug gelitten. Wir sollten mal wieder über Geld reden.
Moment.
Ich will jetzt mal kurz hier wissen. Also 8 GB RAM, 512 SSD, 3831. Ist doch kein Geld! Das geht doch fast sogar. Also ich meine... 3831 kostet das hier.
Lire.
Euro.
Für eine Platze.
Nee. MacBook 15 Zoll rechts unten größter CPU.
Alter 3800 Euro.
8 GB RAM und eine 512 SSD.
I don't pay it.
Ja, aber die SSD ist das teure.
Ich weiß. Aber ich bin... Also ganz ehrlich, das zahle ich nicht für einen Computer.
Du kannst ja auch mit...
Fanboy hin, Fanboy her. Aber da ist irgendwie...
Das hat ja nichts mit Fanboy zu tun.
Den Nutzen kann ich daraus nicht ziehen. Also das ist einfach zu viel.
Die SSDs sind noch zu teuer. Das ist schon richtig.
Ja, genau. Das ist irgendwie alles elend.
Da kann man vor allen Dingen auch keine anderen Sachen wegklicken. Wenn man eine SSD haben will, dann ist man halt auch gleich richtig dabei. Mit den 1000. Wie viel kostet die auf Preis?
3800 Euro. Genau. Der Stack... Der Stack... StackEvil im Chat meint, das wäre ja eine Badenkarte 100. Und recht hat er. Ich bin lieber eine Badenkarte 100.
Aber ist eine Badenkarte 100 so schnell wie eine SSD?
Leute. Flatter. Lass uns über Flatter gehen.
Flatter, flatter, flatter, flatter.
Echt, jetzt schon?
Ja, dann haben wir das hinter uns. Das ist ja eigentlich immer ein bisschen schleimig, über Geld zu reden. Aber, da ich ja so viele Statistiken von mir gegeben habe, wollte ich das auch hier noch mal...
Ich glaube, die Leute fanden das echt spannend, weil du bist ja, sage ich jetzt mal, der erfolgreichste deutsche Flatterer, Flatter-User.
Naja, aber wenn es in Beta ist und sowieso kaum jemand in einen Account sich da gerade klicken kann, dann ist das ja auch nicht schwer, ne?
Genau.
Ich weiß gar nicht, die sind...
Ich will jetzt natürlich nicht den Erfolg schmälern, ja.
Ja, das hast du überhaupt nicht getan.
Ich wollte nur mal kurz anmerken, dass es noch Beta ist und Closed Beta.
Na gut, sagen wir mal, also ich habe in diesem ersten halben Monat 50 Euro mehr eingenommen als die Tat, das fand ich... Fand ich okay. Aber gut, ich weiß nicht genau, woran das liegt. Aber ich finde das natürlich super. Das sind natürlich im Vergleich zu dem, was man braucht und was man irgendwie über gezielte Spendenansprache auch in der Regel bekommen kann, ist das immer noch Kleckerbeträge. Aber Flattr ist natürlich ein super Ding. Also eine Bahncard könnte ich mir damit jetzt noch nicht finanzieren. Man muss halt auch mal sehen, wie das weitergeht. Aber jetzt haben sie vor ein, zwei Tagen, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wann sie es angeschaltet haben, haben sie ja eine Einzelauswertung, die man sich auch schön als CSV runterladen kann.
Dieser View Revenue Report?
Genau, dieser Revenue Report. Und dann siehst du eben, was man eben bisher noch nicht konnte, ist das Ganze aufschlüsseln nach welcher Klick, den jetzt eigentlich inwiefern zu diesem Revenue-Einnahmen beigetragen hat.
Also man sah, wie viele Klicks jeder gebracht hat, aber man hat nicht gesehen, wie viel Kohle dabei hängen geblieben ist.
Genau, und du siehst auch nicht...
Wollt man zu Recht erst mal erklären, was Flattr ist?
Das wissen die doch alle.
Gut, falls noch keiner weiß, nicht dem Internet war in den letzten vier Wochen. Flattr ist dieser Micropayment-Dienst, der auf der Basis arbeitet, dass man sich quasi selbst eine Spendenflatträte einrichtet, die man dem Internet weiht. Dort lauern dann kleine Flatter-Buttons an allen möglichen Blogs und sonstigen Orten, wo man dann draufklicken kann. Und jeden Button, den man geklickt hat, wird dann Teil der Ausschüttung. Am Ende des Monats werden alle Buttons, die man geklickt hat, gleichmäßig verteilt.
Also man sagt, 10 Euro, 20 Klicks, jeden Monat, und das Geld wird gleichmäßig auf allen Klicks verteilt. Und die kriegen das dann automatisch zugewiesen.
Und Flatter holt sich dann noch 10% davon weg.
Genau. Man sagt, mein Blog-Konsum oder mein Social-Media-Konsum, oder wie auch immer man das jetzt nennt, ist mir im Monat 10, 20, 50, 100, 5 Millionen Euro wert. Und das Geld wird dann verteilt.
Anfangs war es so, dass man entweder auswählen müsste zwischen 2, 15 und 20 Euro. Mittlerweile gibt es da so einen Slider, wo man irgendwie in 5-Euro-Schritten das bis 100 Euro hochschieben kann. Da haben sie wohl offensichtlich eine Menge Feedback bekommen von Leuten, die der Meinung waren, sie wollen auch mehr Geld bezahlen. Warum nicht? Das könnte auch nochmal interessante Auswirkungen haben. Davon ausgehen, dass es vielleicht wirklich Leute gibt, die einfach sagen, ich habe genug Geld. Soll es ja geben. Es soll ja Leute geben, die haben genug Geld. Und die haben vielleicht viel Spaß mit dem Internet und wollen dann halt auch wirklich über den Dienst dann mal die Kohle verteilen. Kann durchaus sein. Also ich bin da sehr optimistisch, was Flatter betrifft. Movamex ist auch ein bisschen geflattert worden. Und wir sind hier sogar in dieser Alltime Top 5, die so ein bisschen verwirrend ist, weil natürlich hier einzelne Buttons nach oben steigen. Und es sind derzeit nur Buttons, die sozusagen, oder im Wesentlichen Buttons, die quasi für ein ganzes Projekt stehen. Also ich habe das bei Movamex auch so gemacht. Es gibt halt einen Button für Movamex.
Und dann gibt es noch diese Variante für Artikel.
Nach dem Motto finde ich gut, klicke ich irgendwie, dann kriegst du das ab. Hab dann aber später auch noch dieses Plug-In, was es von Flatter gibt, in das Blog eingebaut, sodass man im Prinzip für jeden Post, also gar nicht mal für jede Sendung, das machen kann. Vorteil ist, mit diesem Plug-In geht das halt alles automatisch, sonst müsste man eben diese Things immer manuell anlegen. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen mühsig.
Das geht auch sehr gut.
Ja, okay, es ist einfach, aber du musst dann schon dein Button dann auch manuell, du darfst es halt auch nicht vergessen und so weiter.
Ich finde das Plug-In sehr schön einfach. Du packst das rein und es ist drin und alles ist gut.
Ja, auch dieses Thing, also Flatter ist an sich nicht kompliziert, aber weniger Arbeit ist immer besser. Na ja, was wollte ich jetzt eigentlich sagen? Ich wollte sagen, dass wir dann eben auch Einnahmen erzielt haben im Mai. Genau, und jetzt mit dieser neuen Revenue-Auswertung sieht man eben was was ist. Und jetzt habe ich das mal auseinander gedröselt. Und der Mobile-Max-Anteil war halt 30 Euro ungefähr. 9,29.
Das finde ich, finde ich, na okay, so immer. Also es ist jetzt nicht, dass ich jetzt sage, mehr soll es auch nicht sein, aber so für...
Das finanziert auf jeden Fall hier schon mal die Mate-Runde locker. Kiste Mate. Kriegen wir gar nicht weg in einem Monat. Schon Überschuss.
Ich hol mir noch mal eine.
Ich hol mir jetzt mal einen Gehalt ab.
Podcaster Gold. Ja, also ich kann nur jeden ermuntern, der selber Wert schafft, ja, also Inhalte schafft, da so einen Flatterbutton drauf zu machen. Ich bin irgendwie sehr dafür. Das ist super. Und wir freuen uns natürlich jetzt auch über jeden Unterstützung. Aber jetzt ist auch irgendwie genug. Wir wollen jetzt hier nicht Fishing for Compliments machen oder vor Send-Beträge.
Nee, aber was...
Sollen wir besprechen, was hier passiert?
Was ich für Flatter noch sagen kann, was ich daran ganz geil finde, ist die Möglichkeit, hoffentlich schafft die noch jemand, dass man Inhalte kopieren kann von einer Webseite und gleichzeitig den Flatter-Button mitkopieren.
Also du meinst, den Flatter-Button weiter reichen Zitat-Kram?
Genau, das fände ich total geil. Also wenn irgendjemand auf Boing-Boing zitiert wird, dass er dann... weil da hat mir hier dieser Sascha Pallenberg, das steht auch in diesem Artikel über Flatter drin, den ich euch hier geschrieben habe, der hat mir erzählt, dass ein Gadget teilweise Inhalte von ihm übernimmt. Sie sagen, Netbook News hat rausgefunden, lange Absatz von ihm, und dann sind die Affiliate-Links drin. Er hat sich immer einen abgefreut, und wenn er bei einem Gadget war, hat er richtig seine Kasse klingeln lassen. Und mit Flatter könnte was Ähnliches passieren. Hey Guy, ich war auf Boing-Boing, hab mit 30 Euro gebracht.
Hier, gerade einer neu dazu geflattert. Gerade von 287 auf 288.
Warst du bei Movamex? Da-da!
Ka-ching! Du brauchst hier so ein...
Ist ja nicht Ka-ching. Flatter braucht sein eigenes Sound. Gibt ja noch Ka-chingel, die so was Ähnliches probieren, aber deren Ansatz finde ich irgendwie nicht so gut.
Wie probieren die es?
Na, die machen eigentlich so was Ähnliches. Die sind aber sehr viel mehr so... Webseiten orientiert. Also, die denken mehr so von die Seite als Ganzes. Und haben dann so einen riesigen Ka-chingel-Medallion, wie sie das nennen. Medallien, Medaille.
Der ist 600 mal 600 Pixel groß, und verdeckt einen Großteil der eigentlichen Seite.
Und wird mit Werbung geschickt. Ja, und dann ist es auch so, bei Default ist dann erstmal alles, was du anklickst, gibst du dann quasi auch öffentlich bekannt. Und dann aber wiederum pro Webseite einstellen, dass du da mit einem anderen Screen-Namen auftauchst und so weiter. Ich habe mit der Gründerin geredet, die war vor ein paar Tagen hier in Berlin.
Das war in 1993, jetzt geht es ab.
Ich habe mit der Gründerin von Ka-chingel geredet und sie hat einen kurzen Vortrag gehalten. Und zwar, für meinen Geschmack bei mir, dass irgendwie alles zu verschwurbelt und zu amerikanisch so. Also, wie gesagt, die haben ein ähnliches Modell, kann auch funktionieren. Aber dieses Ganze, also sie meinte, das wäre halt alles irgendwie, sie sieht das halt vor alles unter diesem ganzen Social- und Network-Gedanken. Und die Leute wollen ja wirklich dann auch nach außen zeigen, was sie unterstützen. Und ich glaube, dass das irgendwie in Deutschland gar nicht mal so unbedingt das Ding ist.
Aber doch, doch, doch, das würde ich mir total wünschen. Ich würde mir total wünschen, dass es so eine, also ich finde das ja, ich nutze ja diese, bei Google Reader, mit dem du gleich los twittern kannst, nach dem Motto, Ei, flettert, Ei, katscht. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das unbedingt jetzt ganz dringend zu Twitter rein muss, aber beim Google Reader, gucke ich mir zum Beispiel, share ich gerne mal Items mit anderen Leuten und da lesen auch irgendwie 300 Leute, oder 200 Leute haben da mein Google Reader Zeug abonniert und umgekehrt abonniere ich auch gerne das Zeug von anderen Leuten, weil es gibt so, man stößt auf Dinge, auf die man sonst nicht stoßen würde, genauso wie es bei Twitter funktioniert und so eine das war mir Geld wert AP, dass ich zum Beispiel von dir oder von wem auch immer, von Leuten, die ich glaube, die interessante Inhalte zu schätzen wissen und interessante Inhalte finden und wenn die dann den Flatter-Button gedrückt haben und gesagt haben, das war mir Geld wert, das würde ich gerne abonnieren von vielen Leuten. Das würde ich gerne sehen, was du geflattert hast. Aber das gibt es nicht, oder wie?
Das gibt es jetzt halt nicht. Also ich weiß, wie die Belöden arbeiten an ihrem System gerade.
Das kriegt man ja auch mit.
Ich muss auch sagen, ich bin erstaunt von dem, was ich mal so im Chat so nebenbei habe da an Feedback zufließen lassen. Von dem ist eine Menge umgesetzt worden, unter anderem dieser CSV-Download. Habt ihr mir zu verdanken. kriege ich das jetzt in Numbers? Das geht locker in Numbers rein.
Auf dem iPad?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Probier es mal aus. was wollte ich sagen? Ah ja, genau. Sie arbeiten jetzt an ihrer API vor allem. Sie wollen also eine restbasierte API machen. Und dann wird es halt spannend, wie sie dann integriert sind. Dann könnte ich ja eben auch schon sehen. Über kurz oder lang, ehrlich gesagt, ich erwarte und jetzt mache ich mal eine Voraussage. Ich erwarte, dass Schlatter erfolgreich sein wird. Ich weiß noch nicht genau, wie erfolgreich sein wird, aber ich könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass sie so erfolgreich sind, dass wir das in Windeseile auch bei Facebook sehen werden, dieses Modell. Und dann wird es natürlich echt spannend. Mit 300 Millionen Usern irgendwie, weißt du, da kannst du natürlich gleich ganz anders losstarten. Wenn dieser Like-Button auch mit Geld verbunden ist. Im Prinzip ist das ja genau dasselbe Interaktionsmodell. Wenn du halt nicht nur sagen kannst, I like, sondern I like so much that I'm willing to pay. Und du setzt da halt auch so eine Flatrate auf. Das ist ja eigentlich für Facebook überhaupt kein Problem. Und die sind ja eh auf dem Weg, ein eigenes Payment-Modell aufzubauen. Also ich denke, die Idee wird greifen. Und wir werden das noch bei vielen anderen auch noch sehen. Am Ende sogar bei PayPal.
Ich würde es zu teufeln, wenn da irgendein großer Kreditkartenanbieter oder Paper oder sowas jemand diese Chance ergreifen würde.
Ich denke, die werden sich das irgendwann...
Also ich halte die für zu doof, aber... Und Facebook... Bei Flattr finde ich das Schöne, dass die so total unabhängig sind und dass da niemand so richtig dahinter steht. Ja klar, okay. Aber dass die noch keine Eigeninteressen sozusagen verfolgen. Bei Facebook würde ich immer argumentieren, die würden so ein Dienst doch nicht aufsetzen, natürlich auch damit Geld zu verdienen, aber sie würden auch ihre eigenen Dienste damit irgendwie ein bisschen übervorteilen oder so ein bisschen besser stellen als andere oder irgendwie sowas. Keine Ahnung. Also Facebook halte ich da für den falschen Kandidaten.
Aber wir wollten jetzt ja auch eigentlich so abschließen, so langsam mit diesem Flattr-Geld-Thema. Stimmt. Hat auch einer schon im Chat gesagt hier.
Ihr redet nur über Geld.
Du warst hier schon voll im Ausmoderieren. Ich habe jetzt nur noch ein bisschen geredet.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich spiele nebenbei auch noch ein bisschen mit meinem Gerät rum. Wenn man schon nackt ist. Ich mache mir jetzt hier gerade mal Vorläufe auf meinem Telefon irgendwie. Gucken, wie das so kommt.
Krasser Checker und so.
Ich dachte, du installierst das so für den...
Wir können ja auch noch mal ein bisschen Werbung für unsere Freunde machen.
Unsere Freunde? Wir haben Freunde?
Ja, klar haben wir Freunde. Viele. Nee, hier unsere Freunde aus München hier. Du weißt schon.
Ach so, mit ihrem... Ich hab's noch nicht... Ich hab's installiert, das Spiel.
Carcassonne.
Carcassonne, ich kann's nicht aussprechen.
Genau. Die haben ja schon erstaunliche Erfolge damit erzielt und waren jetzt irgendwie eine ganze Woche lang während der WBC war die ganze Woche lang...
Auf Platz 1 im App Store.
Genau. Und zwar sowohl der meisten Verkauf...... als auch derjenigen, die am meisten Kohle gemacht haben. Ich hab keine Vorstellung davon, wieviel Kohle das ist, aber es ist sicherlich besser, als wenn man auf Platz 500 ist.
Wobei mir aufgefallen ist, dass...... in dem Zusammenhang fällt mir gerade auch...
Also, Coding Monkeys.
Die haben Carcassonne geschrieben. Ich hab's noch nicht einmal gestartet, aber ist bestimmt super.
Genau, der Dom ist ja auch so ein Brettspiel-Nerd und so, und die haben da irgendwie Kontakte gehabt. Und Carcassonne ist halt auch mal so Spiel des Jahres gewesen. Und lalala. Für Leute, die Brettspiele mögen sicherlich...
Und die Kritik, die ich gelesen habe, ist der totale Hammer. Also ich hab noch nichts Negatives über dieses Spiel gesehen.
Weiß ich, weil das klatschen wundert. Huckel betätigt dich gerade als Fliehenfänger oder Mittenvernichter. Dieses Spiel war wohl schon lange gehalten und lief wohl auch auf der Xbox ganz gut als Game. Und dann haben sie sich entschlossen, das hier zu machen. Und dann haben die locker mal ein Jahr dran gesessen. Und da knietief in den Bits gestanden. Und jetzt gibt es da Erfolge. Ich muss sagen, sogar mir gefällt das. Ich bin so ein Netzwerkspieler und verliere immer gegen alle. Und bin dann immer schnell frustriert.
Ja, das geht mir auch genauso.
Darum mache ich es auch noch nicht gestartet.
Was jetzt aber seit heute für das iPad endlich da ist, offiziell im App Store mein Lieblings-RSS-Feed-Google-Reader mit E. Du warst ja nicht ganz so angetan von der iPhone-Version.
Ich mag dieses Beileiden gerne. Aber das Reader ist mir zu grau alles. Ich weiß nicht, ich könnte ihn nicht einfach schwarz auf weiß machen. Warum muss das alles immer in diesem Web-2.0-igen Melange graubräunlich, sodass man keinen Kontrast mehr hat?
Das kommt in einer iPad-Version relativ gut rüber, weil das ist so ein Notebook, in dem man da rumsäuft.
Ich habe mir das jetzt extra nochmal gekauft vorhin. Das ist ja gar nicht so, aber ich habe es noch nicht eingerichtet. Aber ich mache das jetzt mal auf hier.
Was da echt ein hübsches Feature ist, was dir vielleicht gefallen wird, ist, du hast ja immer gesagt, dass es nicht möglich ist, da einzelne Features zu lesen bei Reader. Man kann hier nämlich, wenn man so Ordner hat, ich habe hier alles in Ordnern organisiert, und jetzt kann man mit dieser Pinch-Geste, kann man die so aufziehen, und kann dann jeden Feed einzeln sehen.
Hast du gerade gesehen, hast du ja geguckt?
Ja, das sieht schön aus. Also da habe ich ja eher, das ist mir zu viel. Aber egal, ich habe damit noch nicht gearbeitet.
Es ist schnell, es hat viele Bugs nicht, die ein Newsfile zum Beispiel hatte, wenn du ein YouTube-Video angeklickt hast und das abgespielt hast. Und dann gesagt hast, ja, YouTube-Video interessiert nicht mehr, mach mal einen nächsten Artikel, hat das im Hintergrund das YouTube-Video weiter abgespielt. Das heißt, du hast den Ton gehabt. Und wenn du aber wieder zurückgeklickt hast, war das YouTube-Video auf Start Play, mit Anworten, du musstest net News-File beenden, um dieses YouTube-Video wieder abzubrechen. So eine Bugs hat das alles nicht. Es ist einfach, ich finde es...
Man kann den Kontrast hier auch konfigurieren. Gut, ich werde mich damit ein bisschen beschäftigen. Aber ich mag trotzdem Byline, ganz ehrlich. Also, so wie der so... Das ist einfach ganz gut durchdacht im User-Interface, wie man da so durch die Artikel durchswipeen kann und so.
Durch die Artikel durchswipeen, das hat Reawealer erfunden, mit denen durch die Artikel durch...
Und wer hat es erfunden?
Also, ich finde, die machen es noch einen Zacken besser.
Mit diesem Hochschieben und so? Muss ich nochmal testen, aber ich bin, wie gesagt, beilein, finde ich, gelungen. Uke will über...
Uke über?
Es ist was passiert. Wir können auch erstmal über iPhone OS 4.0 reden. Da bin ich hier gerade am...
Ach, das kennen wir doch jetzt alle schon. Aber ihr alle nicht. Ihr seid jetzt total iPad-ifiziert und iOS-ifiziert. Das passt doch gar nicht.
iOS-ifiziert. Das ist jetzt definitiv ein sehr wertvolles Thema. Das iPhone ist vorgestellt worden. Im Wesentlichen wenig Überraschungen, weil diesmal wurde so dermaßen viel geleakt. Das ist schade eigentlich. Diese ganzen Leaks vorher...
Das war praktisch kein Detail, was nicht bekannt war.
Fast keins.
Man muss Internet echt Monate vorher ausmachen. Das ist nicht mehr das Gleiche wie früher.
Vier Monate vorher. Jeglichen News-Konsum einstellen.
Diesmal war es wirklich schlimm. Man hatte das Gefühl, zwei Wochen vor der WDC, dass man der Einzige wäre, der noch nicht in einer baren iPhone gefunden ist.
Ich habe mich schon gewundert.
Ich habe mich gewundert, dass er überhaupt noch was hatte, was keine Ahnung hatte. Aber es sind auch richtige Knaller dabei.
Ich finde die Sache mit den Antennen geil.
Das ist cool, dass da auch keiner drauf gekommen ist. Ich gehöre auch zu dieser Kategorie wie Schlitze. Und das soll jetzt Apple Design sein?
Genau, das habe ich auch gesehen. Ich habe das Foto gesehen, von dem allerersten und gesagt, Leute, das ist ein Fake, da sind Schlitze, um den Akku auszuwechseln.
Das ist eine Zwischenversion.
Das haben sie eingebaut, das wollen sie dann schnell rausreißen, damit der Akku schnell raus kann, weil es dann in Flammen aufgeht. Das war meine Vermutung.
Was lernen wir daraus? 4 Monate vorher, war das so? Da steht so ein Design. Bei Apple.
Ich glaube, da muss die ganze Produktion auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ich hatte nie eine richtige Forschung, wie knapp das alles ist.
Die 8 Video hat er erzählt, wie lange sie an einem iPhone entwickelt haben.
18 Monate. Er hat 18 Monate gesagt.
Ja, aber wie es losging, irgendwann 2001, als er wieder zu Apple abging, hat er angefangen, das Touch-Display und wollte erst mal ein Tablet.
Ja, aber hier, ich meine, bei diesem Start-up, was wir hier kennen, diesen E-Book-Reader da bauen, ohne jetzt mal einen Namen zu nennen, ich meine, die wollten ja vor letztes Jahr irgendwann zu Weihnachten und dann noch wieder ein paar Monate. Da sind immer irgendwelche Probleme, weil in China produzieren und so, und dann immer noch Fertigungstoleranzen hier und da. Und ich glaube, da muss man halt auch echt einfach... Das ist, glaube ich, echt voll blöd, so Hardware zu bauen, die nicht zuhause in der Fabrik nebenan zusammengedengelt wird.
Kein Wunder. Von daher hat mich wenig überrascht. Mich hat überhaupt noch überrascht, dass sie überhaupt noch in der Lage waren, was zu zeigen, was man noch nicht geahnt hat.
Die hohe Display-Auflösung zu sehen, das ist mal ganz gut.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du schon mal wirklich ein HD-Video gesehen? Es gab einen Stream, der jetzt in 27p ist. Den habe ich aber noch nicht geklickt. Der Stream, den sie gleich danach veröffentlicht haben und auch der Download, war halt nur 640x irgendwas. Bis 480 sogar.
Wo man dann die beiden Bildschirme sieht nebeneinander.
Das ist der Unterschied. Sieht das nicht großartig aus? Er hat mich das auch sehr gewundert, warum sie nicht gleich eine höhere Auflösung in den Podcast gepusht haben. Aber gut. Ja. Was sollen wir sagen? Ich habe so ein Lieblingsthema bei diesem iPhone.
Das Gyroskop.
Das ist Platz 2.
Ich finde das Gyroskop geil.
Das finde ich auch geil.
Weil da gehen auch total viele Leute, die so Spiele machen, total drauf ab.
Das ist so irre. Vor allem, ich habe die Wee auch total angefixt. Ich habe mir die relativ früh gekauft. Und dann war auch schnell mir klar, bestimmte Bewegungen werden überhaupt nicht abgebildet. Und dann haben sie ja auch nachgelegt. Die sind ein Adapter. Die habe ich noch nicht so viel getestet. Ich habe den zwar, aber ich habe irgendwie immer noch keinen Bildschirm an, den ich anschließen könnte. Aber da haben sie halt nachgelegt. Und es war vollkommen klar, man will wirklich alle Achsen. Und nicht nur die drei. Im Prinzip macht das iPhone jetzt auch. Ich fand die Demo super mit diesem Jenga. Vor allem fand ich es super, wie viel Zeit er sich genommen hat. Ich meine, er macht nichts ohne Grund. Das war dann gleich wieder dieses Immersive Gaming. Es ist so realistisch, dass man sich die ganze Zeit damit beschäftigen kann und guckt mal, wie detailliert man damit spielen kann.
Ich möchte nicht die arme Sau sein, die dieses Spiel vorher extra dafür schreiben musste. Ich glaube, der... Steve, dieses Spiel, dieses Keyboard-Spiel. Ich glaube, das erfährst du nicht von deinem Vorgesetzten, sondern es steht einfach Steve in deinem Büro und alle fünf Minuten und du kannst... Er beschreibt dir haargenau, welchen Maß er um das Holz haben muss und dass das ja wohl die falsche Holzwarte sei.
So muss das gehen. So führt man auch.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall... Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht so... Also das ist wahrscheinlich ein fertiger Baustein und das haben jetzt wahrscheinlich alle anderen Telefone, die demnächst rauskommen, dann auch. Aber es war halt auf jeden Fall mal schick, das so gefeatured zu sehen und... Wir haben das jetzt drin und damit...
Ja, aber das ist auch einfach, dass das... Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, was so ein Baustein kostet. Also ein Baustein kostet so ein Gyroskop. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie das technisch funktioniert. Also ich weiß, dass das früher ein Flugzeug war, dass da ein kleiner... sich einen Kreisel die ganze Zeit mitdrehen musste. Ich hoffe, die haben da nicht irgendwo einen Mikrokreisel drin.
Nee, es funktioniert alles heutzutage mit Halbleitern größtenteils.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie viel so ein Teil kostet. Aber dass Apple jetzt auch... Also dass es immer noch schaffen, da die Ersten zu sein, die so was einbauen, ist, finde ich, doch recht überraschend. Wo ja Android und diese ganzen Geräte, wo die sich ja echte Probleme haben, sich gegenseitig mal voneinander abzuheben, die einzelnen Hersteller. Es ist ja da nicht einer von dir, der mal sagt, wir schmeißen hier nochmal für 30 Cent ein Gyroskop mit rein.
Wobei das Problem ja eigentlich oder die Sache bei den anderen Geräten ist, dass die haben zwar viele Sachen drin, die auch die iPhones sozusagen noch nicht drin hatten, aber da werden sie halt auch nicht benutzen. Und deshalb war ja auch irgendwie so ein Kommentar, dass Apple dann die Sachen, diese einbauen, die sie dann auch irgendwie auch gleich ordentlich benutzt.
Zum Beispiel die 3D-Grafikkarte.
Genau. Naja, nee, aber es ist ja auch so, dass bei zum Beispiel Android, die so, ich glaube, jetzt fangen sie ja an, mit Hardware zu rendern. Und vorher war ja alles Software, deswegen das so geruckelt. Ja, das meinte ich auch. Also, wo man sich auch fragt, Jungs, hallo? Jetzt erst. Ja, nee, aber Gyro fand ich schon mal gut. Kamera fand ich gut. Und was ist dein Nummer eins? Das bin ich jetzt eigentlich gespannt.
Meine Nummer eins ist FaceTime.
Ernsthaft?
Und zwar habe ich auch sehr viel darüber nachgedacht. Und ich bin da noch lange nicht am Ende. Ich habe auch leider weniger Informationen darüber, als mir lieb wäre. Aber das schlug bei mir ein wie eine Bombe. Nicht nur, weil ich unter Umständen sogar die direkte Zielgruppe bin, weil das wendet sich natürlich vor allem an Leute mit Kindern. Das ist das Telefon für Oma.
Und diversen iPhones.
Und diversen iPhones? Du kaufst dann einfach gleich einen Familien-Satz iPhones. Weil das ist halt einfach mal das Connect-to-Home-Tool.
Ja, aber es geht nicht.
Aber das ist nicht der Grund, warum ich davon so begeistert war. Sondern davon war ich deshalb so begeistert. Also erstmal, dass sie es integriert haben, aber vor allem, was sie da eigentlich getan haben. Denn das ist offensichtlich noch keinem so richtig klar geworden. Also es gibt kaum Berichte darüber, was das eigentlich ist.
Wie, was das eigentlich ist?
Was ist FaceTime?
Welche Technologie dahintersteckt?
Ja, wie müsste man das eigentlich nennen? Also wie hat Apple es nicht genannt?
Sie haben es...
Es ist VoiceOver IP. Es handelt sich hier um VoiceOver IP. Das iPhone 4 ist ein VoIP-Telefon. Das merkt man bloß nicht. Und das Coole ist, dass es vermutlich die erste VoIP-Anlage an dem iPhone 4 ist. Und das Coole ist, dass es vermutlich die erste VoIP-Anlage an dem iPhone 4 ist, die mal wirklich funktioniert, wie eine VoIP-Anlage eigentlich funktionieren müsste. Sie haben einen ganz klaren Migrationspfad hier aufgerufen. Erinnert euch mal, ich hab mir das sehr genau angeschaut, wie sie das demonstriert haben, das Teil. Also, was hat er gemacht? Er hat die Telefonanwendung aufgerufen. Und nicht eine FaceTime-Anwendung. Das ist irgendwie integriert. Und er hat dann einfach die Telefonnummer von dem Johnson Ive aufgerufen. Und dann kam dieser normale Ich ruf an Screen. Und dieses FaceTime-Logo in der Mitte war ausgegraut. Dann dauerte das einen Moment. Und dann war es nicht mehr ausgegraut. Und dann hat er das gedrückt. Dann dauerte es noch mal einen Moment. Und dann hat er diesen Ruf initiiert. Dann dauerte es noch mal einen Moment. Und dann war er verbunden. Da waren jetzt verschiedene Pausen da drin. Was man ja nicht unbedingt so direkt verwundern muss, dass Dinge auch eine Weile brauchen. Ich habe mir halt überlegt, was tut dieses Gerät eigentlich tatsächlich? Hier ist meine Theorie. Und vielleicht liege ich falsch. Ich werde auch gerne eines Besseren belehrt. Aber das ist das, was ich derzeit glaube, was sie tun. Sie haben ja auch gesagt, es gibt keinerlei zusätzliche Registrierung, keinerlei zusätzliche Maßnahmen. Du hast diese Bildtelefonie out of the box. das bedeutet, es gibt nichts anderes als nur die Telefonnummer, die dazu führt, dass du deinen Gegenüber findest. Um das Gegenüber aber zu finden, und diese Kommunikation läuft ja nachweislich über IP, weil es geht ja auch nur, wenn Wi-Fi da ist, müssen sie sozusagen über die Telefonnummer die IP-Adresse des anderen Teilnehmers rausbekommen. Das ist natürlich schon mal eine Herausforderung. Aber dafür gibt es bereits einen Standard, der heißt E164, besser bekannt als Enum. Enum ist quasi DNS für Telefonnummer, oder genauer gesagt Reverse-DNS für Telefonnummer. So wie du einen Namen in eine IP-Adresse umwandeln kannst, kannst du auch eine IP-Adresse in einen Namen umwandeln. Genau, Reverse-DNS, dann nimmst du nämlich die IP-Adresse, drehst die Nummern um der IP-Adresse und fügst hinten noch einen Punkt, habe ich vergessen, Punkt APA an. Genau. Das heißt, du baust dir quasi aus der IP-Adresse einen Namen zum Locken ab und dann kannst du da gucken und dann kriegst du den Namen dafür. Genauso funktioniert das mit Enum. Du nimmst die Telefonnummer, drehst alle Ziffern um, das heißt, deine Telefonnummer rückwärts aus 0179 wird. 971 endet mit 49E164ARPA Das ist der DNS-Name deiner Telefonnummer. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo der Jonathan Alf aufgerufen hat und dieses FaceTime-Logo war noch ausgegraut, diese Pause, meine Theorie, hat er verwendet, um diesen Look-up zu machen. Dieser Look-up war quasi das Fragen, gibt es, wenn ich diese Telefonnummer über E-Nummer auflöse, dahinter einen Service-Rekord, SRV-Rekord, der einen Inhalt hat, der mir sagt, wo dieses Telefon gerade in diesem Moment online ist. Dem war dann wohl so, sodass er in dem Moment keinen GSM-Call gemacht hat, sondern einen vollständigen IP-Call. Weil wäre das nämlich Telefon und hätte er einen normalen GSM oder UMTS Telefon-Call gemacht, und das Bild separat über IP, dann wäre das nie und nimmer synchron gewesen. Muss aber synchron sein und das war auch synchron. Ich meine, es war da irgendwie ein Delay drin. War es synchron? Das muss noch gar nicht so genau sein.
Ich hab's mir noch gar nicht so genau angeguckt.
Das können Sie nicht machen. Es war synchron.
Der Nachteil daran wäre natürlich, dass du kein Handover hättest. Also wenn du...
Handover?
Du bist in ein anderes Wi-Fi-Netz. Auch wenn du einfach das Wi-Fi verlässt. FaceTime funktioniert ja nur über Wi-Fi. Das heißt, in dem Moment, in dem ich von zuhause losgehe und sage, du, ich bin jetzt unterwegs, dann würde irgendwann deine FaceTime-Verbindung zusammenbrechen. Die würde einfach nicht mehr gehen. Aber ich würde ja in dem Moment erwarten, dass das Telefonieren weitergeht.
Wird es aber nicht. Aber das ist natürlich eine generelle Frage, wie man überhaupt seine IP-Adresse beibehält. Ich meine, wenn du ein Roaming hast, wenn du in einer Firma bist, wo du ein Roaming hast, dann behältst du deine IP-Adresse in der Regel bei. Und mit IPv6 sieht ja schon das IPv6 vor, dass du deine Adresse beibehalten kannst, auch wenn du in anderen Netzen bist.
Die nächste Frage ist natürlich, wenn ich deine FaceTime habe und ich eine reine Voice-over-IP-Verbindung aufbaue, und am Anfang hat es mit einem stinknormalen Telefonar...
Moment, stopp! Lass mich nochmal kurz zu Ende erklären, was meiner Meinung nach da passiert, weil das war ja nur der erste Teil. Weil er ruft den AIF an, er nimmt die Telefonnummer, er macht diesen Enum und stellt fest, da ist ein Service-Rekord. Wo kommt der her?
Wahrscheinlich baut Apple dafür eine Registry auf.
Na, das können sie aber nicht, weil diese Enum-Geschichte, das ist wirklich klar definiert, wer das vorhält. Also in Deutschland zum Beispiel betreibt die DENIC dieses Repository. Und das wollte ich eigentlich noch recherchieren, aber da bin ich einfach nicht zu gekommen, bzw. habe ich in meinen ersten Versuchen noch nicht so richtig das gefunden. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, eben diese Enum-Rekords direkt reinzuschreiben, aber dafür brauchst du natürlich auch eine Autorisierung. Du musst ja in irgendeiner Form berechtigt sein. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo dein Telefon im Wi-Fi ist, ich gehe davon aus, dass diese Telefonanwendung, die läuft ja sowieso im Hintergrund, weil die muss ja auch die Anrufe entgegennehmen. Und wenn sie im Wi-Fi ist, dann merkt sie, ah, alles klar, ich habe jetzt Wi-Fi-Connection. Und in dem Moment geht sie an diesen Enum-Rekord und sagt, hallo, ich bin jetzt gerade zu erreichen unter IP-Adresse sowieso. Interessantes Privacy-Problem an der Stelle natürlich auch noch, aber das ist das, was das Ding tut, weil sonst würde das nicht funktionieren können. Sonst kann zum Zeitpunkt des Anrufes nicht ermittelt werden, wohin ich eine Voice-over-IP-Verbindung machen soll. Also sowas muss es irgendwie geben.
Naja, oder sie haben komplett eigenes Motokoll aufgesetzt dafür?
Nie und nimmer. Ich meine, sie haben, stand nicht Enum sogar auf der Liste, also ich muss noch mal kurz mal gucken, sie haben ja gesagt, dass sie das als Standard verbreiten wollen. Ja, also sie möchten gerne, dass das von allen benutzt wird. Noch haben sie aber diese Specs meiner Meinung nach nicht veröffentlicht. Wo ist denn hier diese schöne Stelle? Das war ja jetzt irgendwie, ich scrolle hier gerade mal durch das Video. Hier ist irgendwie, äh, FaceTime, genau.
Ich habe mir ehrlich gesagt das nicht mal angeguckt. Ich fand es so langweilig, diese Video-Telefonie, dass sie mir in die Ecke geguckt haben.
Das ist das Spannendste überhaupt. H264, also das sind die Abkürzungen, die sie hier auf dem Slide haben. H264 AAC, klar. Sie machen ein Video mit H264, sie machen ein Video mit AAC. Genau. Dann machen sie ZIP, klar. Das ist ein Protokoll, mit dem alles Voice-over-IP arbeitet. Dann ist es hier STONE, TURN, ICE. Das gehört im Prinzip zusammen. Das sind alles verschiedene Methoden. ICE ist quasi die Klammer darüber. Internet Connection, also da geht es darum, um natt herumzukommen. Was ja immer eine Schwäche von iChat auch war, da haben sie meines Wissens nur STONE bisher gemacht. Jetzt gibt es auch noch weitere Verfahren. Das Ganze ist zusammengefasst unter ICE. Daraus lese ich jetzt einfach mal raus. Wir kriegen das jetzt auch hin. So wie Skype das immer hinbekommen hat. Da hat sich viel getan in den letzten Jahren. Und ich schätze mal, das werden sie schon als Problem erkannt haben. Wie auch immer, das wird sich zeigen. So, RTP, Real-Time Transfer-Protokoll, klar. Das heißt, sie machen diese Verbindung über UDP. Das ist das, was du brauchst für so eine Real-Time-Verbindung. Und jetzt wird es richtig sexy.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die verschlüsselte Variante davon.
Das ist Secure-RTP. Das heißt, sie machen nicht nur VoIP, sondern sie machen verschlüsseltes, sicheres Telefonieren. Das ist ein Krypto-Phone. Das neue iPhone 4 ist ein Krypto-Telefon mit Bild und Ton.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Und dann sprach er noch davon, I'm getting excited here.
Du bist dankt, wir sehen uns.
Er sprach dann davon. Nach dem Motto, wir würden gerne, dass es ein Standard ist. Übrigens, ich weise darauf hin, wir werden Tens of Million FaceTime-Devices verkauft haben in diesem Jahres. Er sagte nicht iPhone 4. Er sagte FaceTime-Devices.
Mit anderen Worten, das wird demnächst im iPod und im iPad auftauchen.
Auf jeden Fall ist das für ein iPod Touch mit Kamera in beide Richtungen. Wäre das einfach mal die Goldanwendung, dann hättest du nämlich auch ein Telefon, was nur im WLAN funktioniert, aber was halt Bild und Ton kann.
Mit normalen Telefonnummern.
Und ohne AT&T. Und ohne Telekom. Mit normalen Telefonnummern. Genau, das ist der Punkt.
Ich habe noch ein Stück weit die Hoffnung, dass hierfür noch so ein kleiner Aufsatz kommt, wo deine Kamera drin steckt. Du musst jetzt schon noch ein bisschen... Ja, okay, ich halte die Schnauze.
Nein, du sollst nicht die Schnauze halten, du sollst einfach beeindruckt... Ich sehe keine Erregung an dir, das ist, obwohl du nackt bist.
Also das Ausmaß dieser...
Ja, also meiner Meinung nach ist Apple gerade dabei, mit dem iPhone 4 das erste wirklich viable, vollständig standardkonforme, nicht proprietäre Voice-over-IP-Mildbild- und Tontelefon auf diesen Markt zu bringen.
Das klingt zu gut, um wahr zu sein.
Und es geht total an den Providern vorbei. Weil die interessante Frage wäre natürlich, die ich mir jetzt auch gestellt habe, ich dachte einfach, sie hatten quasi im Wesentlichen diesen Standard implementiert, aber in dem Moment, in dem ich da anrufe, in dem Steve den Johnny anruft und dann das auf Voice-over-IP umgestellt wird, läuft dann mein Geldzähler weiter? Muss ich dann weiterhin AT&T zahlen? Oder beziehungsweise an meinen Provider? Oder in dem Moment ist das auch meine fucking eigene Voice-over-IP-Verbindung?
Er hat keine GSM-Verbindung aufgemacht. Meiner Meinung nach.
Du meinst, das Telefonat war von Anfang an reines Voice-over-IP-Telefonat?
Aber natürlich hat er das nicht gesagt. Weil das ist nichts, worüber er redet.
Dann hat man ein lustiges Abrechnungsproblem. Wobei das ja bei Voice-over-IP sowieso der Fall ist.
Naja, ich meine, letzten Endes kann sich keiner davon abhalten, so was draufzumachen. Wenn es auch Skype gibt, warum soll Apple das nicht auch selbst machen?
Natürlich, klar, gar keine Frage. Ich finde es ganz...
Es ist insofern auch eine logische Konsequenz, weil in dem Moment, als sie angekündigt haben, Background-Ups, das erste war so, ja, aber bestimmt nicht mit Skype. Und dann demonstrieren sie es tatsächlich mit Skype. Da dachte ich mir so, aha, sie lassen jetzt Skype drauf, da Voice-over-IP zu machen, an ihrem Telefon vorbei. Und die lange Antwort ist, ja, weil sie es auch selbst tun und sie bauen es auf eine Art und Weise ein, dass die Leute gar keinen Skype brauchen. Weil du hast jetzt Voip.
Skype hat ja schon irgendwie angekündigt, dass sie gerne da ran würden, an das FaceTime.
Haben sie? Echt? Bitte einmal.
Es hat Apple den Serial-Port weggelassen an das Floppy-Laufwerk und jetzt lassen sie GSM aus dem iPhone weg. Dann warten sie nur noch über Wi-Fi. Die provider das so alles, Legacy. Das supporten wir nicht mehr.
Dieses Telefonie.
Also, ich finde, in jeder Hinsicht ist es das Wert, dass das jetzt wirklich das One More Thing war.
Das hätte ich... Ich fand das ja eher... Aber jetzt macht es tatsächlich Sinn. Aus der Techno-Perspektive macht es plötzlich Sinn.
Ja, und ich sage dir, dieses Feature steckt ein bei Familien. Das ist einfach das, was du haben willst.
Ja, es muss natürlich noch...
Das ist das Babyphone.
Skype, Hatches und FaceTime.
Du kannst ja da irgendwie so einen iPod Touch, der irgendwie Auto-Ansa macht, das hängst du da irgendwie über das Baby-Bett, und dann hast du da irgendwie das 1A-Babyphone.
Es muss natürlich noch über UMTS gehen, über 3G. Dass es bisher nur über WLAN geht, ist klar.
Dass das aber jetzt in der ersten Version nicht geht, das ist mir auch klar.
Natürlich.
Aber das haben sie ja angebläht. Also ich will mir einen irgendwo auch gesagt, das ist erstmal nur auf...
Das ist ein Grund für ein Jailbreak.
Wobei ich glaube, das war so ein Wink-Wink, das war ja normal so Richtung AT&T. Naja, jetzt wärt ihr euch noch. Aber nicht mehr lange.
Irgendwann kaufen sie AT&T.
Das wäre aber tatsächlich... Oder die Teile, die für sie relevant sind, die Datenteile. Das muss ich ja sagen, das wäre tatsächlich ein sehr tolles Feature. Also abgesehen davon, dass ich ja telefonisch, e-Frash, Alte, totalte, aber...
Jetzt gucke ich erstmal...
Also im Chat scrollen wir so ein paar Links durch.
Dieser Artikel auf Apple Insider, der hat leider auch nicht so richtig viele... Also Enum hat bisher irgendwie noch keiner so richtig genannt. Von daher... Was für Links gibt es hier noch? Denik, Enum... Enum Lookup. Also wie gesagt, mir ist nicht so ganz klar, wie der... Aber es gibt... In DNS gibt es halt dieses... dieses DNS-Push oder so heißt es so was. Hier ist ein Link. BenMAT bringt es. Skype interessiert an Videokonferenz. Das finde ich ja interessant, dass Skype daran interessiert ist.
Na, wenn Apple für die... so die... die technischen Details löst und sie dann einfach nur ihre GUI noch drüber kleben.
Na gut, aber das ist natürlich nicht mehr ihr Protokoll.
Ich muss ja auch sagen, wenn ich mal abschweifen darf, ich finde das auch mit diesem... was ich auch sehr beeindruckend fand, ist diese Video- und HD-Foto- und so weiter Geschichte. Das fand ich ja auch... Das fand ich ganz schön krass. Ich bin sowieso ganz schön beeindruckt an den letzten Monaten von dieser fortschreitenden Miniaturisierung. Ich habe mir letztens einen DVB-T-Stick gekauft. Der ist ja wirklich... Du findest ja fast aus der Fingerkuppe nicht mehr. So klein sind die mittlerweile. Und jetzt, was die in so einem Telefon einmauern, dass du da irgendwie HD-Movies schnibbeln und rendern kannst...
Wobei, das Rennern haben sie nicht gezeigt, ich glaube, mit gutem Grund.
Aber egal. Nicht, dass ich jetzt auch Wert darauf legen würde, ob ich auf meinem Telefon HD-Movies schneide, aber dass es prinzipiell geht. Und vor allen Dingen auch dieses... Ich kann mich noch erinnern, als mein Notebook mit iMovie-Videos, wo du über diese Clips slidest und dann die CPU am grünen war und es geht jetzt auf dein Telefon. Das ist schon krass. Und dass sie hier auch Wert gelegt haben, darauf zu betonen, dass sie zwar mehr Megapixel haben, aber das nicht geschafft haben, indem sie den Chip gleichgelassen haben und die Dichte erhöht haben, sondern sozusagen die Pixelgröße immer noch identisch ist. Also hatten sie ja auch extra betont hier beim Kamerasensor-Thema.
Ach so, ja, dass einfach mehr Fläche...
Also da bin ich auch extrem gespannt. Das erste, was ich glaube ich ausprobieren werde, ist auch Foto- und Videokamera, Low-Light-Situations. Also wenn sie das halten, ihr versprechen, dann macht das auch eine ganze Menge Leute glücklich. Plus hier dieses Display, 800 zu 1, Kontrast und so. Also ich... War das das Nexus, was hier bisher die höchste Android-Auflösung irgendwie hatte?
Ich glaube dieses HTC, was das heißt?
Oder das von Motorola? Ich sehe da auch nicht mehr durch.
286 DPI habe ich irgendwie so im Kopf.
Ja, wobei das ja bei diesem Nexus, das war ja irgendwie so...
Das reicht aber auch schon. Ja, das OLED-Display macht halt nicht wirklich alle Farbpixel.
Ist ja auch egal. Ich habe auf jeden Fall schon Android-Displays gesehen, die sahen einfach scheiße doll lecker aus.
Also das war auf dem Milestone auf jeden Fall auch sehr geil.
Ja, genau. Und...
Von der Typo-Auflösung vor allem. Das stimmt. Beim Nexus One ist das auf jeden Fall so.
Und da bin ich auch extrem gespannt, wie sie da jetzt so die Marke setzen. Also Auflösung ist jetzt eh, glaube ich, also mehr braucht man da wirklich nicht mehr. Auf so einem Telefon. Und jetzt noch so Kontrast und Vivid Colors.
Aber was natürlich ein extrem konsequenter Schritt ist, ist halt einfach diese Verdopplung. Was es natürlich auch für die Anwender leichter macht. Oh, ist die Carcassonne ab...
Für die Entwickler. Die Scater einfach doppelt?
Ja, weil wenn du das auf dem iPad spielst, dann hast du da auch irgendwie hohe Auflösungen.
Ernsthaft? Das wäre ein guter Grund, das App auch mal zu starten. Was ich an dem Zusammenhang ganz geil finde, ist mir auch im Urlaub aufgefallen, wird natürlich mit dem iPhone 4 noch mal besser werden. Zwei Jahre hatte ich auf dem Kongress diesen Eindruck. Mit einem iPhone in der Tasche kommt man den ganzen Tag ein. Man kann damit eine kleine Berichterstattung mitmachen. Man kann sein Twitter-Feed füllen. Man kann mit Quick ein paar Videos posten. Man kann so rumrennen auf einer Veranstaltung und keine Live-Berichterstattung machen. Dafür muss man ein Jailbreak machen. Im Urlaub ist mir etwas aufgefallen. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man mit Tweety auch Video-Dienste bedienen kann. Du kannst genauso wie ein Foto hochladen, kannst auch ein Video hochladen. Dann ist das online, dann können sich die Leute das Video angucken.
Und du hast einen LED-Flash, das finde ich auch.
Wobei, da wäre mir ein Xenon-Flash lieber gewesen.
Live-Streaming von Veranstaltungen. Jetzt brauchst du nur noch ein iPhone auf dem Stativ zu schrauben.
Mal gucken, wie es...
Da fehlt noch dieser Einsatzwoll.
Aber Mikrofon kannst du einschleifen über das Headset.
Gibt es so etwas wie Ableton für das iPhone?
Was es für das iPhone gibt, ist ein Programm namens Reporter. Hindenburg heißt das. Hintenburg, mit dem man auch so...
Haste richtig schneiden, da habe ich noch nicht viel mitgemacht.
Mein Gedanke war, warum ich das immer haben wollte, ist die Mikrofonqualität hier eher nur so im Mittel. Aber es gibt ja diesen USB-Adapter-Kit für das iPad, mit dem man SD-Card-Reader und so, wo ja auch dieses USB-Link dabei ist. Und da kann man wohl auch Headsets anschließen, USB-Headsets. Und dann könnte man mit diesem Hindenburg aus dem iPad oder aus dem iPhone ein flottes, kleines Studio machen. Mit OKIA-Soundqualität.
Das ist mir bei diesem ganzen iPhone-iPad-Gerafel immer noch so. Ich finde es natürlich total toll. Noch ein bisschen fehlt. Oder was ich mir noch wünschen würde, wäre noch so irgendwie die Pro-Developer-Version, wo ich auch mal einen Editor irgendwie aufmachen kann, irgendwas compilen kann und so weiter. Und irgendwie so noch ein bisschen... Ob sie das irgendwann mal machen? So noch mal so eine Pro-Version von was? So von dem OS da irgendwie, dass du halt auch einen Editor, eine Shell hast und so weiter, dass du auch so entwickeln kannst auf dem iPad und so.
Eine Nerd-Version meinst du?
Ja, eine Nerd-Version. Ich fände das ja total megamäßig cool, da irgendwie ein Text-Mate drauf zu haben und so weiter. Wenn ich hier sehe, wie Max da drauf tippt und so, für so Kleinigkeiten mal eben auf den Server einloggen und irgendwie einen Bug fixen oder so was, das wäre doch total ideal.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es so zumindest Web-Entwicklungsidee ist oder so was, wird es über kurz oder lang gehen.
Sie könnten doch eine Pro-Version machen. Also ich finde sowieso, die könnten irgendwie... Aber das ist ja die alte Beschwerde der Power-User, wie wir sie ja liebevoll nennen, dass Apple da mehr auf die Power-User noch mal irgendwie gehen könnte.
Ich fand's ja schon lustig, dass Sie jetzt das OS umbenannt haben, iOS. Und ihr erinnert euch, als Sie das iPhone rausgebracht haben, wer hat sich beschwert?
Ach, das ist bald iOS.
iOS ist das Betriebssystem von Cisco.
Ja, die haben den Namen lizenziert.
Haben sie, ja. Diesmal mussten sie sich nicht danach streiten. Haben sie vorher schon drüber nachgedacht. Aber es war erstaunlich, dass Cisco das rausgebracht hat. Ich frage mich, was sie sich dafür haben zahlen lassen. Ich meine, das ist Cisco iOS, das ist das Betriebssystem von allen Cisco-Rautern auf diesem Planeten. Das ist nicht irgendwie so ein unbenutztes Stück Einzelprodukt, das sie nicht wirklich auf dem Markt haben wie beim iPhone, sondern das ist so ihr Betriebssystem. Wenn du heute jetzt das Betriebssystem sagst, ich programmiere für iOS, dann wird kein Mensch mehr, was gemeint ist.
iPhone, sehr gut.
Ja, wobei, das kennt natürlich auch keinen Schwanz.
Vielleicht werden die auch migriert beide und dann wird in Zukunft auf Cisco-Routern ein App-Stock-System.
Oder jedes iPhone kann irgendwie auch Gigabit-Switchen. Richtig Gigabit Ethernet, 10 Gigabit Glasfaser.
Und der Router-Code läuft aus dem Boden.
Du kriegst von Cisco nur noch so ein 19-Zoll-Gehäuse, dann steckst du da so ein 32-Akt-Gehäuse.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen, nur Google hat es irgendwie mit einem Eisenstab bekommen.
Ja, aber die haben ja auch mit einem Eisenstab in Richtung Apple geheilt.
Und jetzt schmollen sie bestimmt total.
Ach Quatsch.
Das ist mit dem Ad-Mob das Schmackdinger.
Ich glaube, das machen die nur für PR. Das ist so wie damals Blur gegen Oasis, Beatles gegen Stones.
Guck doch mal, Google hat sich irgendwie angekackt nach dem Motto, wir gehen jetzt auf euren Markt, wir verkaufen jetzt auch Telefone, oder wir tragen dazu bei, dass Telefone gemacht werden. Sie verkaufen ja eigentlich selber gar nicht so richtig welche. Und wo hat Apple jetzt irgendwie die Sperre zugemacht? Also AdMob darf jetzt erstmal nicht so ohne weiteres weitermachen, so wie sie bisher gemacht haben. Safari kriegt diesen Reader-Modus, wo die Werbung ausgeblendet wird. Safari müssen auch drüber reden.
Wobei das würde ich tatsächlich nicht so auf die...
Nö, würde ich jetzt auch nicht so... Aber es zählt einfach nochmal so ein bisschen zusammen, was halt irgendwie alles so ein bisschen nachbrennen kann. Und Bing wird dann irgendwie auch noch als dritte Option mit dazu geführt. Alles keine bahnbrechenden Neuigkeiten und der Google-Button heißt auch nicht mehr Google-Button in iOS 4.
Sondern Suchen.
Genau, wie er schon immer heißen soll, meiner Meinung nach. Aber, ne? Jetzt müssen sie halt ein bisschen bluten dafür für diese IOConferenz. Das hat ihnen nicht geschmeckt.
Ja, aber ich glaube trotzdem irgendwie... Also stell dir mal vor, es ist wirklich so was wie Stones. Sie fanden so eine Rivalität hoch. Und dann irgendwie die Awareness für beide, sie profitieren beide davon und bashen sich einfach öffentlich mit. Das gab es schon vorher, schon vor 40 Jahren und so haben das die Leute gemacht.
Ich hoffe bloß, dass die Software-Auswahl auf dem iPhone da nicht so sehr drunter leitet.
Stones und Beatles sagst du? Und wer ist Stones und wer ist Beatles?
Ja, das ist die Frage. Je nachdem, wie man so... Also natürlich würde man... Ja, eigentlich schon.
Ich gehe mit den Beatles.
Das war ja wahrscheinlich so die zweitgrößte derartige Realität, aber da bist du wahrscheinlich schon zu jung für...
Ja, da konnte ich mich nicht mehr ganz so einfinden. War das nicht das Gleiche?
Ja, mehr oder weniger nur transponiert in die 90er.
Welches war vorher? Na wer hat zuerst angefangen? Blur oder Oasis?
Ja, weiß ich nicht...
Wer hat wen kopiert?
Das weiß ich nicht. Die haben sich einfach so angezickt halt auch die ganze Zeit. Und die sind scheiße und die können nichts. Und die sind ja selber doof und haben dann so eine Rivalität auch hochgepeitscht.
Ich will diese scheiß Google-Navi. Will ich jetzt auch auf meinem iPhone haben.
Ja, das ist eine Big News wiederum im Android-Lager, dass das jetzt für Deutschland auch freigeschaltet ist. Habt ihr das schon mal irgendwo gesehen?
Ich hab's ja damals mir gehackt, als ich noch das Android hatte. Das hab ich ja mittlerweile verborgt. Und als ich das noch hatte, da gab's ja so eine inoffizielle Maps-Version, die das dann einfach schon konnte. Und diese Navigation, die ist gut.
Also, ich würde ja total geil finden, wenn Apple einfach sagt, pass mal auf, wir pushen jetzt hier Open Street Map und gehen da mal richtig voll in die...
Ja, das werden sie aber wahrscheinlich nicht tun, oder?
Also, weil, also, ich muss ja sagen, so ein bisschen Open Street Map-Zeug, das geht schon echt erstaunlich gut, oder? Es gibt ja jetzt auch erste...
Aber nicht beim Routing und auch nicht beim...
Aber da gibt's schon Sites, also die muss man halt suchen, die gibt's jetzt nicht so auf dem ersten Klick irgendwo schon automatisch drin, hier mal Maps und so weiter, aber es gibt erste Sites, die halt Routing damit machen. Das Problem ist halt, da musst du dich mit Graphen-Theorie im Wesentlichen beschäftigen, weil das ja eben alles auch ein bisschen anders aufgebaut ist und so weiter. Und wenn da Apple jetzt so ein paar smarte Engineers mal draufschmeißt, die eben mal so dieses Number-Crunching und wissen schon, ach, das wär schön.
Apple wird selber in den Navi-Markt reingehen, das glaube ich ja immer noch nicht.
Ja, in den Navi-Markt nicht, aber sie könnten einfach so, so, so nebenbei so ein bisschen pushen.
Die Frage ist, werden sie Google-Navi jetzt überhaupt noch einbauen? Das macht grad nicht so den Eindruck.
Ja, also ich meine, dieses Google Maps auf dem Android unterstützt mittlerweile einige Sachen, die das iPhone Google Maps nicht kann.
Und im Web?
Was ist das?
Na, es gibt bei diesem Android halt so Ebenen, die man einblenden kann mit zusätzlichen Informationen. Also, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel saß gestern rum und wollte wissen, wo ging hier eigentlich mal, hier ging irgendwo die Mauer lang, wo ging die eigentlich lang? Auf einem Android wäre das wahrscheinlich irgendwo ein zusätzlichen Layer, den man sich irgendwo zusammenklickt und dann hat man es und dann sieht man die eingezeichnet.
Also sozusagen so eine Maps-Karte einfach, mit Einblenden sozusagen.
Genau. Und so dieses ganze Zeug, so zusätzliche Informationen und damit verdient Google ja auch echt das Geld über ihre Werbeeinblendung und bei Apple passiert einfach jahrelang auch im Augenblick. Und das liegt, glaube ich, ein bisschen daran, wie Apple tickt. Wir brauchen geschlossene Applikationen, die schick ist und das reicht schon. Es liegt aber auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen daran, weil es nicht im Markt ist. Und diese Navigation, die wäre eigentlich auch cool, wenn sie die drinnen hätten.
Ich meine, wenn Google das wie bei Voice als Web-App sozusagen macht, dass jeder das benutzen kann, egal auf welchem die Web ist.
Es würde ja schon reichen, wenn Apple einfach das entsprechende Programm von Google im App Store approved. Also, das könnten sie ja auch machen. Navigationslösungen gibt es ja auch von anderen Hersteller, können sie ja nun schlecht so tun, als ob sie jetzt Google irgendwie...
Die sollen einfach OpenStreetMap nehmen, das ist ja auch alle drin fast.
Ich habe mir extra für den Urlaub Navigon gekauft. So dieses Navigationssoftware. Und ich bin ja wirklich, also für das Geld, was das kostet, bin ich ja wirklich baffenttäuscht. Was kostet irgendwie die Europa-Version 60 Euro oder so was? Und was das in Spanien an Straßen nicht kannte, also komplette Autobahnabschnitte, die mindestens 10 Jahre in der Planung waren, die dieses System einfach nicht drauf hatte, sondern vor jedem Kreisverkehr. Wer schon mal in Spanien war, der weiß, dass sobald eine Straße mal einen kleinen Winkel drin hat, ist da ein Kreisverkehr. 700 Meter vorher, 500 Meter vorher, 300 Meter vorher kommt eine fette Ansage, an der dritten Ausfahrt bitte raus. Das hat sich natürlich auch dieser Kreisverkehr im Laufe der letzten 10 Jahre mal geändert, sodass du nicht mehr an der dritten, sondern an der vierten Ausfahrt raus musst. Also liebe Navi-Hersteller, und dann so eine Sache wie, du kannst das in der Stadt nicht mal eben als Karten nehmen. Du kannst das nicht nur so wie Google Maps, um mich mal zu orientieren. Da sind Karten drinne mit Straßennamen und allem Pipapo. Die kann man wirklich nur zum Autonavigieren benutzen.
Was ist denn das für eine Scheiße?
Ich muss jetzt an dieser Stelle auch wirklich mal sagen, also alle Leute, die sich da irgendwie beschweren, benutzt OpenStreetMap, tragt dazu bei, gebt denen Geld, gebt denen Hardware, schreibt coole Programme mit OpenStreetMap, weil das ist echt so viel cooler.
Das ist aber immer noch sehr umständlich, da irgendwie beizutragen.
Na, ich weiß nicht, ich finde, das geht mittlerweile zumal jetzt ja auch hier.
Hast du da schon mal was reingegossen?
Ich habe mal einen Fehler gekennzeichnet, der war noch auch relativ kurze Zeit später.
Also, ich habe tatsächlich die iPhone App hier benutzt, dieses, wie heißt es denn, Geo, der auch dieses Offline-Maps oder Off-Maps macht. Wie heißt denn das, Geo, Geo-Log, Trails, Trails. Damit habe ich das gemacht. Und dann halt in diese komische Webseite reingekippt, und die komische Webseite hat damals aber nicht so gut funktioniert, weil ja auch Flash oder ist Flash. Und dann habe ich mir diese Java-Software installiert, und die war aber auch okay. Damit ging das schon. Also klar, es ist jetzt nicht so clicky-bunt, die Fluff-Fluff-Cocoa-App, aber es geht ja, und es ist einigermaßen schnell oder direkt, also du lädst deine Änderung hoch, und alles, was dann noch passieren muss, sind, dass die Teils gerennt werden müssen für alle Zoom-Stufen. Und dann ist es halt drin. Und wie gesagt, als ich jetzt in Polen war, ich habe mir halt den ganzen Autobahnabschnitt, also richtig großflächig ringsrum die Teils acht Zoom-Stufen runtergeladen. Das war dann am Ende irgendwie ein Gigabyte oder mehr. Aber das war halt total cool, weil irgendwann haben wir uns verfahren. So, kein UMTS und nichts, sondern nur GPS ans Fenster gehalten, klick, wo bin ich, irgendwie hast du sofort gesehen, konntest ordentlich reinzoomen. Dann habe ich mir für Krakow, wo ich halt war, auch nochmal so einen vorbereiteten Guide runtergeladen, der in der Abda verfügbar war, aus OpenStreetMap mit allen möglichen Ebenen. Und haste nicht gesehen. Und du kommst halt umhin. Die Daten sind auch einige, also aktuell zumindest, habe ich jetzt in der Phase nichts Unaktuelles gefunden. Das ist voll cool. Also ich bin, nachdem ich überhaupt erstmal verstanden habe, was OpenStreetMap macht, ich habe ja auch eine Zeit lang gedacht, ja, hier, Open Source-Karten, jada, jada. Aber als ich mich damit ein bisschen auseinandergesetzt habe, seitdem bin ich ja totaler Fan. Ich finde ja, alle sollten das machen.
Ja, also ich stimme dir eigentlich total zu. OpenStreetMap ist ganz großartig. Und ich wünschte mir, es gäbe da noch mehr.
Also eine iPhone-App, das für einfach Taggen, so eine richtig gute OpenStreetMap-iPhone-App und Android-App, das wäre es echt.
Was benutzt du? Du benutzt Off-Maps?
Ich glaube, das Gleiche, was halt dieses, also der Typ, dieser Felix Lamoureux, der ist zwar nicht der allerbeste Coder, scheinbar, aber sein Off-Maps oder Offline-Maps, wie es heißt, und Trails benutze ich.
Also ich hatte hier noch eins, warte mal, wie hieß denn das?
Wo habe ich denn mein iPhone hingedrückt? Ich habe vorhin Airplane-Mode angemacht.
Also ich habe hier noch OpenMaps drauf. Das finde ich tatsächlich. Das benutze ich auch. Das sieht relativ gut aus.
Das finde ich besser. OpenMaps finde ich besser. Das funktioniert auch ganz konkret besser im Zooming. Also dieses Ganze, wie sich das Ding so verhält und wie man so hin und her navigiert, ist einfach näher an der Original-Maps-Anwendung dran. Also das OpenMaps ist meiner Meinung nach derzeit das beste Tool, es sei denn, es ist wieder irgendwas rausgekommen, was ich noch nicht kenne.
Also ich habe benutzt... Also ich habe Off-Maps benutzt für jetzt diese Polen-Krakau-Geschichte, weil das halt für mich am einfachsten oder am besten war, zum Teils runterladen, also zum Downloaden von Offline-Maps.
Off-Maps.
Off-Maps heißt das.
Off-Maps. Mit OpenMaps geht das aber auch.
Mit OpenMaps geht das.
Das habe ich jetzt wiederum nicht. Und ansonsten habe ich eben dieses Trails zum Geologgen, wo ich überhaupt langgefahren bin und aufzeichnen, weil das ist halt meiner Meinung nach der beste GPS-Tracker sozusagen.
Ist das genau genug?
Na, du kannst da einstellen. Du kannst da auch richtig viel einstellen, ab wann er überhaupt einen Keypoint anlegen soll, wie viele Abstände, also wie viel Meter Abstand er machen soll, ob du mit dem Auto, mit dem Fahrrad zu Fuß unterwegs bist und hat dann so ein paar Presets schon für die Genauigkeiten und so weiter.
Ich habe das irgendwie als Light-Version mir irgendwann mal geladen, aber dann festgestellt, dass ich das nie so richtig...
Ja, man braucht es nicht oft, aber wenn...
Kostet 3 Euro, aber was ist da so toll dran?
Ja, ich glaube, es wird ein bisschen viel Einfluss darauf nehmen, wie da deine GPS-Strecke aufgenommen wird, in welchen Abständen und so weiter und so fort und mit welcher Genauigkeit mindestens und so eine Geschichten. Dann hast du da halt irgendwie ein echt cool, also finde ich halt ziemlich übersichtlich einfach auch präsentiert nach deinem Trip sozusagen, wo du überall warst. Du hast halt Export, also Interaktionsmöglichkeiten, da gibt es halt dieses Trail Runner auf dem Mac und so ein paar andere Programme, zu denen du irgendwie, ich weiß nicht genau, wie sie das machen, aber du kannst dann zum Beispiel im Trail Runner sagen, hol mal hier die Daten von meinem iPhone und dann transferiert er hier aus diesem Trail die GPS-Strecken raus und es eignet sich dann halt auch genau gut, um das in so Open-Street-Map reinzukippen. Und alle anderen Tracker, die ich bisher hatte, die sahen entweder total dämlich aus, also von der UI völlig unbrauchbar oder waren halt buggy, crashy, keine Ahnung. Also das war das Einzige, was bisher so ziemlich getan hat, was drauf steht, auch wenn der Coda hier und da auch mal...
Also ich hoffe, dass da die Versionen, dass sie das aktualisieren, weil für iOS 4 mit Background, weil das war immer so mein Hauptproblem. Wenn das Ding halt läuft, dann kannst du nicht sagen, was machen und dann kann ich sowas nicht einsetzen. Und wenn die sich alle aktualisieren, dann werde ich da auch mal zuschlagen, glaube ich.
Genau, also das ist tatsächlich genau der größte Punkt.
Dann lasse ich das mitlaufen und dann wird auch mal was. Ich meine, hier ist es auch ein bisschen schwierig, noch Sachen zu finden in Berlin, die noch nicht in OpenStreetMap schon über Gebühr...
Ich habe den Hof hier neben dem Club mit der Pyramide, das habe ich da eingeteckt und den Springbrunnen auf dem einen Hof.
Also Häusergrenzen, das ist das, was hier im Wesentlichen noch fehlt. Und so draußen in der Pampa, was ich zum Beispiel super cool finde, was ja bei OpenStreetMap mega detailliert ist, ist der Berliner Zoo. Da ist ja jedes Gehege, aber hier so im Brandenburg gibt es irgendwie ganz viele solche Sachen und die sind irgendwie gerade alle nicht verzeichnet. Da finde ich es mal ganz super, dass da mal einer betätigen würde. Vielleicht betätige ich mich da selber nochmal.
Genau, alle sollen OpenStreetMap machen.
Genau, wir fordern euch dazu auf. Gleich nachdem ihr eure Flatterblattens geklickt habt natürlich.
So, Safari 5?
Ja, Safari 5, stimmt, muss ich auch noch zusammenfassen.
Das fand ich ja auch total gut, also in jeder Beziehung. Also Reader-Feature, oder wie heißt das?
Ja, ich habe das noch nicht ganz verstanden, worauf dieser Reader eigentlich anspringt.
Erst fest, soweit ich das verstanden habe, oder? Also ich meine, das ist...
Aha, also das bedeutet, dass bei Webseiten, wo es Zusammenfassungen gibt, sie nur den Zusammenfassungen zeigen.
Nee, sie zeigen immer den ganzen Artikel an.
Also ich vermute aber, dass es mit RSS funktioniert. Ich habe es halt noch nicht genau verstanden. Ich habe ein paar Seiten getestet. Ich habe erst spiegel.de gesehen, dass da sofort das Reader-Feature kam. Dann habe ich irgendwie gedacht, wie sieht es denn aus bei der Wikipedia? Weil die haben ja im Prinzip auch RSS. Bei der Wikipedia geht es halt nicht, aber da ist der RSS-Feed auch nicht so... Der hat da nicht so eine chronologische... Also es ist halt was anderes da. Es ist nicht wie bei einer Webseite. Und dann habe ich irgendwo noch von irgendeinem Format oder irgendwas gelesen, womit dieser Reader funktioniert. Jetzt muss ich noch mal kurz googeln, bevor ich hier irgendwie einen ganz großen Quatsch erzähle. Kleinen Moment.
Weißt du da was drüber, Max?
Also ich habe es mir angeguckt, ich fand es als Feature ganz hübsch. Ich behaupte mal, dass es nicht aus dem RSS-Feed raus ist, weil es eben gerade auch auf Seiten ging, die eine Zusammenfassung anbieten. Sie scheinen irgendwie ein bisschen mit hinten rumzuklicken, also dass sie Next-Page-Links automatisch finden.
Aber das Reader-Feature geht halt bei bestimmten Seiten in der Wikipedia geht es dann schon.
Also was sie implementiert, was sie eingebaut haben, ist ein Tool namens Readability.
Also hier geht es nicht.
Das ist so ein Open Source-Tool und das gibt es auch so als Browser-Toolbar-Item. Aber auf was der jetzt eigentlich da springt, ist mir auch noch nicht so ganz klar.
Ich habe jetzt hier bei Recent Changes, nehme an, dass das so ein bisschen AI ist, dass sie hier davon ausgehen, dass es eine Übersichtseite ist.
Aber ich habe gerade eine Seite gefunden, wo das mit dem Reader ging auf der Wikipedia.
Na ja, bei einem kompletten Artikel.
Da wo Experten keine Ahnung haben, worüber sie reden.
Aber hier kommen wir bei Elisabeth II. Weil das ein langer Artikel ist. Ich glaube, die haben eine gewisse Intelligenz, die dann irgendwie Diffs erkennt und dann sagt, alles klar, das ist ein langer Text, den nehme ich mal. Also dass das wirklich nicht einfach so wie in dem RSS-Feed oder nicht so billig ist, sondern wirklich... Was natürlich Reader jetzt argumentiert immer alle, dass das gegen Werbung ist und ich weiß, dass bei Apple auf der Seite steht, dass man da mit Werbung umgehen kann, was natürlich wahrscheinlich viel spannender ist als... Also erstens kriegt man die Inhalte damit, glaube ich, auf dem iPhone ein bisschen hübscher präsentiert, dass man die ein bisschen lesbarer machen kann für die Zukunft mal. Und so die Blindentauglichkeit dürfte sich damit für Safari mal wieder deutlich erhöhen, oder? Wenn du dann so eine App hast, die dir ohne irgendwelche dämlichen Navigationspunkte...
Ich klicke mal auf timgeekheim.de, mal sehen, ob der da auch schon Reader kann.
timgeekheim.de ist gerade nicht zu erreichen wegen eines DNS-Fails.
Geh mal auf mobilemax.de.
Weil DNS-Server nicht funktionieren, die funktionieren sollten. Kannst du dir schon vorstellen, welche? Ja, also ich wollte auch vorhin nicht sagen, dass sie das eingebaut haben, um Werbung auszublenden. Das halte ich für Quatsch. Sie haben das eingebaut, damit sie das haben, was es tut. Dass man einfach komplexe, zugeklatterte Webseiten einfach mal den Inhalt finden kann, weil das ist ja auch so einfach nicht. Und ich finde das super. Mir war dieses Readability-Tool vorher nicht bekannt und mir sind die Methoden, mit denen sie das machen, nicht so ganz klar, aber wenn ich das richtig sehe, haben die da schon so, die erahnen einfach den Content. Die schauen sich irgendwie die Seite an und versuchen rauszukriegen, was das Richtige ist.
Kennt ihr Instapaper? Klar, kennt ihr Instapaper. Das bin ich als großer Freund von geworden, seitdem es das auf dem iPad gibt. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das ein ähnlicher Algorithmus ist. Weil die holen ja auch irgendwie die Inhalte aus der Seite raus.
Aber es muss ja auch einen Weg geben, wenn du jetzt deine Webseite readerfreundlich machen willst. Also, da muss es da irgendwas...
Gibt es da vielleicht bei divalapa.apple.com? Da kann man das ja auch explizit markieren. Also in HTML5 gibt es ja auch entsprechende Text, mit der du deine Navigation und Sidebars und so weiter trennen kannst von deinem eigentlichen Content. Und ich vermute mal, dass auch irgendwelche DIV-Classes dort zur Kenntnis genommen werden.
Weil sagen sie auch echt nicht genau, ne?
Nee, zumindest nicht auf dieser Webseite. Ich habe sie nicht so ganz verstanden.
Da müssen wir nochmal ran.
It's magic.
Ja, it's magic. Aber es gibt ja noch andere coole Features. Und zwar, der Himmel hat sich geöffnet, die Hölle ist zugefroren, sie haben ein Extension-Framework.
Damit hatte ich keine Sekunde gerechnet.
Das war auch so richtig. Es gab ja Rumors dazu. Aber dass sie das wirklich tun...
Aber sie machen es zumindest anders als alle anderen?
Wie Chrome machen sie das so ziemlich.
Was machen sie anders?
Was sie anders machen ist, dass sie nur gesignte Extensions erlauben. Das ist bei den anderen nicht so. Bei allen anderen kannst du auch ungesignte Extensions installieren. Safari installiert nur gesignte Extensions, sodass sie im Zweifelsfall, wenn deine Extension böse ist, diese auch sperren können.
Ich glaube, bei Chrome muss man die auch signen. Zu Entwicklungszwecken kann man sie so rauslassen, aber ich glaube, die muss man signen.
Punkt. Und nur Safari besteht auf das Teilen.
Ich glaube, dann gibt man sie nicht installiert. Doch. Are you completely sure?
Das ist das, was ich gelesen habe.
Im Internet? Nein. Vielleicht machen sie es einfach schwer, aber ich habe ja schon mal eine Chrome-Extension geschrieben. Und als ich die dann rausschmeißen wollte, habe ich die selbstverständlich gesigned.
Man muss sie signen, bei Chrome. Du kannst sie signen. Also Dirk Jäckel sagt gerade hier, jetzt habe ich seinen Klarnamen verraten, sorry, sagt gerade im Chat, man muss sie signen. Und Dirk ist auch hier voll.
Aber man kann selbstsigned verwenden. Ja klar, du kannst selbstsigned... Ja, aber selbstsigned ist wie nicht... Also, eine Safari-Extension muss mit einem gültigen Developer-Key gesigned werden, der von Apple gesigned ist. Das heißt, der Safari rennt nur Extensions, die in irgendeiner Form auf die Signatur von Apple zurückzuführen sind.
Aha, jetzt haben wir es mal auseinandergegeben.
Ich meine, selbstsigned gilt für mich nicht als gesigned, aber ich verstehe die technische Detailversesenheit. Also selbstsigned ist möglich. Und selbstsigned ist aber Quatsch, weil selbstsigned ist wie nicht gesigned.
Zumindest in dem Kontext.
Ja, das ist, wenn du selber unterschreiben kannst, dann ist es Quatsch. Du darfst nur mit etwas unterschreiben, was dir jemand unterschrieben hat, dass du ein Developer bist. Und in diesen ganzen Safari Extensions...
Das sind einfach zwei unterschiedliche Aufgaben, die damit erfüllt werden. Also beim Selfsigned zum Beispiel kann ich nicht ein Update nachschieben. Ich kann sagen, ich bin mir... also... Ich kann beweisen, dass ich... dass das wirklich ein Update ist für die Extension, die du schon installiert hast.
Das kannst du auch sonst. Nur, dass du ein Zertifikat hast, was von Apple unterschrieben ist. Aber jetzt kann der Safari weiß, bei einer Extension, ob da ein bei Apple registrierter Developer das macht. Wohlgemerkt, das bedeutet nicht, dass es so ist wie beim iPhone und dem App Store. Ja, dass Apple die abnehmen muss, sondern du kannst einfach mit deinem Account, den du hast, mit einem eigenen lokal agierenden Tool, ohne dass du bei Apple was einreichen musst, kannst du dir eine Extension bauen und designen, mit deinem Developer-Ki.
Vor allem mit Web-Technologie, also auch nicht mal irgendwie irgendwelche komischen Voodoo-Geschichten, sondern JavaScript, HTML, CSS, XML und so weiter. Genau, ja, das ist ja auch gehört sich auch so. Und natürlich dann eben auch noch sagen sie ja irgendwie Sandbox, ne, das ist irgendwie genau Signed-and-Sandbox, das heißt, selbst wenn du irgendwelchen Crap programmierst, machen sie es wahrscheinlich ähnlich wie mit den Flash-Plug-in-Prozessen, die dann einfach killen, aber der Browser halt weiterläuft.
Genau, beziehungsweise sie bedienen sich explizit dieses Sandboxing-Features von 10.6. Das ist ein Extensions für den Safari. Und hier ist es vorstellbar, dass das kommt.
Halt dich auch für vorstellbar.
Es ist aber auch vorstellbar, dass es erstmal über einen Store geht.
Es ist auch vorstellbar, dass es noch bis iOS 5 oder 6 dauert, bis das kommt.
Bis iOS nicht mehr iOS heißt.
Also Adblock und diese eine Extension, die jetzt gerade rausgekommen ist.
Hast du schon irgendeine gefunden, die wirklich sinnvoll ist? Ja, sag mal.
Also ich benutze Adblock tatsächlich und finde, das funktioniert.
Das gab es aber irgendwie nicht in Kompiliert.
Doch, mittlerweile schon.
Und was richtig geil ist, ist dieses, wie heißt es doch gleich, wenn du links auf diesen Web-Preview von iTunes Store Applications klickst.
Achso, und dass dann iTunes nicht mehr startet.
Dass dann nicht das iTunes mit automatisch startet.
Oh ja, stimmt, davon habe ich auch gelesen.
Ja, toll, toll, toll.
Firebug für Safari wäre natürlich nochmal so richtig geil.
Das gibt es doch schon. Das ist doch build-in. Webinspector.
Ja, aber er kann nicht alles.
Der kann sogar mehr.
Ja, aber er kann auch einige Dinge nicht. Ich hätte so gerne beide parallel.
Also ich finde ja, ich brauche jetzt keinen Firebug mehr. Ich bin ja voll runter von Firebug. Ich finde ja Webinspector ist der new Firebug.
Webinspector ist sehr, sehr geil. Definitiv. Was hat denn... Also zum Beispiel was Firebug kann, was Webinspector nicht kann, wenn du... Du gehst auf eine Seite und lässt dir irgendwas anzeigen, zum Beispiel eine Konsolen-Message oder irgendwie so was. Und er macht einen Redirect auf eine andere Seite. Dann ist die Wiederweg-Nachricht. Du kannst sie im Zweifelsfall nicht lesen. Und bei Firebug kannst du so einen Button behalten oder so was, oder dauerhaft. Und mit dem bleibt die Nachricht dann auch auf dem zweiten Bildschirm stehen, sodass du auch über mehrere Redirects hinweg deine Konsolenausgaben und Ähnliches weitererhältst. Also es gibt so ein paar Features, die sind einfach, also es ist tatsächlich nicht viel und es ist bestimmt ein Stück weit eine Glaubensfrage, aber ich hätte trotzdem gerne beide. Weil der Webinspektor hat definitiv auch einige Vorteile gegenüber Firebug, das möchte ich um Himmels willen keine Sekunde lang bestreiten. Und ich nehme sie beide.
Ich bin, einfach weil dieser Firefox so langsam auch immer ist, wenn ich mir einfach Webkit pänge. Und vor allen Dingen der Webinspektor, der ist ja auch bei Chrome so, ne?
Der sieht halt genauso aus.
Das finde ich ja auch schon mal sympathisch.
Ja, was ich ganz geil finde bei Safari 4, haben ja alle gesagt, ist schnell. Und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, mag sein, dass das schnell ist, aber nicht bei mir. Safari 5 ist auch auf meinem Rechner plötzlich schnell.
Ich benutze eh immer das Nightly-Bild von daher.
Ja, aber auch so dieser Safari-Teil, bis diese merkwürdige Bilder da aufging.
Genau, ich sehe es gerade wieder, das neue coole Feature, der blaue Ladebalken ist zurück.
Aber das konnte man doch auch irgendwie über die Einstellung...
Nein, bei dem letzten nicht mehr.
Ging nicht mehr? Konnte man über die Einstellung einstellen?
Ah, den haben sie wieder geholt, finde ich auch. Voll sympathisch. Und was gab es denn noch für neue Features in dem Safari? Bing?
Endlich eine Microsoft-Zuchtmaschine und Safari drin.
Wobei, das Wichtige, Apple-Fanboy ist ja Google-Evil und da muss man das auch einstellen, oder?
Eigentlich schon, eigentlich müssen wir jetzt mal kurz...
Nur was tief absegnet ist.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich immer noch so, was durfte man früher bei Bing nicht suchen? Ich glaube, nach Strumpfhose durfte man, konnte man bei Bing nicht suchen.
Ich mache mal Bing.
Bing ist tatsächlich nicht so schlecht, also von allen Suchmaschinen.
Erst mal gucken, ob der Mobamex findet.
Ich habe das beobachtet bei ein paar Webseiten, die ich hoste. Am Anfang war es so, ihr könnt euch nennen, als QL kam und wir sagten, wir machen es noch besser als Google. Ich habe in dem Moment die Web-Server-Logs beobachtet und QL kam nie vorbei. Google hat gigabitweise Traffic gemacht und alles gespidert, dreimal täglich oder noch öfter. QL nie. Dann kamen hier die Bing-Jungs an. Die haben am Anfang auch nicht viel mehr gemacht als QL-Jungs, aber mittlerweile sind die ziemlich nah dran oder überholen Google beim Spidern, zumindest auf den Hosts, die ich unter Kontrolle habe. Was ich schon mal krass finde. Das zeichnet sich auch bei den Resultaten ab. Die sind ziemlich gut. Im Vergleich zu allen anderen Suchmaschinen, die ich bisher ausprobiert habe, kommt Bing am nächsten tatsächlich ran an Google.
Ich habe jetzt auch auf dem iPhone. Kann ich jetzt auch bei Safari Bing einstellen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Suchmaschine, Google, da gibt es Bing. Jetzt gucke ich mir mal an, wie das iPhone optimierte Bing aussieht. Da bin ich ja mal, oh Gott, oh Gott, jetzt steht da Bing.
Ich habe ja letztes Mal schon erzählt, dass ich mir auch Silverlight installiert habe.
Warum ist das eigentlich nicht auf dem iPhone? Ich finde ja immer diese Diskussion, die jetzt, glaube ich, jetzt auch vorbei ist. Oder diese Flash-Diskussion?
Sie fängt an, sich im Kreis zu drehen.
Sie dreht sich wunderbar im Kreis. Aber was ich plötzlich immer so lustig finde, ist bei den Leuten, die der Meinung sind, das müsste jetzt unbedingt Flash auch aufs iPhone. Warum die dann nicht auch Silverlight, Shockwave-Direktor und Real Player?
Also wenn du jetzt die Diskussion hier aufmachst, dann kann ich die auch nochmal aufmachen.
Ich mache sie nicht auf.
Fehlinterpretation hinlegen und dann...
Ja, wir lassen es lieber. Ich hoffe, wir lassen es lieber. Für die Flatter-Quote. Klickt jetzt auf Flatter, wenn ihr die übliche Swiss-Session zwischen Tim und Max Harbert habt.
Wir streiten uns auf der Stelle, wenn er nicht sofort 20 Euro da ist.
Über für eine Stunde.
Oder andersrum. Wir können ja nochmal einen expliziten Flatter-Button nur dafür aufmachen.
Wir machen einen Podcast raus. Die Flash-Diskussion, wo wir die ganze Zeit nur da sitzen und die ganze Zeit...
Also wir machen zwei Flatter-Button. Wir machen einen, wir sollen dann streiten.
Wir können noch mal ein bisschen über IOS reden. Ich weiß, ich hab's jetzt alle nicht ausprobiert, aber Fulldust fand ich am Anfang total scheiße, finde ich mittlerweile total toll.
Das ist das erste, was ich hier in Angriff genommen habe, muss ich sagen. Ich hab so ein dermaßen überladenen Homescreen-Kram und so viel, was ich eigentlich ganz gerne mal weggesortiert bekommen hätte.
Also ich bin jetzt so weit, dass ich glaube ich meine Startseite, das ist mein ersten Screen, nie wieder verlassen muss. Da ist jetzt...
Ihr Glücklichen.
Ja, total viele Ordner. Und ich hab mir ein tolles Hintergrundbild reingepappt.
Ich dachte mir hier mal, bei meinem schönen alten iPhone 3G, wenn ich jetzt kein Multitasking haben kann und so, dann will ich auch nicht iPhone 4.
Aber es gibt ja noch keine Ups mit Multitasking, ne?
Ne, so richtig noch nicht. Also das wundert mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen, weil es gibt jetzt Rotation-Log. Ja, aber nur für Hochformat.
Nur für Hochformat, ja. Das ist schon mal die halbe Miete.
Ach, das kriege ich auch dann aber, ne? Also ich kriege alles außer Multitasking.
Wie meinst du das, ich auf dem 3G?
Na, hier mit meinem iPhone 3G. Ich habe einen alten Computer und ein altes iPhone.
Also du kriegst keine Hintergrundbilder hinter dem Homescreen? Und? Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass du diese Steuerung, diese Rotation-Log, da kommt man ja auch nur ran, wenn man hier die Multitasking-Steuerung auswählt und dann nach links geht.
Ja, das hast du dann aber dann auch.
Aber wenn er kein Multitasking hat, wieso soll er dann diese Doppelquick-Kraft machen? Eigentlich hast du gar keinen Feature von dem neuen.
Das wird schon kommen.
Es ist wenigstens schneller, das war ja auch mal was. Ich will ein iPhone 4 jetzt schnell...
Du hast irgendwas mit An...
Ein anderes iPhone.
Ach so, ein anderes iPhone.
Mit Android werde ich nicht warnen. Das ist zwar alles ganz schön und gut, und ist ja auch super, aber...
Ich habe ja mal in die Google-Press-Abteilung eine Mail geschrieben, dass sie mir noch mal ein Testgerät zuschicken sollen. Ich habe noch nicht mal eine Antwort bekommen von den blöden Arschlöchern.
Ich dachte, sie bewerfen einen mit...
Ich dachte das auch. Ich dachte so, ja, wie viele brauchst du denn? Und bis wann? Nee, gar nichts. Nicht mal antworten. Das finde ich wirklich hart für eine Presseabteilung, deren einzige Aufgabe ist, auf solche Anfragen zu reagieren. Es gibt eine Rechtscheibprüfung jetzt hier im iPhone OS auch wie auf dem iPad. Und die nutze ich auf dem iPad, nutze ich die sogar ziemlich häufig. Also, ich finde das schick, dieses iPhone OS 4.
Aber bei Podcasts hat sich nichts verändert. Jetzt kommt der Test.
Also, ich bin echt eher scharf auf neue Hardware, aber ich bin halt auch... Ich habe halt so alte Haare.
Die sollen endlich mal die Podcasts richtig...
Eigentlich könnten wir auch noch mal darüber reden, was wir nicht vorgestellt haben, nämlich das Bluetooth-Touchpad, Multitouchpad. Darauf habe ich ja schon ein bisschen...
Ich habe mir das Foto gesehen, habe mir gesagt, das ist ein Fake.
Was haben Sie nicht vorgestellt? Aber kann ich jetzt meine Bluetooth-Tastatur perren mit meinem iPhone?
Ja, das sollte gehen.
Na los, Live-Demo. Wir brauchen hier noch Video, finde ich auch.
Dann atme ich aber schwer.
Film ist begeistert.
Dann atme ich schwer.
Wie geht's?
Aber dieses Touchpad, das ist so dämlich, weil das sieht ja so aus wie so eine Tastatur und wie diese Rolle da hinten dran, die ja nur so einen Durchmesser hat. Da hast du hier vorne so ein relativ kleines Touchpad dran. Das wäre so ein Winkel gewesen. Das wäre ein Winkel von 6, 7 Grad gewesen für ein Touchpad. Ein Touchpad muss gefälligst gerade auf dem Tisch liegen. Muss horizontal sein. Ich wünsche mir auch ein externes. Ich wünsche mir eine Tastatur mit Touchpad unten dran. Aber so dieses Foto, was wir da gesehen haben, von irgendeinem Gerät, ist natürlich geil, dass man mittlerweile Apple-Geräte faken kann, indem man einfach eine Fläche nimmt.
Wie bringt man die Bluetooth-Tastatur in Sync-Modus?
Ich glaube, Einschalt-Taste irgendwie.
Lange gedrückt halten.
Ah, nee, das ist, wenn er mal den Akku schneller entlernen will.
Aus.
So, mal gucken, was er sagt.
Nicht gekoppelt. Gar nicht, dass Koppeln dann schon gekoppelt ist.
Hast du eigentlich die Tastatur mit einem iPad verbunden?
Aber krass, guck mal, wie groß sieht da dieses Bing-Feature?
Das habe ich schon mal gemacht.
Ich meine, ich habe einen Full-HD-Display. Und wenn ich hier auf apple.com bei Safari New Features browse, ist hier irgendwie dieses Slide zu Bing Search.
Melli, ich habe mitgekriegt, dass du es schon eingestellt hast.
Reden wir jetzt eigentlich gerade total durcheinander?
Also Tim versucht, seine Bluetooth-Tastatur mit dem iPhone zu fällen.
Ich gucke mal im Chat, ob die schon genervt sind.
Ja klar, die sind immer genervt.
Das ist der beste Teil von Mobile Max. Das war nur einer.
Muss man hier Bluetooth ausschalten. Hoffentlich geht das wenigstens.
Erst entkoppeln, dann mit neuem Gerät koppeln. Auskoppeln, einkoppeln.
Schließt doch lieber per USB an. Das wäre meine spannende Frage, ob das geht.
Was?
USB-Tastatur an iPhone? Also das ist ja nicht total abwegig, weil es geht ja am iPad. Kann man ja eine USB-Tastatur anschließen.
Ich gucke jetzt nochmal bei Flitter. Auf nochmal ein bisschen hier das Konfusionsniveau zu erhöhen.
Ich habe mein Keyboard gekoppelt.
Nein!
Tipp du Luder!
So, jetzt guck mal, ob sich die Tastatur ändert, wenn du probierst, eine URL einzugeben.
Probier mal Al-Tap, äh, Apfel-Tap. Apfel-Tap, geht Apfel-Tap? Multitasking.
Apfel-Tap.
Das geht nicht.
Gilt Apfel-A?
Apfel-A. Und geht auch irgendwie Shift? Ja! Man kann sogar mit der Tastatur hier die Selektion...
Kann man Reverse löschen?
Kann man auch sehr... Man kann sogar ein ganzes Wort nach vorne......wenn du Escape drückst.
Kann man Reverse löschen? Ja, bestimmt, ne? Wie machst du das? Geh mal hoch in die Mitte so, und jetzt drück mal Fn und Delete. Also halt...
Ah, nee.
Ja, geht auch voll.
Nee, geht nicht. Es gibt keinen Delete.
Und wenn du Fn drückst, auch nicht?
Ja, das hab ich gemacht. Ich weiß schon, was du meinst. Ich benutze das den ganzen Tag, aber das geht hier leider nicht. Das ist sehr schade. Das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Apple bringt eine neue iPhone- auf iOS-Version raus.
Jetzt mit Rückwärtslöschen.
Nee, aber das ist aber super, weil, ich meine, damit wird das iPad...
Das iPad oder das iPhone?
Das iPad weniger Löschen bringen. Weil so kann ich dann halt wirklich auf meinem iPhone entspannt mal einen längeren Text...
Vor allen Dingen, es gibt ja auch diese Ausroll-Tastatur.
Ich wollte jetzt mal gucken...
Ich finde diese Apple-Tastatur schon ganz super. Und ich würde mir jetzt grad noch eine dritte dazu kaufen. Ich habe mir wirklich für jeden Computer so einen Teil geholt. Das bringt es irgendwie. Ja, liebe Zuhörer, ihr merkt schon, wir sind hier so total in so einem Lab-Modus, weil alles muss ausprobiert werden.
Das ist wie Weihnachtswidrate.
Haben wir nicht irgendwie ganz viel schon geredet?
Ja, wir haben auch schon ganz viel geredet.
Wir haben schon eine verdammt lange Sendung hier schon wieder am Start, schon über zwei Stunden.
Haben wir denn noch irgendwas, was noch fehlt?
Ich gucke mal kurz in meine Notizen.
Bist du jetzt nicht mit dem iPhone gepaart?
Ach so, jetzt muss ich wieder meinen...
Du hast zu wenige Tastaturen. Das ist das nächste Bluetooth-Gerät, dass man so einen Tastaturswitch hat.
Geht das auch mit meinem iPhone dann?
Das ist ein Feature, das auch mit deinem iPhone geht.
Oh, ein Bluetooth-Mouse.
Dann muss ich nicht mehr tanzen. Dann kannst du endlich deine Magic-Pause nicht mehr. Reader hatten wir... Ich hab mir Numbers fürs iPad gekauft.
Ich hab nur eine einzige Sache noch nicht erwähnt, die ich hier auf meiner Liste habe.
Und die wäre Tim. Das erfahren wir nach der Pause.
Klicken Sie jetzt den Flatter-Button.
So, die Werbepause ist vorbei. Das haben wir im Podcast rausgeschnitten.
Puh, dieses Produkt muss ich mir aber sofort kaufen gehen.
Ich weiß nicht, habe ich schon erwähnt, es gab noch eine zweite Änderung in den SDK-Rules.
Achso, ja. Nee, hast du noch nicht erwähnt.
Und zwar haben sie...
Eine kleine Entspannung.
Eine kleine Entspannung hervorgerufen. Genau, und zwar, jetzt weiß ich gerade wieder nicht, wie die Formulierung war, aber im Kern haben sie andere Programmiersprachen innerhalb von Apps wieder zugelassen. Also sie haben ja diese Regel eingeführt, um irgendwie erstmal Flash zu... auszuschließen. Und haben die Regel von, es darf kein interpretierter Code in der Applikation drin sein, es ist JavaScript, haben sie geändert oder ergänzt. Das ist wieder hier so legal gibberisch. Ich lese das mal quer. No, maybe then...
Ja, jetzt weiß ich, warum wir es nicht drin hatten, weil das ein Lesen hatte.
Hat man das gerade gehört? Es darf interpretierter Code in der App verwendet werden, wenn es in einer begrenzten Art und Weise stattfindet. Also limited way.
Die fanden den C64-Emulator einfach zu cool. Oder diese Arcade-Maschine. Die hatten auch noch diesen geilen Hubschrauber.
Haben sie den rausgespürt?
Zwischendurch war der doch immer mal wieder irgendwie...
Also ich weiß, dass er ganz am Anfang in Syrien war.
Sie haben doch erst erlaubt, dass sie einen eigenen Code auf der C64-Shell haben. Deswegen ist es ja gleich mal rausgeflogen. Dann haben sie das wieder ausgebaut. Dann ging das als Easter Egg noch. Dann ist er noch mal rausgeflogen. Da gab es auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Hin und Her mit diesem C64-Ding. Dann dachten sie sich, wenn die Leute sowas machen, stimmt.
Aber die haben noch so einen In-App-Store da drin. In den C64-Emulator, oder?
Der ist auf jeden Fall cool.
Naja, ich habe mal geschadet.
Also ich denke, im Wesentlichen ist das jetzt erstmal die Klausel für Games, die Script-Engines drin haben. Das sind so viele.
Also sie wollen...
Gerade Lua, aber auch viele andere Programmiersprachen sind einfach so als Embedded Scripting-Engine. Das ist einfach Standard.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, wieso klatscht das gegen Flash?
Die ursprüngliche Regelung klatscht gegen Flash.
Ja, aber die doch jetzt, wenn ich das...
Achso, Entschuldigung, ich habe... Nein, nein, das geht gegen... Gegen was ging mir das eigentlich? Das ging einfach gegen andere Scriptsprachen.
Gegen andere Scriptsprachen. So, jetzt sind andere Scriptsprachen erlaubt. Solange, quasi...
Es ging gegen Java zum Beispiel und so.
Ja, jetzt ist es... Solange du... Habe ich das richtig verstanden? Solange du...
Es war gegen Flash, oder? Die Regelung, die war ja schon älter. Die war schon vorher drin.
Also das hat jetzt nichts mit diesem Cross-Compile, Cross-Tools zu tun.
Ach so, da gibt es noch eine Extra-Stack.
Es ist ein bisschen unübersichtlich. Nein, das ist irgendwie 332. Das andere war irgendwie 332. Aber das muss halt sein. Wobei, es gibt immer noch so Sachen, wo man sich fragt, ob es da eine Möglichkeit gäbe. Hatte ich zum Beispiel gestern noch im Gespräch sowas wie Processing. Was ja im... Das ist schon sehr geil, wie er im Media-Artist-Bereich extrem verbreitet ist. Und nicht auch Arduino und so weiter. Die arbeiten damit in den Sachen, das halt in Java derzeit implementiert ist. Es gibt wohl auch Implementierungen in anderen Programmiersprachen. Im Prinzip bräuchte die Sprache eine Implementierung in Objective-C. Genau, es gibt auch eine in Javascript. Ich hab bloß gehört, dass das noch nicht so... Gut, vielleicht kommt das ja noch. Ich weiß es nicht. Oder es erbarmt sich irgendjemand, der implementiert das noch mal in C.
Ich weiß nicht, WebKit kann noch... Oh, WebGL, oder? Ah, die sind noch dabei, stimmt. Im WebKit-Repo gibt's WebGL schon als Patch-Set. Man kann sich da sozusagen mit reinkompilen, wenn man da die Special Compile Flex baut. Und WebGL ist ja gerade so der Underdog, der gerade kommt. Und wenn das drin ist, wenn dein Browser dann WebGL kann, dann ist ja eh die Himmel und Tor offen. Dann glaube ich, poppender Frameworks für sowas dann noch erst recht aus allen Ecken und Enden. Also, ich glaube hier, wie heißt das? Processing.js, das hat ja dieser John Rizik von jQuery gemacht. Und ich habe mir das auch schonmal angeguckt, und es ist gar nicht so verkehrt. Aber ich glaube, das so richtig fliegt die Kuh, wenn dann wirklich WebGL drin ist, im Browser. Ich glaube, auch bei den anderen Browser-Herstellern war da so eine kleine Tendenz schon zu vernehmen, dass das kommt. Ich weiß nicht, ob bei Firefox die da schon weiter sind sogar. Na, Chrome ist ja eh WebKit, also von daher, also die, die WebKit benutzen, die werden das dann schon auch alle drin haben, denke ich mal. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall da Bewegungen im WebKit, Trepo und so weiter.
Was wir jetzt natürlich überhaupt nicht mehr geschafft haben gerade, aber ich würde sagen, das rauert ja nicht mehr auf, diesen WebM-Codec.
Doch, darüber müssen wir noch reden.
Das kann nicht gut sein. Das hat Apple, das hat Steve nicht für gut befunden und dann kann das auch nicht gut sein.
Fertig.
Also ich frage mich ja, was Googles Intention ist. Ganz ehrlich, also ich, ich glaube denen nicht. Aber vielleicht liege ich auch falsch. Ich bin mir nicht so richtig sicher. Kurz nochmal zusammenfassen, was ist passiert. Auf der Google IO hat Google dann das gemacht, was ja Richard Stolman von ihnen gefordert hat, dass sie diese On-Tour-Bude, die sie gekauft haben, dass sie ihren VP8-Codec, den sie da entwickelt haben, den bis dahin noch keiner so richtig gesehen hat, dass sie den doch mal bitte Open-Sourcen. Das haben sie dann getan, haben das Ding WebM genannt und auch gleich großkrotzig angekündigt, dass sie irgendwie ihren ganzen YouTube-Kram darauf konvertieren, dass sie den Source-Code-Releasen, lalala, und haben also eine lange Liste von...
Dass das ein Flow angebaut wird und dass es in Firefox angebaut wird.
Genau, eine lange Liste von Unterstützern, Opera und so weiter. Dann hat irgendjemand Microsoft noch so ein komisches Zitat aus der Nase gezogen, das ja so interpretiert wurde, als würde Microsoft das jetzt auch unterstützen. Wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe, haben sie nur gesagt, dass, wenn das auf dem Betriebssystem sozusagen vorhanden ist, dass sie das dann auch mitnutzen würden. Sprich, wenn der Computer einen Web-End-Plugin hat, dann würden sie das auch bei HTML5 durch... Dann kann auch der Windows-Media Player das. Nee, dann würden sie es halt auch bei HTML5 durchreichen. Das ist ja auch nochmal so ein... Das ist schon eine Aussage. Genau, schon mal eine Aussage. Ich frage mich halt nur so richtig, ob das überhaupt eine Chance hat. Das ist jetzt eine sehr schwierig zu beurteilende Geschichte. Ich bin ja in gewisser Hinsicht... Ich würde es ja viel lieber sehen, man würde sich mal endlich auf was einigen. Und dadurch ist natürlich diese Einigung noch weiter in die Zukunft verschoben worden.
Ja, aber ich meine, H264 hat nun seine Nachteile, was die Lizenzierung angeht.
Das ist richtig.
Aber es hat auf der anderen Seite alle fucking Major Entertainment Cooperations hinter sich und die werden jetzt nicht H264 sterben lassen, sondern werden das schön weiter pushen. Also es wird beides...
Ja, vor allem WebM ist ja... Klar, es gibt jetzt Source-Code. Habt ihr euch diesen Blogpost durchgelesen von diesem X264-Developer, der das mal auseinandergenommen hat?
Der ein bisschen drüber gejammert hat?
Gejammert ist gar kein Ausdruck. Der hat sich das irgendwie angeschaut und hat einfach nur gekotzt. Also erstmal, was so seine Kerntese ist, WebM, V8, ist technisch in etwa so auf der Höhe von H264 Baseline-Profile. Zum Verständnis, H264 ist so eine Art Codec-Framework, in der es so verschiedene Stufen gibt und Profiles definieren, welche Features genutzt werden können. Es gibt so eine ganze Reihe von einzelnen Features und im Baseline-Profile sind im Wesentlichen die der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner. Ja, der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner in Hinsicht auf, die sind weitgehend auch kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Das sind sozusagen eher so die, für die jetzt nicht noch mal zusätzliche Lizenzkohle gezahlt werden muss und die sind auch auf die Fähigkeiten von mobilen Abspielgeräten hin optimiert. Wobei es ja schon beim iPod 5. Generation, der der erste war, der Video hatte, gab es ja schon diese Einschränkung, dass sie im Prinzip zwar Baseline Profile spielten, bloß mit der Ausnahme eines einzigen Features, was im Baseline Profile vorgesehen ist, was sie nicht konnten. Und das waren Referenz-Frames. Da kannst du nämlich laut Baseline Profile mehrere davon haben und sie waren aber nur in der Lage einen einzigen zu machen. Das ist sozusagen, du merkst dir so ein Frame und kannst dich dann später darauf beziehen und sagen, jetzt bitte nochmal diesen Frame. Also wenn immer wieder was nochmal kommt, kannst du dich eben darauf beziehen. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr nettes Feature, aber auch das musst du dir irgendwie merken. Du brauchst dafür halt einen Buffer und der iPod 5G unterstützt halt nur einen davon. Wie auch immer. VP8, sprich WebM, sei technisch nicht nur von der Qualität her vergleichbar, sondern das war seine Aussage, arbeitet letztlich mit denselben Strategien und seiner Meinung nach no way, dass das Ding durchkommt, dass die Patent-Holder, die bei H264 mit im Pool sind, dass sie das einfach vorbeiziehen lassen und sagen, damit haben wir nichts zu tun.
Zumal ja Steve gesagt hat irgendwo mal, dass jetzt gerade schon so ein Patent-Pool da aufgebaut wird. Genau.
Und ich glaube auch, dass das am Rollen ist. Nur gesehen hat diesen noch keiner, also bisher wird er wohl noch gesammelt.
Wobei, gegen Ogg und Teora und wie sie nicht alle heißen, wird ja auch schon so, ja wir sammeln da schon, wir werden da mal im Wald mal unsere Patent-Pool.
Na gut, aber jetzt hat sich halt einer tatsächlich von den Großen mal rausgewagt, bei dem es auch was zu holen gäbe, im Zweifelsfall. Also wenn du Joe Random verklagst, dann ja gut.
Genau. Und das ist nämlich jetzt wirklich so das Ding. Also alles wird sich jetzt daran messen. Im Prinzip sind sie jetzt gezwungen, gegen Google vorzunehmen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich erwarte diesen Moment, weil es jetzt einfach mal dann auch nötig wäre, hier mal klar Schiff zu machen. Wobei, es ist nicht so, dass das nicht schon mal gab. Es gab das schon mal diesen Fall. Da hieß es bloß nicht WebM, sondern VC1. Das war was Microsoft mit der HD-DVD versucht hat, durchzubringen. Also known as Windows Media, WMV. Das haben sie ja dann mal einer Standardisierungsbehörde dann auch mal überlassen. Und hier, wir hätten jetzt auch mal einen Standard-Vorschlag. Und dann hieß das eben VC1. Den wollten sie quasi auch einfach so rausgeben, so nach dem Motto, die Patente von den anderen, die gehen uns nichts an. Dann kam die MPEG 4 LA und hat gesagt, Guten Tag! So, und dann war's das eben. Und dann mussten die sich auch auf einen Patentpool einlassen. Also auch für VC1 gibt es einen Patentpool, der die Firmen, die da eben Gewichte einer Wachschale haben, entsprechend bedient. Das interessante ist, auf dieser H264-Liste der Patentholer steht auch Apple. Mir ist nicht ganz klar, was Apple eigentlich mit H264, was die dabei gesteuert haben, weil Codex haben die nie entwickelt. Das Einzige, meiner Meinung nach, also das Einzige, von dem ich meinte, zu wissen...
Den Glossy-Button-Code.
Das Einzige, von dem ich sicher weiß, dass Apple das im ganzen MPEG-4-Patentpool mit drin, also im MPEG-4-Pool mit drin hat, das ist ihr Dateiformat. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob sie darauf Patente haben und Royalties einfordern, aber das ist ja, also MP4 ist im Prinzip eine Weiterentwicklung vom MOF-Format.
Nee, wenn sie wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal patentiert haben.
Weiß ich gar nicht, ob das so patentierbar ist und ob sie das so patentiert haben. Ja, das mag sein. Ich weiß es einfach nicht.
Also ich habe auch nur gelesen, dass sie da mit so ein paar Stecken im Feuer mit drin stecken, sozusagen. Aber das ist eher so eine Zweckgemeinschaft an sich sowieso.
Also Apple ist definitiv nicht die Firma, die am meisten Code daraus zieht. Sondern das sind eben so Philips, Sony, Lalala und Fraunhofer vor allem. Also die ganzen Buden, die einfach wirklich auch Codec-Entwicklung machen. So, und ich vermute, dass die Google gegen Google angehen werden. Nun ist ja Google auch nie blöd und die werden sich, die meinen ja auch, sie hätten sich das angeschaut. Und ihrer Meinung nach wäre das irgendwie alles okay. Glaub ich bloß nicht. Also glaube ich, in dem Moment, wo die MPEG-4-LA ankommt und Google den Stinkefinger zeigt, dann fange ich an, das zu glauben. Aber nach dem, was ich gelesen habe, bei diesem X64, X264-Developer...
Das ist ein Entwickler und kein Patentexperte.
Ja gut, aber der kann bewerten, ob die Methoden, die VP8 anwendet, ähnlich sind, wie die, die er den ganzen Tag implementiert.
Das mag ja sein, aber es ist trotzdem noch ein Unterschied, ob das auch von irgendwelchen Patenten abgedenkt ist.
Ich habe nur versucht, ein bisschen breiter darüber nachzudenken, was eigentlich Googles Intention ist. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, Google ist jetzt doch nicht evil. Don't be evil. Und wir schenken der Welt jetzt einen freien Code.
Das haben sie jetzt erstmal getan.
Erstmal unter diesem Deckmantel haben sie das gemacht. Vielleicht ist das auch so. Vielleicht ist es einfach die gute Seite von Google und sie setzen sich ja auch für freie Standards ein und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter. Nur, das kann auch nicht eher ernst sein, dass jetzt so ein Codec, der es technisch mit der ganzen H264-Wolke gar nicht aufnehmen kann. Weil wenn er bestenfalls bis Baseline-Profile reicht und heutzutage im Satelliten-Business und im Profibereich, da hast du irgendwie etwa und so weiter.
Ja, es geht auch weg. Und im Web hast du eh Baseline. Mach nur alle.
Der heißt WebM, der Standard. Und dafür ist er gedacht.
Ja, aber wir sind jetzt irgendwie in der HD-Welt. Da kommt HD-Contact und der soll möglichst kleingerechnet sein.
Ja, aber ist das nicht so, dass wenn du... Also ich meine, das Baseline hast du ja selber gesagt, ja, benutzt man ja auch wegen hier mobiler Geräte, oder?
Da hast du was gedacht, ja.
Weil wenn du komplexe Codec-Features benutzt, dann brauchst du halt auch mehr CPU, um die ganzen Geschichten dann auch auszurechnen, die du da in diesem Codec reinschiebst für die ganzen Bewegungsvektoren und was da nicht alles für Voodoo-Magic machen. Das heißt irgendwie, für jetzt erstmal die nächsten zwei Jahre, gibt es halt wahrscheinlich auch einfach nur Baseline auf den mobilen Endgeräten und so weiter. Also ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht super dramatisch, dass es jetzt nur Baseline ist. Das ist immer noch besser als wahrscheinlich Hartz IV 6.3 oder alles was davor so im Webrom fleuchte.
Ja gut, aber es ist total anstrengend, noch ein Codec-Format zu unterstützen. Das ist es einfach. Gerade, wenn du selber Content Provider bist. Ich meine, Google mag sich das leisten können. Ich bin erstaunt, dass sie sich das leisten, weil Storage kostet die auch eine Menge Kohle.
Die schmeißen ja deswegen erstmal nichts aus dem Browser raus oder sowas. Moment, für einen Content-Anbieter, du hast nach wie vor die Wahl, was du einbaust.
Klar, was die Wahl, aber diese Wahl ist ja das Problem. Du musst ja auch dein Workflow darauf einrichten und wenn du zwei Video-Formate vorhältst, dann hast du immer alles doppelt. Doppelte Arbeit, doppeltes Knowledge, doppeltes Kosten, doppelte Tools, doppelter Platz, doppelte alles.
Also im Augenblick gibt es noch keinen Browser, der WebM unterstützt, aber hat 264 nicht, doch Firefox. Aber Firefox hat jetzt auch den Hard 264-Unterstützung nicht deswegen rausgeschmissen.
Firefox macht Flash? Superfreie Browser?
Nee, Firefox kann auch hier Oktiora-Video abspielen und die wollen WebM einbauen.
Ja, sagst du nicht gerade, da habe ich deine Aussagen nicht verstanden. Es gibt keinen Browser, der was nicht...
Ja, nee, das ist doch noch das Thema, und Max Streit geschmissen.
Nein, ich will nur versuchen, herauszufinden, was Googles Intention ist. So, und ich sage einfach nur Folgendes. Jetzt haben sie diesen Move gemacht. Das ist ein Bold-Move, weil sie da richtig viel Geld in die Hand nehmen. Sie haben irgendwie diese Bude gekauft und sie konvertieren ihren ganzen YouTube-Kram. Das ist alles nicht ohne Kosten. Jetzt kann es natürlich sein, dass sie tatsächlich irgendwie da eine Zukunft sehen. Technisch gesehen kann Web-M eigentlich nichts anderes sein, als so eine Art Fallback-Technologie. Weil es ist einfach nicht absehbar, dass ich darauf wirklich... Gerade wenn das Ding besser werden soll, dann hast du diese Patentproblematik wieder. Also wenn du das verbessern willst, das ist nicht aus der Welt.
Aber guck mal, die sind Google, die sind sowohl Technologie-Anbieter als auch Content-Anbieter. Das heißt, zum einen, glaube ich, wollen die was haben, um... Guck mal, ihr MPEG-Alliance, ihr habt da einen lustigen Panzerstellen, wir haben ja auch einen Panzer. Der ist vielleicht noch nicht ganz so gut geschützt wie euer, aber da steht schon mal ein Panzer rum. Wenn ihr jetzt eure Lizenzgebühren zu hoch ansetzt, dann probieren wir mal zu schießen.
Das ist genau das, was ich mir nämlich auch dachte. Dass sie den ganzen Popans nur machen, um einfach in dieser Debatte um MPEG 4 ein Druckmittel einzubauen. Genau, ein Druckmittel.
Das wäre eine Option. Die zweite Option, die ich habe, ist, wenn sie YouTube-Videos anbieten und sie müssen dann irgendwann Lizenzgebühren abdrücken für H264, also sagen, alles klar, für das, was wir nicht anders ausliefern können als H264, hier habt ihr eure Lizenzgebühren. Für alles, was wir können, für unsere Android-Geräte, für die Chrome-User, bieten wir WebM an, weil dann sparen wir richtig fett Lizenzgebühren. Die Variante zu haben.
Ich frage mich allerdings, ob sie da gerade wirklich zahlen.
Noch nicht.
Aber es ist auch da.
Mit YouTube müssen sie ja, glaube ich. Als Content-Anbieter war das nicht. Ich weiß nicht, dieses Lizenzgebühren.
Das ist halt das, was irgendwann mal kommen soll. Das geht aber dann auch nur für bestimmte Mengen und Längen. Und für unter 10 Minuten gilt es meiner Meinung nach eh nicht. Und das ist ja die YouTube-Beschränkung.
Achso, nee, genau. Es war, glaube ich, so, dass du als Verteiler von dem Zeug irgendwie nichts bezahlst, aber für Herstellungen von sowas wie Final Cut oder Premiere oder sonst was. Also wenn du da irgendwie so... Da musst du jetzt schon bezahlen.
Es geht keiner durch. Theoretisch droht es auch für Podcaster, wenn du irgendwie mehr als 200.000 Abnehmer hast, dann musst du dann halt auch noch irgendwas dafür bezahlen. Wo man auch sagen könnte, okay, dann zahlt man halt dafür, aber das natürlich...
Wo man auch sagen könnte, Moment mal...
Was von vielen nicht angenommen werden wird...
Wenn du sagst, hey, 10% meines Kontes liefere ich plötzlich als WebM aus und nicht mehr als MPEG 4 und dadurch bleibe ich unter der 200.000-Grenze, ist doch super für dich.
Ja, also ich will das ja auch nicht. Und ich bin... Ich habe mir was anderes überlegt, okay? Ich habe mir darüber nachgedacht, wie man das Problem vielleicht anders lösen könnte. Und unter Umständen ist WebM da auch ganz hilfreich, eben, wie du so schnell sagst, weil man einfach noch mal einen weiteren Panzer im Zimmer hat. Aber eigentlich wollen alle ein technisch fortgeschrittenes, allseits akzeptiertes, in Hardware implementiertes und von dem kleinsten bis zum größten Gerät skalierendes Super-Framework haben, wo Video, Audio-Codex, Metadaten und so weiter alles mit drin sind.
Lizenzfrei.
Lizenzfrei, kostenlos, für alle zu benutzen. Das ist das, was wir haben wollen.
Auf alle Ewigkeit.
So, und bis auf diese Lizenzsachen gibt es das schon. Heißt MPEG 4. Es ist ein riesen Framework, wo ganz viel Klumpatsch drin ist, mehr als WebM, auch nur im Ansatz abdeckt, weil es im Wesentlichen nur ein Video-Codex und sonst nichts. Plus halt der Audio-Codex, das kommt noch dazu, und ein Container-Format, aber dann ist da auch irgendwie auch schon Ende. Ja, da ist kein MPEG 7 drin, mit irgendwie XML, Metadaten, Schnickes und Gedöns. So, das heißt, das gibt es alles schon. Das einzige Problem ist, es gibt da ein paar Companies, die wollen in den nächsten 20 Jahren, solange diese Patente laufen, Kohle verdienen. Und die haben so eine gewisse Vorstellung davon, wie viel Kohle sie damit verdienen. Klapplos noch nicht so richtig, weil die Adoption ist irgendwie nicht da. Warum ist die Adoption nicht da? Weil es keiner benutzen will, weil die Companies da sind, die Kohle verdienen wollen. Also das irgendwie schließt sich alles gegenseitig aus. Das heißt, auf der einen Seite gibt es die Leute, eigentlich wollen wir das haben, weil wir haben den Schnauz voll von irgendwie 1000 Standards. Wir wollen einfach einen haben und fertig, weil das ist einfach, Video ist einfach zu aufwendig, um da zu viele Standards zu haben. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir die Buden, die wollen Kohle haben für 20 Jahre. Wie lösen wir das Problem?
Google bezahlt einfach.
Alle zahlen. Wir machen Buyout. Wir legen einfach die Kohle zusammen. Wir machen da den großen H264-Flatter-Button.
Wir kaufen Philips, Apple und Microsoft auf.
Ich meine, es ist ja eine klare Rechnung. Die haben doch bestimmte Erwartungen darüber. Man kann in etwa abschätzen, was sie da wohl verdienen würden in den nächsten 20 Jahren. Da macht man dann einen Kompromiss und sagt, okay, alles klar. Ihr würdet aber nicht so viel kriegen, wenn wir da nicht reingehen. Dann kommt hier irgendwie Web-M und Streit. Was zahlt ihr für eure Leuern in den nächsten zehn Jahren, wenn die ganzen kamen? Macht mal einfach mal eine Rechnung auf. Und das ist so das, was ihr vielleicht verdienen wollen würdet. Wie schön wäre es, wenn ihr die Kohle jetzt bekommen würdet?
Und dass dann Google mal 5 Milliarden auf den Tisch legt.
Nicht nur Google, alle.
Flatter.
Alle.
Nee, alle. Das ganze Internet, alle. Wir kaufen uns einfach frei. Das haben wir doch bei Blender auch gemacht. Bei Blender? Ja. Blender, diese 3D-Software, die haben gesagt, geile Software, wir haben eigentlich keinen Bock mehr weiterzuarbeiten, aber gib uns 30.000 Dollar, dann geben wir euch das Ding irgendwie frei. Warum nicht auch mit H264? Ja, also wir würden gerne so und so viel Kohle verdienen. Das ist aber ein bisschen viel. Und dann liegt noch ein drauf und zack und hin und her. Und dann hat man irgendwie eine schöne Software im Internet, mit der man das irgendwie alles aushandelt. Dann macht man irgendwie so eine UNO-Sitzung, wo irgendwie alle dabei sind. Ghana, Tuvalu, alle sitzen da. Tuvalu hat ein großes Interesse an Punkt TV. Irgendwie muss es funktionieren.
Und dann sitzt Merkel in einer Verhandlung über den Preis für einen Videokodik. Na toll.
Ich finde, man muss auch einfach mal ein bisschen breiter denken. Wir kommen irgendwie nicht voran.
Ich dachte ja auch zwischendurch, dass Google einfach sagen könnte, wie viel wollte er denn jetzt? Sagt doch einfach mal eine Zahl. Und dann hier, peng, da ist es.
Es gibt ja auch noch andere Boon-Dikolen.
Man sollte sich einen der Keyplayer aus diesem Patentpool, den es wirklich nicht geht, rauspicken, dem es vielleicht gerade nicht ganz so gut geht, Microsoft, und den dann einfach aufkaufen.
Microsoft aufkaufen?
Nein, nein, also ein dieser Keyplayer da so rauspicken sich und sagen, so, und wenn wir jetzt weiterspielen wollen, dann lasst uns mal gucken. Dann lasst uns alle den Preis senken, oder irgendwie so was, oder?
Ja, Mexican Standard.
Also ich glaube, am Ende würde es die Weltwirtschaft einfach deutlich billiger kommen, diese paar Buden auszukaufen, da einfach eine Rechnung aufzumachen. Das wollt ihr in den nächsten 15 Jahren, 20 Jahren damit verdienen. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie lange diese Patente laufen, aber irgendwann ist halt Schluss. So, okay, lass uns ein Deal machen und dann sammeln wir irgendwie die Kohle und das kriegen wir irgendwie zusammen. So, und dann ist das aber auch gleich frei. Freies in, kann jeder überall, jederzeit kostenlos benutzen, Software vertreiben, die das implementiert, alles ist frei.
Ewige Codec-Kraft.
Ich glaube, da würden einige nicht mitspielen. Sony zum Beispiel. Warum?
Die kriegen Kohle. Die kriegen die Kohle sogar schneller, als sie sie jetzt bekommen würden.
Sie wissen auch, wie viel.
Sie können die Kohle gleich wieder in ihre Entwicklung stecken.
Ich glaube, dass einige Buden dabei sind, denen das zu sozialistisch ist. Das glaube ich total ernst. Unter den Konservativen in Amerika gibt es auch einige, die Open Source generell für den puren Sozialismus halten. Die meinen, dass man ein Kommunist wäre, wenn man Linux benutzt. Ich glaube, das ist eine Einstellung, die gar nicht so unweit verbreitet ist. Wenn ein Sony-Vorstand sagt, wir haben hier mal unsere Anteile an H265 verkloppt und wollen das in Zukunft freieinsetzen, dass dann ein Teil ihrer Aktionäre sagen, ich glaube, da würden auch einige einfach klagen, Aktionäre mit. Es ist eine schöne Vision.
Soll ich mal die Liste durchgeben?
Ich halte sie für realisierbar kurz nach dem Weltfrieden.
Ich weiß nicht, was das Problem ist.
Kurz nachdem das Stadtschluss gebaut wird.
Es geht doch hier nur um Geld.
Es geht nicht nur um Geld.
Doch, die wollen Geld verdienen. Ich meine, guck dir die Firmen an. Apple, DeWu, die Autos bauen. Südkorea, Dolby, die AAC und so weiter drin stecken. Electronics and Telecommunications Research Institute, ist mir persönlich nicht bekannt. Franz Telekom, Fraunhofer Gesellschaft, Fujitsu, Hitachi, Königliche Philips Elektronik, NV, LG Elektronik, die mit den Fernsehern. Microsoft Corporation, Mitsubishi Electric Corporation, NTT DoCoMo, Nippon Telegraphen Telefon Corporation, Panasonic Corporation, Robert Bosch GmbH, Samsung, bitte?
Was haben die denn da reingeschmissen? Akku-Hochschrauber?
Wir können auch gleich die Patent-Pist durchgehen, aber das wird glaube ich nicht ganz so schön. Samsung, Scientific Atlanta Vancouver Company, Zetna Patent Services LLC, Shady Shady, Sharp Corporation, Siemens AG, interessant, Sony, Telefonaktie Bola Get LM Ericsson, also Ericsson, The Trustees of Columbia University in the City of New York, Toshiba Corporation und Victor Company auf Japan. So, da sind sie.
Scientific Atlant ist gleich Cisco, sagt einer.
Was ist Cisco?
Scientific Atlanta.
Wirklich?
Sagt der Chat.
Der Chat lügt doch.
Der im Chat, der das gesagt hat, der heißt Stack Evil.
Und bei VC1 sieht es irgendwie ähnlich aus. Also wenn man jetzt mal so guckt, Microsoft hat es halt auch probiert mit ihrem Codec. Und da ist dann Deo, Dolby, Franz Telekom, Fujitsu, Philips, LG, Microsoft selber, Mitsubishi, Nippon. Also einige, nicht alle. Aber dann noch ein paar andere. TeleNoir zum Beispiel, die waren bei Nippon nicht dabei.
Weitere Beispiele aus dem Patentwesen in dem Appendix zu dieser Sendung.
Ja gut, aber ich freue ja nur darauf hinaus, wie man das hier irgendwie drehen könnte.
Wobei man die Extended Version beherrscht, wie er liest, das Telefon buchfugt.
Schauen wir doch mal, wer, jetzt können wir auch mal gucken, was Apple hier am Start hat. Hier ist nämlich die Patentnummer.
Wann kommt denn hier Fußball eigentlich? Also ich würde ja irgendwann so demnächst auch mal...
Was bist du denn für ein Nerd?
Ja, ich habe dafür nicht Lena geguckt.
Das habe ich schon gesehen.
Guck an, also Apple hat tatsächlich wirklich ganz konkret Patente Using Order Value for Processing in Video Picture. Was ist hier irgendwie von Apple mit drin? Dann die Columbia University hat gleich ganz viele, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9. Dolby hat auch ganz viele. Franz Tete hat so einige. Fraunhofer hat richtig viele. Richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig viele. 3, 4 Seiten lang. Krass. Fujitsu hat auch ganz viele. Philips hat auch so einige. Zwei Seiten.
Das wollen wir aber gar nicht lesen, oder?
Ich will nur wissen, wer hier die Leute sind. Ja, wie toll das wird. Beziehungsweise, wem man hier...
Oh, LG hat ja richtig viel.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir noch eine Weile Flattr für benutzen.
Und Microsoft auch. So viel.
Cross.
Das sind auf jeden Fall viele, viele, viele Patente.
Ich lese gerade, dass es iMovie wahrscheinlich nur fürs iPhone 4 geben wird.
Jetzt nicht ablenken.
Alle Patente meines Portfolios sind glücklich.
Man merkt, die Sendung nähert sich ihrer dritten Stunde. Im Abschluss dieser dritten Stunde. Okay, that's my point. Dirk meint ja im Chat, ich sollte mich freuen über WebM. Ich kann mich nicht so darüber freuen, wenn diese...
Warum nicht?
Weil dieses, weil sich das einfach nicht will ein... Guck mal, die Realität mit diesem WebM ist, es gibt eine einzige Implementierung von einer einzigen Firma, die jetzt gerade mal seit drei Wochen bekannt ist.
Genau, und es werden mehr werden.
So, dieser X200, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Wenn es nicht mehr werden, dann ist es eh ein toter Standard. Dann ist es auch drauf geschissen.
Na, bei Zeora gibt es auch nur eine Implementierung.
Ja, dann werden auf der alle aufbauen, oder wie auch immer. Ja, Zeora ist ja auch quasi, also ich glaube, das kann man durchaus als...
Lies dir mal diesen Blogpost durch.
Aber was gibt es denn außer X264? Also ich meine, ja, es gibt den von Apple, aber X264 ist jetzt ja trotzdem was, die meisten da draußen benutzen, oder?
An freien meinst du jetzt. An freiem Sourcecode gibt es meines Wissens nur X264. Aber es gibt zahlreiche Implementierungen von H264 in Hardware, in Software, es gibt zahlreiche Decoder, die du halt auch nochmal lizenzieren kannst. Also das ist...
Aber wir wollen ja frei.
Genau, man will frei. Das wollen wir haben.
Wir warten uns einfach mal ab. Also ich bin auch total gespannt, aber ich kann überhaupt nicht einschätzen. Also ich...
Es scheint mir ein OKA Codec zu sein. Es steht ein großer Anbieter dahinter. Es steht ein großer Anbieter, dem ich zutraue, dass er Interesse daran hat, dass das ein freier Codec ist.
Ja, das stimmt, ja.
Und dass das für das Google das als Vorteil einsieht, wenn das ein Open-Source-Standard ist und das auch mit ein bisschen Geld durchpeitschen bereit, durchzupeitschen bereit wäre. Und der Rest, der Rest wird sich zeigen. Und wenn wir alle in drei Jahren nur noch WebM haben, dann ist OK.
Also ich bin schon mal sehr gespannt, ob es ihnen überhaupt gelingen wird, das auf Android-Halbwegs-Performan hinzubekommen. Das wird auf jeden Fall schon mal ein interessanter Test werden.
Sie haben doch auch MPEG-4 ohne Hardware-Beschleunigung zum Laufen gebracht und...
Wer? Was?
Android. Google.
MPEG-4 ohne Hardware-Beschleunigung?
Das ist doch im Augenblick... Ich weiß nicht, haben die eine Hardware-Beschleunigung? Also sie können MPEG-4 abspielen?
Das machen die doch nicht in Software.
Meinst du, sie haben da ein MPEG... Also sie machen quasi alles in Software im Augenblick.
Video abspielen? Ich es nicht, keine Ahnung. Das war jetzt einfach nur ins Blaue hineingequatscht. Mensch, als Kinder.
Die bauen doch alle da die selben Steine ein.
Ja, aber bisher hatte ich das Gefühl, dass Android die nicht so richtig nutzt.
Na, sie nutzen nicht im User-Interface die Grafikbeschleunigung als solche. Also sie benutzen nicht die GL-Fähigkeiten der Grafikchips, um ihr User-Interface zu beschleunigen. Blitting etc. Deswegen ist einiges so sluggish gewesen. Das werden sie irgendwann nochmal nachliefern.
Klar, das ist jetzt das, ich wollte jetzt auch gar keine andere Baustelle aufmachen. Wir werden sehen, was aus Web-App wird. Dann können wir uns entspannt zurücklehnen.
Solange es noch nicht da ist, ist eh total entspannt.
Solange es geeignet ist, um beim MPEG-LA ein paar Hühner aufzuscheuchen.
Eure Verschwörungstheorien der ganzen Sache lesen wir dann gerne in den Blog-Kommentaren.
Die wir übrigens nicht zensieren, wie gerne mal behauptet wird, sondern einfach manchmal vergessen, freizuschalten.
Stimmt, das wurde wiederholts Zensur vorgebracht.
Ich war im Urlaub.
Diese Apple-Faschos sind doch alle gleich. Wir müssen erstmal hier Hose runterlassen.
Ich glaube, bisher haben wir wirklich versucht, nur mal klarzustellen, außer Spam noch ist alles freigeschaltet worden.
Ja, manchmal bleibt ja auch ein Kommentar im Spam-Ordner Spam-Dingsbums hängen. Und da man sich den irgendwie auch nicht regelmäßig durchliest, dann ab und zu sich da auch mal so 3000 Kommentare sammeln. Und die liest man dann auch nicht einzeln durch. Und dann kann es auch schon mal sein, dass man irgendeinen, der als Spam qualifiziert wurde, übersieht.
Ja, das kann passieren, aber...
Das kann passieren.
Wir sind da nicht böse und be evil.
Aber wenn wir das nicht machen, dann ist da nur noch Spam drin.
Ja, klar.
Das funktioniert echt überhaupt nicht, ne?
Ohne Archismet wäre das alles tot.
Ohne Archismet und auch ohne alles...
Moderation.
Wie ist das gerade konfiguriert? Gehen auch manche durch, wenn Archismet sagt Ja?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich glaube, wenn du einmal oder zweimal durchgekommen bist, ich glaube, wenn du einmal durchgekommen bist, dann bist du frei. Und ansonsten ist da auch tatsächlich, muss man auch sagen, zu viel so, hey, toller Block-Eintrag, wo ich schon immer mal gelesen habe, hier ist mein Autoteileversicherung, ja, gerade zubehört.
Was sich auch letztens hier Pavil hat mir erzählt, da gibt es jetzt irgendwie so ein neues sozusagen Capture-Plugin für WordPress, wo du nicht irgendwie Capture eintippen musst oder 2 plus 4 rechnen musst, oder sagen musst, welcher Tag ist, sondern da hast du so einen HTML-Slider, den du einfach so von links nach rechts slidest, sozusagen, ja, und wenn du das erfolgreich geschafft hast, ist das sozusagen die Human Interface Verification.
Das ist immer geil, also so wie Slide to Unlock?
So genau wie bei Slide to Unlock, dass du halt irgendwie so einen JavaScript-Slider da immer kurz von links nach rechts schiebst.
Das hätte ich gern, würde dann von Apple abgemahnt werden wegen App-Appetite. Aber das ist natürlich echt geil.
Aber das kann man auch automatisieren.
Klar, kannst du alles automatisieren. Spanien-Gespiel kannst du auch automatisieren. Macht bloß keiner.
Bots tun sich ja schon schwer, JavaScript so abzuformatieren und abzuschicken, dass es tut.
Slide-Tokument.
Das ist geil. Wenn du das mit JavaScript hast, die Idee ist, du lädst ja den Artikel, dann baut er mit JavaScript on the fly diesen Slider überhaupt erst auf die Seite. Und dann musst du halt den sliden. Und dann passiert natürlich ein Callback, den der Bot jetzt nicht unbedingt ahnen kann. Fand ich ganz nett, aber ich weiß leider nicht, wie es heißt. Von daher kann ich jetzt keinen Link. Aber wenn ihr das wisst, dann... Gibt es da eine Demo? Das muss ich gleich noch kurz klicken.
Geht das auch auf dem iPad? Das wäre jetzt...
Ja, eben. Genau. Das wäre jetzt für Touch-Interfaces natürlich auch genau das Richtige.
Können wir das bitte gleich einbauen?
Erst wenn es... Warte mal, wo ist hier die Demo? Wo ist hier die fucking Demo? Das ist so geil, das hat so...
Aber diese Seite kommt dann auch erst mal mit so einem CSS-Overlay-Spamteil. Das sieht sogar genauso aus wie auf dem iPhone.
Ach, das ist also ein Screenshot da, ja?
Kann man hier kommentieren?
Wo? Ich will haben. Also das sieht ja schon mal schick aus. Auf dieser Abun-Seite gibt es das. Ja, oh, wie schick.
Warte mal, welche Seite ist das?
abun.com, da ist das auf jeden Fall drauf. Also es ist da verlinkt in diesem Slide to comment.
So, plugin is based on...
So, jetzt mach ich hier mal einen Test. Na, ich wollte auf derselben Seite das...
Das ist ja... Nee, die benutzt das.
Ich bin doch auf der falschen Seite.
Nee, klick mal da auf dieses Abun. Da ist das, dieser Link.
Also hier geht's leider nicht. Also das ist...
Echt?
Es geht nicht auf dem iPad.
Wie schlecht.
Das muss man dann echt noch einbauen. Aber dann kann man's echt sich geben. Check.
Unlocked. Fancy.
Aber wenn das nicht auf dem iPad geht, ist es natürlich voll für den Fuß.
Das ist schick. Das kann man ja auch erweitern für das iPad. Ist ja alles kein Problem.
Slide to a finished show.
Genau. Das war's, Leute. Wir haben uns nicht gestritten.
Ich hab aufgepasst.
Ich hoffe, es war nicht so langweilig. Noch eins für Deo. Okay, aus den Streams, aus die Maus. Bis bald.